monsieur le ministre chers collègues
après avoir procédé mardi dernier à
l'audition du ministre de l'Intérieur et
des autres maèes et à la discussion
générale sur le projet de loi pour
contrôler l'immigration améliorer
l'intégration nous entamons aujourd'hui
l'examen des articles et des amendements
alors pour faire un point avant que ne
commence la commission 1675 amendements
ont été déposés et j'ai déclaré
recevable 225 amendements pour défaut de
lien avec le texte 35 l'ont été par mon
collègue président de la commission des
finances au titre de l'article 40 il
s'agit là de ratio tout à fait
habituelle et même presque moins sévère
que la lopmie que nous avions étudié
j'ai reçu plusieurs contestations
d'irreabilité donc j'ai répondu
normalement à l'ensemble des collègues
qui m'ont écrit je suis je dois vous le
dire parfois trop souple dans dans ce
contrôle puisque je vous renvoie à la
lobgie où j'avais accepté des
amendements modifiant le Code de
procédure pénale car un article
prévoyait sa ratification par ordonnance
et c'est le Conseil constitutionnel qui
a censuré très largement plusieurs
articles de ce texte je vous renvoie à
la lecture de sa décision en
l'occurrence modifier le czda ne
suffisait pas euh je vais donc répéter
ce que je vous dis habituellement
d'abord le lien ne s'apprécie pas avec
le titre du projet de loi qui est en
l'occurrence très large mais avec le
contenu du projet de loi initial du
gouvernement il s'apprécie pas davantage
par rapport aux articles additionnels du
Sénat c'est la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel là encore qui exige un
lien avec les articles du projet de loi
adopté en conseil des ministres alors
certes le conse le Sénat avait largement
élargi ce ce projet de loi j'ai donc
tenu compte des modifications qui
avaient été les siennes pour inclure les
les amendements qui se rattachaient à
ces articles en revanche pour tout ce
qui ajoute en additionnel pour tout ce
qui complète hors des champs de ces
articles ça n'est pas une surprise je
vous l'avais également rappelé dès les
précédentes commissions pour une
meilleure indication de ce qui'est la
jurisprudence de la euh recevabilité au
de l'article 45 moi je vous renvoie à la
note que l'on édite c'est une coutume
qui a été prise par ma prédécesseur
madame yelbron pivé et qui vous a
diffusé systématiquement avant l'examen
de Cha texte voilà j'espère avoir
répondu à toutes vos questions à ce
titre et on va pouvoir commencer les
amendements en commençant par celui de
Monsieur
brun mais je crois qu'il n'est pas
défendu
voilà donc le suivant euh c'est un
amendement de suppression du 1er a qui
le défend pour le groupe de la France
insoumise personne ne le
défend le premier a allez-y madame
Martin
bonjour Merci beaucoup de me donner la
parole on va rester un son un certain
nombre d'heures
ensemble et sans nul doute de la
discussion va-t-il jaillir la lumière
comme on disait il y a longtemps nous
voulions simplement faire quelques
commencer par quelques commentair et
donc proposer cette suppression de
l'article 1emière A euh dans la mesure
où il nous apparaît que que ces
fondements sont à caractère tout à fait
xénophobe comme ça vous voyez on va
commencer en beauté tout à fait
xénophobe dans la mesure où les
étrangers l'étranger est toujours
présenté comme la figure de l'Autre qui
vient se confondre avec celle du
délinquant voire celle du terroriste
nous considérons que tout ça n'a aucun
sens euh que cela ne correspond
évidemment pas à la réalité y compris la
réalité chiffrée si l'on parlait
d'arrivé importante de personnes
étrangères sur le sol français on va y
revenir et que par principe il n'est pas
acceptable de de jouer sur ces
catégoriesl pour des raisons que nous
exprimons d'ailleurs depuis le mois
d'août et qui sont à caractère
complètement politicien ce qui n'est
bien sûr pas acceptable quand on parle
d'un sujet aussi sérieux de notre point
de vue si l'on veut parler de migration
et si l'on veut en faire une loi il y
aurait au moins euh deux choses à mettre
en jeu la première c'est la coopération
à l'échelle européenne et la seconde
serait de créer des conditions d'accueil
dignes ne serait-ce que digne ce qui
résoudrait de nombreux problèmes par
ailleurs si j'avais un troisème point à
ajouter j'ajouterais qu'il faut aussi
anal les raisons pour lesquelles ces
migrations existent et ces raisonsl ne
vont pas s'éteindre monsieur Lucas alors
vous voyez que les balances des micros
sont pas tout à fait les mêmes que dans
notre salle de commission initiale donc
vous pouvez baisser d'un ton ou alors on
baissera le volume sonore monsieur Lucas
merci monsieur le Président pour notre
part nous contestons tant le l'idée de
quota de quantification que l'idée
d'avoir un débat farfelu absurde tous
les ans au Parlement faire croire que
l'immigration en tant que telle peut
être l'objet d'un débat d'une discussion
est est absurde si on peut évidemment
débattre de de de l'accueil débattre de
l'intégration l'inclusion on ne peut
rien sur les migrations qui sont un
phénomène humain social climatique
depuis en climatique de de plus en plus
et que ces débats et ces quotas ne
changeront rien d'un yota à la volonté
de femmes et d'hommes de fuir la guerre
la misère ou le désordre climatique le
résultat c'est qu'en 30 lois en 40 ans
vous navez fait les gouvernements
successifs n'ont fait que deux choses
enrichir les passeurs qui indexent leur
t arrive sur la difficulté à passer les
frontières et augmenter le nombre de
cadavres qui flotent dans la
Méditerranée ou gèle dans les Alpes moi
je conteste l'idée qu'il y aurait une
juste part de la misère du monde à
accueillir je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
traiter des questions aussi importantes
par des tableaux comptables et pas par
des valeurs par des principes d'autant
que et je termine par cela monsieur le
Président tout cet argumentaire cet
article procède de l'idée que nous nous
vivrions sous la menace d'une submersion
migratoire et je mets évidemment des
guillemets à ce terme or c'est faire fi
d'une réalité qui est que l'essentiel
des migration re pays sud et donce la
misère du monde elle n en réalité pas du
tout à nos portes cet article nous fait
perdre du temps il fait perdre du temps
au débat public il fait perdre du temps
à la réalité et à nos principes de
rationalité il convient donc de le
supprimer dans de breev
délaiis Madame
Fillon je rejoins les arguments invoqués
par par mes deux
collègues généralement les propositions
visant à mettre en place des des côas
migratoires ressortent à peu près euh
tous les 10 ans d'ailleurs pas toujours
dans les meilleures périodes politiques
euh ni les meilleures périodes social
climatique euh et elle vise à chaque
fois à euh tenter de faire intégrer euh
l'idée d'une submersion d'une vague d'un
trop plein d'immigrés je crois qu'au
cours de de ce projet de loi euh que les
exilés ont à redouter que celles et ceux
qui sont à leur côté ont aussi à à
redouter et bien bien nous voulons au
groupe GDR mais je le crois aussi avec
les députés des autres groupes de gauche
pouvoir apporter un autre récit celui
qui se base sur une rationalité sur la
réalité de ce que sont les parcours
migratoires mais aussi sur la nécessité
d'un accueil digne la les politiques de
de quôas migratoire ce n'est même pas
nous qui qui le disons mais je lorsque
en 2008 Nicolas Sarkozi a tenté
d'impulser à nouveau cette idée et bien
il y a le dans dans le cadre du Conseil
constitutionnel une commission présidée
par par Pierre Mazo qui avait tranché la
question en disant que les quotas
seraient irréalisables ou sans intérêt
et je crois que les personnes qui les
collègues qui déposent ce type
d'amendement le savent bien et qu'en
réalité et bien le seul objectif de de
cet amendement est de pouvoir expliquer
que l'immigration serait le le fruit de
tous les problèmes nous contestons
absolument cette logique et je crois
qu'au travers des propositions ou des
oppositions que nous nous menons au sein
de l'Assemblée sur des questions
économiques ou climatiques et bien nous
arrivons à le
démontrer madame brocard Monsieur
balanan Merci monsieur le Président
euh donc également pour le groupe modem
un amendement de suppression sur cette
sur cet article alors pourquoi euh tout
tout simplement parce que son écriture
la façon dont il est tourné les données
qu'il demande les les les points qui
l'accroche ne nous semble pas
satisfaisant et et nous pose un certain
nombre de problèmes presque
philosophiques et et politiques ça a été
dit par mes collègues mais je le dirai
pas de la même façon queeux parce que je
ne suis pas non plus complètement en
accord avec eux déjà sur la question
d'accueillir la misère du monde il faut
pas qu'on confonde tout dans notre pays
on a l'asile et l'asile est un bien
inaliénable de notre pays un un un
comment dire
un un un dispositif qui découle de nos
accords internationaux des accords de
Genève de 1951 et c'est quelque chose
sur lequel il ne faut pas toucher mais
dans notre pays on ne se pose jamais la
question d'avoir une politique
migratoire et de se dire qui on
accueille comment on accueille en quel
nombre on accueille alors en ce sens un
débat pourrait être intéress mais on ne
demande pas un débat au Parlement je
crois pas que c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne éventuellement il peut y
avoir un débat une concertation et un
choix qui est fait par les
parlementaires de dire qu'est-ce que
veut la représentation nationale mais
tel qu'il est écrit là ça serait presque
un article qui imposerait de nous
donner serait presque une injonction à
donner un un un définir des quotas c'est
pas c'est pas l'idée l'idée c'est pas de
définir des des quotas l'idée c'est
d'avoir une politique migratoire
juste euh qui répond à des
problématiques économiques dans notre
pays des problématiques aussi humaines à
certains moments par rapport à la
question de de l'asile mais certainement
pas comme il a été écrit parce que il
comme il est écrit effectivement il
laisse penser que dans notre pays il y
aurait une vague migratoire ce qui n'est
pas le cas du tout monsieur le
rapporteur oui merci Monsieur le le
Président je je vous salue toutes et et
tous pour ce cette entame de l'examen de
nos amendements concernant ce texte
important euh d'abord je crois que cet
article 1er a ne ne mérite pas les excès
d'indignation et et les mots que j'ai pu
entendre il y a quelques quelques
minutes de la même façon monsieur Lucas
que je ne vois pas pourquoi nous
refuserions le débat sur la question
migratoire de façon générale pourquoi
l'Assemblée nationale nen débattrait pas
nous le faisons à l'instant même autour
d'un texte de loi il me semble tout à
fait normal que nous puissions le faire
en revanche il il y a deux dispositions
j'allais dire hérité du Sénat qui ne
sont tout simplement pas conformes à la
Constitution et d'ailleurs le rapport
masau que elja fossillon vous évoquez
quelques instants rapport de juillet
2008 lui-même indiqué un que l'Assemblée
nationale ne pouvait pas s'imposer à
elle-même de débattre ni pour demain ni
pour après-demain et ni d'ailleurs sur
la question migratoire que sur aucune
autre question de façon générale ce qui
fait que l'alinéa 2 de l'article 1er a
n'est pas correcte lorsque il est écrit
les orientations plurann annuelles font
l'objet d'un débat annuel ça n'est pas
possible et de la même façon que le
rapport Mao souligner et c'est l'alinéa
cette fois-ci
28 du l'article 1er a que il n'est pas
possible pour l'Assemblée nationale de
déterminer les chiffres de l'immigration
il faut pour cela réviser l'article 34
de la Constitution certains d'entre nous
considère qu'il faut réviser l'article
34 ça c'est un autre sujet donc moi ce
que je vais vous proposer dans les
prochaines minutes et permettrait
monsieur le Président d' avoir une
intervention un peu plus longue sur ces
amendements pour anticiper les
discussions que nous aurons dans
quelques instants c'est de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait une possibilité de
débat pour respecter notre Constitution
et de faire en sorte que le Parlement ne
détermine pas les chiffres mais qu'il
débattent d'objectifs d'objectifs qui
seront chiffrés d'objectifs qui seront
par conséquent indicatifs et moi-même
j'apporterai des amendements en ce sens
dans quelques instants mais nous pouvons
débattre et quelle est la logique de
l'article 1er a c'est de débattre sur
les orientations qu'un gouvernement
celui-ci pour l'instant un autre
peut-être demain présenterai des
objectifs qui soient quantifiés
attention avec deux limites extrêmement
fortes la première nous ne pouvons pas
débattre de chiffres concernant l'asile
ce serait violer nos engagements
conventionnels deuxièmement sur le
regroupement familial nous pouvons
débattre d'objectifs indicatifs mais ils
ne seront pas fermés parce que là aussi
il y a la Convention européenne des
droits de l'homme un nombre par
conséquent précis ne pourrait pas être
adopté ou débattu ça ne serait pas
conforme en revanche sur les titres visa
étudiant sur
l'immigration économique il y a tout à
fait la possibilité de débattre et ce
sera d'ailleurs l'occasion pour le
gouvernement et pour la majorité
présidentielle d'assumer ses ambitions
nous sommes favorables à l'immigration
économique nous l'avons dit à plusieurs
reprises 51000 titres l'année dernière
nous sommes favorables à des visas
étudiants c'est une force d'attractivité
c'est la capacité notre pays à rayonner
c'est aussi l'avenir de la Francophonie
et donc nous y sommes extrêmement
favorables 108000 titres l'année
dernière au titre des visas étudiant et
donc avis défavorable monsieur le
Président pour ces amendements parce que
je crois que nous pouvons débattre je
dis bien nous pouvons nous avons pas
l'obligation et nous devons le faire
dans le cadre des règles
constitutionnelles qui doivent s'imposer
à nous merci alors j'ai CIN inscrits
monsieur nagelen 6 merci monsieur le
Président cet article qu'est-ce qu'il
dit certes il détermine dans son alinéa
28 des des quotas mais regardons les les
27 premiers alinées et en fin de compte
il permet d'avoir énormément
d'informations qui sont nécessaires quel
type de visa sont sont accordés ça nous
permet d'avoir des informations
extrêmement précises et encore une fois
je pense que le but est pas de
dévaloriser le Parlement mais au
contraire de le mettre en valeur et cet
article il perd permet justement que le
Gouvernement présente au Parlement des
informations claires et précises pour
que demain nous soyons en capacité de
légiférer d'ailleurs si on regarde bien
c'est dans son
alinéa 26 et 27 que sont joints au
rapport du gouvernement les
recommandations et les observations de
l'OFI et de l'OFPRA qui sont en réalité
les les références dans dans ce domaine
donc je vois pas pourquoi on on
s'amuserait à supprimer quelque chose
qui euh permet d'avoir des informations
supplémentaires ou en tout cas au
parlementaires que nous sommes d'avoir
des informations
supplémentaire madame
Genevard merci monsieur le Président
alors cette demande de de plafond
migratoire c'est une demande constante
des républicains vous le savez nous
sommes parfaitement conscients que cela
euh résulte d'une mesure
constitutionnel c'est donc un sujet que
nous aborderons dans quelques heures
dans quelques jours puisque vous savez
que le 7 euh décembre prochain nous
examinerons notre proposition de loi
constitutionnelle néanmoins cet article
me semble des plus utiles parce que la
France a euh tout à fait loisir de
choisir qui elle veut accueillir sur son
sol c'est légitime c'est parfaitement
légitime elle veut passer d'une
immigration subie à une immigration
choisie
la France veut réduire nous voulons
réduire la pression migratoire c'est un
objectif que les républicains affiche
très clairement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle cette demande de rapport est
tout à fait pertinante il s'agit de
rappeler notre intransigence dans la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
de rappeler que nous voulons une
procédure d'asile qui soit efficace et
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
demande de supr
de cet article nous paraît tout à fait
infondé et et même
regrettable demander des informations
sur les procédures sur les titres de
séjour délivrés sur le nombre
d'étrangers admis au au titre de
différentes procédure nous semble tout à
fait normal il faut savoir de quoi nous
parlons lorsque nous parlons
d'immigration il faut connaître les
chiffres il faut connaître les les
éléments objectifs qui nous permettent
de déterminer ensuite des politiques
pertinente et
efficace monsieur cabrat
oui merci monsieur le Président bon la
question avec ce débat de la statistique
du chiffre du
quota serait très intéressant s'il n'y
avait pas une contestation permanente
des chiffres que nous donne la recherche
nous avons les éléments factuels et vous
refusez d'écouter ces éléments factuels
vous inventez un mirage qui est la
submersion migratoire pour certains ça
sera le grand remplacement alors que les
quotas ont été par l' gooliste même par
un goliste monsieur Mazo quand même
prouverver que c'était inutile et à mes
collègues macronistes sur le rapport sur
les quotas qui avaient été donné par
Pierre Mazo je tiens à rappeler que donc
Christophe Castaner ministre de
l'Intérieur en 2019 avait appuyé
lui-même le rapport Mazo je vais vous
lire une partie hein le rapport estimait
qu'établir des quotas par nationalité ou
par région du monde pourrait contredire
le principe d'égalité entre tous les
citoyens tous citoyens et citoyenne
quelle que soit leur nationalité qui est
un principe garanti par la Constitution
elle conclua en constatant que les
quotas sont contraires à nos engagements
internationaux et à nos principes
constitutionnels je pense que il y a pas
besoin de créer des faux débat parce que
au final vous contesterez les chiffres
chers collègues de la droite et
l'extrême droite vous nous direz que ces
chiffres sont faux vous nous direz que
il y a toujours une part cachée vous
refusez d'écouter les scientifiques les
associations les chercheurs François
erand qui n'arrêtent pas de nous dire
que c'est un mensonge la submersion
migratoire vous refusez de les écouter
donc ce débat qui commence maintenant il
faut le mener sur des basses scènes
sortir des faux chiffres que vous allez
donner par exemple de dire que il y a 7
% de qtf qui sont exécutés et que c'est
moins qu'en Allemagne je vous rappelle
que c'est 16000 au qtf exécutés en
France 26000 en Allemagne les
statistiques c'est comme les fleurs on
leur fait dire ce qu'on veut donc
maintenant essayons d'avoir dès le
départ un dialogue raisonné supprimons
les éléments de ce texte qui sont
inutile et chers collègues de la
macronie faites un effort au moins RESPE
ce que disait votre ancien ministre de
l'Intérieur Christophe Castaner
monsieur valallot
oui merci Monsieur le le président
beaucoup de choses ont ont déjà été
dites on a un certain nombre d'obstacles
constitutionnels et conventionnels à
l'établissement des quotas c'est vrai du
droit d'asile et pour reprendre les mots
de Madame jeunevard un droit d'asile
efficace c'est celui qui protège les
populations suppliciées menacé dans un
certain nombre d'autres pays que
répondrait-on aux Afghans si nous
devions première nationalité accueilli
dans l'accueil dans le dans l'asile si
nous devions mettre des quotas et
renvoyer ceux qui sortirai de ces quotas
dans des pays où ils seraiit soumis au
pire au pire servic je pense en
particulier aux Fas GAM que
dirionons-nous au titre du droit
constitutionnel du droit conventionnel
de l'atteinte au regroupement au
regroupement familial j'aurais moi aussi
cité à la fois le rapport Mazo peut-être
pas monsieur Castaner euh pour appuyer
la la la démonstration peut-être
François erand qui avant ce débat a fait
l'effort de rendre disponible à chacun
les chiffres de l'immigration et il est
important madame jeev le disait de
savoir de quoi on parle c'est une
lecture que je lui recommande vivement
par ailleurs j'ai regardé ce qui se
passait dans d'autres pays en Allemagne
au Canada au Danemark au Royaume-Uni en
Suède en réalité il n'y a nulle part de
quotat de portée générale et
juridiquement contraignante il y a de
temps en temps en effet des objectifs
c'est le cas du Canada et d'ailleurs ces
objectifs sont régulièrement dépassés
vous dites que tout à l'heure vous
proposerez monsieur le rapporteur une
sorte d'amendement de repli mais qui est
une amendement de jésuite dans le
respect du principe de de laïcité qui
évidemment n nous gouverne mais j'ai
bien compris l'espèce de d'interstice
que vous essayez de trouver ou de points
prétendument d'équilibre entre les uns
et les autres vous avez raison de dire
vous avez raison de dire que l'Assemblée
nationale peut débattre de tout ce dont
elle se saisit ou dont le gouvernement
la saisirait au titre de l'article 50-1
ce que nous avons fait en octobre 2022
tous les chiffres que nous demandons
sont en réalité parfaitement disponible
ce sont des statistiques publiques et il
est loisible à chacune et à chacun de
les demander en particulier au ministre
de l'Intérieur monsieur
Lucas merci monsieur le rapporteur
général quand même vous n'avez pas
l'impression qu'on débat tout le temps
de l'immigration dans ce pays enfin on
est sur la 30e loi immigration en 40 ans
le débat public est englouti sous les
thèmes et les termes de l'extrême droite
depuis depuis des
décennies maintenant et moi j'entends
madame jeunev je me dis que à lire ce
que ce qui nous vient du Sénat on a plus
besoin d'un plancher humaniste que d'un
plafond migratoire dans la situation
dans laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui et
de rappeler quelques quelques vérités
encore une fois la la encore une fois la
la la la discussion sur quoi
porte-t-elle sur quelle vérité euh tout
établit que les Françaises et les
Français dans les différentes enquêtes
d'opinion surestime considérablement le
nombre d'étrangers vivant dans notre
pays le débat public est à ce point
englouti sous les contevérités les
mensonges les peurs les fantasmes de
l'extrême droite qu'on a réussi à créer
une situation de peur là où il n'y a pas
de fait réel qui viennent en attester je
vous ai parlé des migrations entre pays
du Sud qui sont l'essentiel des
migration je pourrais vous parler
également du présupposé d'appel d'air
qui consiste à dire de votre part que
une politique plus inclusive une
politique plus fraternelle constituera
un appel d'air aucune réalité
statistique historique géographique tout
ce que vous voulez rien nulle part à
aucun moment dans notre histoire n'a
démontré que ce fantasme de l'appel
d'air existait donc encore une fois de
quoi parle-t-on vous voulez monsieur le
rapporteur général qu'on ait des grands
débats à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
très bien euh je je constate là que vous
peut-être remettez en cause le le 493
compulsif du gouvernement mais je le dis
s'il faut débattre des vrais sujets
ayons un grand débat chaque année sur
l'école de la République ayons un grand
débat chaque année sur les services
publics ayons un grand débat chaque
année sur la réalité climatique et sur
la façon dont n nous affrontons ce qui
est le plus grand péril de notre
histoire et de et de l'humanité voilà
des sujets qui pourraient mériter qu'on
y consacre chaque année mais je fais
confiance au successeurs de Monsieur
Darmanin euh peut-être il y en a-t-il
dans cette salle qui chaque année nous
proposerons comme c'est le cas depuis 40
ans une loi immigration pour que chacun
puisse avoir son texte avec son nom euh
dénonçant les mêmes fausses causes et
produisant les mêmes non non effet
madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président alors
on savait que ce texte allait nous
réserver quelques surprises mais là on
voici une bonne premier amendement
étudié un amendement quasiment identique
déposé à la fois par l'anupes et par le
modem alors nous nous sommes absolument
défavorabl à la suppression de cet
article qui propose l'instauration d'un
débat annuel moi je suis comme 75 % des
Français et je consid considère en effet
que la question de l'immigration doit
faire l'objet d'un débat on doit donner
la parole au peuple et si on ne la donne
pas au peuple au moins il faut que le
Parlement débatte de ce sujet ensuite ce
rapport aurait le mérite de de préciser
des données ou qu'on essaie de nous
cacher ou alors qui reste assez flou moi
je me souviens il y a quelques jours
pendant l'une de nos auditions on a
appris par Madame la Ministre clobel que
le coût d'un mineur non accompagné
pouvait varier entre 60000 et 100000 €
alors qu'on avait entendu il y a
quelques temps encore que ce coup
pouvait varier entre 40000 et 50000 €
donc on a besoin d'avoir des précision
sur ce type de sujet et ensuite bien sûr
nous contestons bien sûr ce qui est
écrit dans le texte à savoir l'obsession
politique permanente antimigrant de la
droite dans notre pays macronie comprise
alors là je vais juste rappeler quelques
chiffres pour indiquer que la macronie
n'est pas du tout anti-immigrationniste
elle est même pro immigration un seul
exemple les titres de séjour 316000 ont
été délivrés l'année dernière et 1600000
titres de séjour ont été délivrés entre
2017 et 2022 c'est considérable pareil
pour les demandes d'asile une
augmentation exponentielle et je ne vous
parle même pas des coûts engendrés par
exemple par l'aide médicale d'État donc
pour nous la macronie est profondément
immigrationniste et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous allons combattre de toutes
nos forces ce texte et enfin monsieur
Guillaume gouffi Valente
oui merci Monsieur le le Président je
pour vous dire que le groupe Renaissance
votera contre ces amendements de
suppression nous n'avons pas peur du
débat sujet nous sommes pas fa blocat
mais nous n'ons pas peur du débat et que
celui-ci soit structuré par ailleurs je
suis assez surpris du fait qu'un certain
nombre de collègues qui déposent ces
amendement de suppression par ailleurs
derrière nous dépose un certain nombre
d'amendements justement pour structurer
ce débat et structurer ce qui pourrait
être dans le rapport qui donnerait
naissance à ce à ce débat par ailleurs
sur je reviens sur le nombre de lois
monsieur Lucas vous avez évoqué le fait
qu'on ait un certain nombre de lois au
cours des dernières années celle-ci se
justifie et a des apports nous vous
attendrons quand il s'agira des
questions de régularisation des
questions de porter à 18 ans
l'interdiction de présence des mineurs
dans les cras la question de la prise en
charge des cours de français
c'est-à-dire de l'amélioration de nos
politique d'intégration et peut-être que
dans les années qui viennent oui nous
aurons à revenir encore sur des lois qui
viendront améliorer encore nos
politiques d'accueil d'intégration
refixer peut-être des dispositifs qui
visent à un moment à dire ce que nous
faisons à partir du moment où quelqu'un
se met en dehors du respect des règles
de notre République c'est important
enfin pour répondre au front au
rassemblement national juste rappeler
qu'il faudrait éviter toute confusion
durant les jours que nous allons passer
ensemble entre migration régulière et
migration irrégulière s'il vous plaît ce
que vous venez de faire juste à
l'instant enfin Monsieur Laurent
marcangéi merci monsieur le Président
écoutez le groupe horizon votera contre
ces amendements de suppression je vois
pas
là de quoi être totalement ébourifé
avoir un débat dans dans le cadre des
discussion parlementa comme cela se
passe dans de nombreuses démocraties je
pense pas que nos amis canadiens soient
à la titre d'une d'un système
particulièrement antidémocratique et
raciste bien au contraire je pense par
ailleurs que ce que vous avez complété
monsieur le rapporteur général avec
l'amendement que vous proposerez tout à
l'heure nous éloigne du risque de
censure constitutionnelle donc il y a
aucun problème à ce que nous ayons un
débat qui soit raisonné et raisonnable
concernant l'immigration et sur tout
autre sujet mes chers collègues tout
autre sujet dans le
Parlement monsieur le ministre et a
prends votre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les les
parlementaires peut-être quelques mots
d'abord pour dire que je me range
évidemment à la proposition faite par le
rapporteur génal dans sa modification de
l'article 1er a évidemment d'un avis
défavorable aux amend de suppression
pour pour plusieurs raisons répondant
ainsi peut-être au aux parlementaires
qui sont exprimés d'abord sur les quotas
il y a plein de pays en effet qui fixent
des quotas indicatifs et je vourais dire
d'ailleurs à Monsieur Valot que il n'est
pas prévu de ce que j'ai lu de la loi
effectivement imaginé dans cet article a
part le Sénat que l'asile y est concerné
on a bien exclu l'immigration familiale
et l'asile des côas il s'agit donc de
côas économique ou étudiant ce qui
correspond à me semble-t-il ce que
pourrait faire le le gouvernement ce qu'
d'ailleurs il a décidé de faire déjà je
vous le rappelle depuis le comité
terministériel à l'immigration à
l'intégration du 9 novembre 2019
rapporté par mon collègue Christophe
Castaner sous la présidence édard
Philippe qui avait acté le débat annuel
au Parlement qui permettrait de fixer
annuellement des cibles et des quotas
qui ne seraient pas limitatifs qui
correspond donc à l'engagement du
président de la République voilà 4 ans
preuve d'ailleurs que nous faisons pas
une loi immigration chaque année je
rappelle qu' nous faisons une loi
immigration tous les 6 ans dans la
majorité monsieur Lucas c'est quand vous
étiez en responsabilité que vous faisiez
une immigration tous les ans parce que
je rappelle que Monsieur Hollande a fait
une loit d'immigration tous les ans et
demi alors que Monsieur Macron a fait
une tous les 6 ans la dernière étant
j'ai une pensée évidemment pour lui
celle de de Gérard colon donc les quotas
en tant que tel sont à la fois un
objectif gouvernemental voulu par le
Président de la République et exclu
l'asile et exclu l'immigration familiale
le deuxième sujet je voudrais répondre
au rassemblement national aucun pays au
monde ne fait de quota prescriptif et et
surtout lorsque vous êtes en
responsabilité nationale je dis à Madame
Diaz vous augmentez l'immigration
puisque madame mélonie en 2023 vient de
prendre un décret qui augmente les
quotas d'immigrés légaux madame Mame qui
admis sur le territoire italien alors je
vous rappelle le décret pris par Madame
mélonie et vos amis 136000 personnes
accepté en 2023 151000 en 2024 165000 en
2025 c'est vra que Madame mélonie n'est
pas Madame mélonie ne confond pas comme
vous immigration légale et illégale
comme ça très bien dit par Monsieur
goufiercha donc effectivement les quotas
quand ils existent en effet peuvent
aussi augmenter l'augmentation permettre
l'augmentation d'immigration légale
c'est le cas de votre amie madame
mélonie en Italie il n'y a pas jeux dire
à Madame jeunevard il n'y a pas de pays
à notre connaissance il y a des quotas
prescriptifs au sens où on s'arrêterait
à un niveau mais on entend le le débat
et je pense que le gouvernement n'a rien
a effectivement à à cacher chaque année
à fixer des quotas y compris sur 3
années parce que ça peut être dynamique
et se les donner comme indication et
voir pourquoi on les a dépassé pourquoi
on a obtenu pourquoi on a été en dessous
c'est les raisons qui évoqué le
rapporteur général je veux bien prendre
un engagement puisqueeffectivement ce ne
serait pas constitutionnel selon le
professeur Mazo comme bien sûr on le
sait très bien vous l'avez dit vous-même
notre Constitution que le président de
la la République comme il l'a déjà fait
chaque année et je m'engage au nom du
gouvernement que ce soit inscrit donc
nous sommes en responsabilité nous
puissions justifier euh de la politique
migratoire de notre pays dans un débat
au Parlement que demandera le ou la
première ministre avec en effet c'est un
point très important l'idée qu'on peut
justifier euh des des des montants
effectivement de visa accordés et si la
loi ne peut pas le retenir et évidemment
j'espère que votre commission adoptera
l'amendement du rapporteur général le le
gouvernement peut l'organiser et il
prend l'engagement au moment où je le
fais je referit évidemment dans
l'hémicycle je vrais juste terminer par
dire euh que d'abord s'il y avait une
réforme constitutionnelle on en parlera
le 7 décembre madame la députée Genevard
il nous semble que sur la question de
l'asile quoi qu'il arrive la réforme
constitutionnelle ne pourrait pas
s'appliquer puisqu'il faudit changer
aussi le préembule de 46 la déclaration
droit de l'homme de 1789 et et la CDA
j'ai bien compris que c'était le
principe de la réforme constitutionnelle
la question se pose peut-être
différemment sur l'immigration familiale
mais la question de de l'asile par
nature ne peut pas être soumise à à cota
et puis dire peut-être au député de la
France insommise qui a évoqué des
chiffres assez étonnants puisqu'il
appelé à la recherche et à l'exactitude
sur les eqtf alors les derniers chiffres
que nous avons tous collectivement
connus publiquement et et qui ne
souffrent pas de contestation puisqu'ils
sont des données d'Eurostat qui sont les
seuls disponibles pour les comparaison
pour les reconduites à la frontière la
France en 2022 c'est 14235 éloignement
l'Allemagne c'est 13135 je sais pas vous
avez été chercher 25000 donc vous avez
doublé là parce que ce que vous demandz
en exactitude aux autres appliquez-le à
vous-même c'est 13135 c'est 1000 de
moins alors qu'ils ont deux fois plus
d'immigration irrégulière la Suède 10490
l'Espagne 4515 et l'Italie 2915 il est
vrai que nous avons un taux
d'application des ETF qui est faible
mais qui est malgré tout le plus fort
d'Europe bien sur les amendements de
suppression qui vote
pour qui vote contre ils sont rejetés
amendement 1657 monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit de l'amendement que j'ai il y a
quelques instants c'est de faire en
sorte que le débat puisse se faire
chaque année ne soit pas une obligation
j'ai expliqué les raisons de cet
amendment il y a quelques minutes
l'identique monsieur gouff Valente
monsieur le Président amendement
travaillé avec le rapporteur est donc
identique monsieur de la porte oui donc
si je je comprends en fait l'intérêt de
cet amendement c'est à la fois de
dévitaliser l'article en disant que il y
aura peut-être un débat et peut-être pas
de débat mais c'est surtout de faire en
sorte qu'il a un rapport qui soit remis
au Parlement si je comprends bien votre
intention monsieur boud avec un certain
nombre d'indicateurs par exemple le
nombre de personnes ayant eu des
autorisations de travail le nombre de
personnes ayant été admises au titre du
regroupement familial mais alors
j'aimerais que vous m'expliquiez si il
doit y avoir potentiellement un débat au
Parlement sur un rapport remis au
Parlement avec toutes ces éléments là en
quoi c'est différent de ce qui est déjà
dans le droit actuel c'est-à-dire
l'article L
111-1 qui exista jusqu'en 2021 qui a été
modifié par la loi du 1er mars 2019 à
l'article 2 qui se voyait par un rapport
transmis annuellement au gouvernement
euh et qui au Parlement par exemple et
qui comportait exactement la même chose
c'est-à-dire les étrangers deis au titre
du regroupement familial le nombre
d'étrangers on obtenu le statut de
réfugié et cetera voilà donc
expliquez-moi en quoi vous allez
révolutionner les choses voilà et où le
rapport sachant que par ailleurs depuis
2021 du coup il y a plus ce rapport
monsieur léomand et bien il aura fallu
42 minutes très exactement pour que tomb
les masques
puisque vous venez en l'espace de 40
minutes de valider un amendement du
Sénat qui propose enfin un article du
Sénat qui propose de de de faire une
fultitude de choses sur l'immigration et
notamment d'ajouter les quotas et puis
monsieur le ministre dans votre réponse
vous faites le concours avec le
rassemblement national en disant mais
regardez madame mélonie comment elle
fait elle fait des elle augmente
l'immigration et d'une certaine manière
vous dites moi je vais faire mieux que
Madame mélonie en matière d'immigration
vous avez donc commencé en l'espace de
42 minutes à faire le concours sur
l'immigration avec la droite et
l'extrême droite et vous avez dévoilé
votre stratégie qui divise d'ors et déjà
votre propre majorité puisque à
l'intérieur de votre majorité il n'y a
pas d'accord sur ce premier article je
trouve que vous commencez ce débat sur
l'immigration d'une manière qui est
extrêmement intéressante et
enrichissante voilà donc ce dont on va
parler pendant des jours et des jours
alors que vous nous disiez même qu'il
n'y a pas assez de débat sur
l'immigration oui que vous nous disiez
qu'il n'y a pas assez de débat sur
l'immigration on va parler pendant des
jours de savoir quels sont ceux qui vont
faire le mieux dans la lutte contre
l'immigration vous ne voyez
l'immigration que comme quelque chose
contre quoi il faudrait lutter vous ne
voyez pas l'immigration comme quelque
chose qui peut apporter des choses à
notre pays et je crois qu'il y a dans
cette salle un certain nombre d'entre
nous de députés qui euh ont des parents
ou des grands-parents qui sont nés
ailleurs que sur le territoire hexagonal
et qui à la fin font des magnifiques
députés de la République française du
moins magnifique pour ceux qui
continuent à défendre les valeurs de la
République française car je vois qu'un
certain nombre déjà au bout de 44
minutes sont en train de s'en écarter de
manière assez sévère madame
Genevard bien merci merci monsieur le
Président de deux remarques
d'abord pour
regretter cet amendement qui
va malgré le caractère onodin que vous
vouliez lui conférer modifier
profondément ce qu'a souhaité le le
Sénat puisque d'une
obligation qui permettrait de
reprendre possession de notre destin
migratoire vous en fait une
faculté qui sera exécutée ou pas selon
le bon vouloir de l'exécutif donc ça
veut dire que le Parlement qui pouvait
par cet cet article reprendre main et
prise sur une politique migratoire qui
échappe totalement à la représentation
nationale qui est subie qui n'est pas
décidé qui n'est pas voulu vous en
refaites une une faculté aléatoire comme
un peu ces débats sur l'immigration que
vous nous avez annoncé et qui n'ont eu
aucun impact je crois que plus que
jamais quand on regarde les chiffres
on mesure la nécessité de limiter
l'immigration et de poser ces quotas
migratoires je rappelle qu'il y a il y
avait en 2012
2610000 permis de séjour titre de séjour
lorsque Nicolas Sarkozi a quitté
l'Élysée il y en a aujourd'hui
3830000 soit une augmentation de 70 %
dans une décennie et si on y rajoute les
chiffres de 2023 on n'est pas loin
d'avoir doublé on sera pas loin d'avoir
doublé le nombre d'étrangers présents en
France de façon légale de façon légale
sans compter ceux qui sont en situation
illégale vous avez vous-même évoqué
autour de 700000 on est sans doute
autour d'un million le nombre
d'étrangers en France deuxème remarque
et je voudrais sur le troème point vous
avez évoqué le rapport Mazo qui pointe
légitimement la question de la
constitutionnalité c'est pour cela que
nous débattrons DESS mercredis j'en
serai le rapporteur le texte
constitutionnel qui
mercredi alors madame Diaz puis monsieur
balanan et je suis désolé pour les
autres orateurs on aura C inscrits donc
on passera au vote ensuite après le
réponse de notre rapporteur madame Diaz
merci monsieur le Président alor
aujourd'hui ce sont 74 % des Français
qui rejettent la politique que le
gouvernement mène en matière
d'immigration si cet amendement était
validé ça voudrait dire que la majorité
prendrait la liberté de débattre ou pas
d'un sujet éminemment important dont on
ignore les critères de sélection donc
euh si cet amendement est voté c'est pas
74% de mécents que vous aurez c'est
peut-être 80 ou 90 %. nous nous
considérons que cet amendement est
dangereux parce qu'on prend le risque de
ne pas débattre et les Français les
Français qu'est-ce qu'ils vont penser
ils vont se dire qu'est-ce qu'on nous
cache pourquoi on ne veut pas débattre
les chiffres sont-ils mauvais les
chiffres doivent-ils nous alerter
l'immigration coûte-t-elle à ce point
cher et donc en prenant la liberté de de
pouvoir faire un débat ou de ne ou de ne
pas pouvoir faire un débat finalement je
pense que vous entretenez la suspicion
et nous au rassemblement national nous
considérons que les Français ont le
droit de savoir parce qu'il s'agit de il
s'agit de leur pays il s'agit de leur
argent donc nous vous demandons de ne
pas être fâché ni avec le débat ni avec
la démocratie ni avec le Parlement donc
nous voterons contre cet
amendement monsieur
balanan merci monsieur le président euh
c'est c'est intéressant effectivement
monsieur léoman a raison les certains
masques tombent mais faut pas tout
mélanger monsieur léoman pas tout
mélanger c'est pas parce que c parce
c'est pas parce qu'il y a des voix
divergentes dans la majorité que c'est
nécessairement un débat que nous devons
pas avoir alors sur la question du débat
et sur la question de de de la façon
dont il était écrit par les sénateurs
qu'il y ait un débat oui c'est
nécessaire ça c'est sûr parce que si
aujourd'hui on a 74 % des Français qui
peut-être rejeterait la politique
migratoire en France c'est parce qu'on a
aucun jamais cadré qu'est-ce qu'est une
politique migratoire dans un pays
j'entends monsieur sooti dire tout à
l'heure bah oui il faut des quotas mais
si vous dites monsieur sooti que vous
admettez qu'il faut des quotas vous
admettez aussi que dans ce pays on a
sans doute besoin d'avoir une m des des
des flux étrangers qui viennent dans
notre pays qui s'installent dans notre
pays qui peut-être embrasseront le
destin de la France et deviendront
citoyens ou peut-être d'autres
retourneront dans le leur pays après un
temps après avoir travaillé durant de
nombreuses années il faut effectivement
que il faut effectivement que nous
posons ce ce débat mais que nous le
faisons sereinement et là les cadres du
débat tels qu'ils sont partis on est
entre les outrances de l'extrême droite
et les outrances de l'extrême gauche
dans quelque chose qui nous nous
embarque mal je crois que les français
contrairement à ce qu'on croit ont une
vision bien différente de ce que vous
dites madame Diaz par exemple les
Français disent aussi que ils acceptent
acte parfaitement le fait d'avoir des
gens qui viennent dans notre pays et qui
viennent travailler dans notre pays
alors oui sans doute qu'il nous faut
revoir complètement la façon dont nous
gérons ces sujets et c'est aussi le
sujet de de ce
texte le rapporteur avant que nous
votions oui merci monsieur le Président
mais pour un état quel qu'il soit
choisir sa politique migratoire c'est un
acte de souveraineté pourquoi le
contester mes chers collègues et la
souveraineté n'empêche pas la solidarité
confè le droit d'asile bien sûr à
l'évidence vous dites madame Diaz 74 %
d'abord nous ne sommes pas la Safra ici
nous sommes des responsables politiques
intéressant mais si je devais regarder
les enquêtes d'opinion je constaterai
que beaucoup de français semble partager
les objectifs de ce projet de loi les
chiffres là aussi sont relativement
clairs quant à Monsieur choti vous vous
vous dites dans la même phrase si je
peux me permettre à la fois que vous
regrettez que mon amendement tout en
reconnaissant que le rapport
Mazo Poa l'inconstitutionnalité de
l'obligation pour un parlement de
s'obligé à lui-même pour l'avenir de
débattre donc c'est une réalité constitu
je vous confère d'ailleurs je vous
réfère pardon à la décision du Conseil
constitutionnal du 20 novembre 2003 qui
précisément a indiqué qu'il n'appartient
pas au législateur qu' n'appartient pas
au législateur d'imposer par avance au
gouvernement nous aux instances
parlementaires compétentes de
contraintes relativ à l'ordre du jour de
chaque ass assemblé ça ne passerait pas
les fourches codin du Conseil
constitutionnel raison pour l'appel cet
amendement ne remet pas en cause la
nécessité je réponds à Monsieur de la
porte de débattre mais nousallons pas
débattre dans les conditions que vous
avez indiqué d'abord c'est l'article
50-1 c'est le chiffre est relativement
précis si ce sera un débat article 50-1
celui-ci si Monsieur de la porte et par
ailleurs je vous indique simplement que
la la la nouveauté que nous acceptons du
Sénat c'est de débattre d'objectifs
chiffrés quantitatif ce sera indiqué
totalement dans l'article prier c'est ça
l'innovation nous acceptons avec le
Sénat de considérer que il n'est pas du
tout comment dire incroyable hallucinant
que un un gouvernement Vienne avec ses
projections ses objectifs
quantifié indicatif devant le Parlement
qui en débat et qui arrête le cas échant
une position qui peut même voter parce
que c'est un débat 50-1 c'est tout à
fait
possible monsur le ministre oui en
quelques mots redire peut-être à
Monsieur le Député que le grand
changement indépendamment du fait que le
gouvernement une nouvelle fois je le
redis en attendant d'éventuelles
réformes constitutionnelles s'engage
chaque année à parler d'immigration bien
évident avec le Parlement la grande
différence avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et les informations que
pouvez avoir c'est que le gouvernement
ne donne pas ces objectif plurannuel
pour obtenir ces objectifs économiques
de visatudion d'ailleurs il se discute
on constate d'ailleurs que partout où il
y a des quotas partout il y a une
augmentation finalement de cet objectif
d'immigration y compris dans l'Italie de
madame mélonie et d'ailleurs je le redis
à à Monsieur sioti peut-être qu'il était
pas là tout à l'heure quand on a fait le
premier débat c'était l'idée de dire
qu'il n'y a pas un pays ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas le faire mais il y a pas
un pays au monde où il y a des quotas
prescriptifs au sens où on ne les
dépasse pas en revanche qu' a des quotas
indicatifs notamment dans le domaine
économique et vis étudiants et discuter
pourquoi on atteint on atteint pas on a
décidé de dépasser et rendre compte
devant le Parlement ça me paraît
intelligent de plannuel donc je veux
redire que nous corrigeons si jeose dire
le fait que le Parlement ne peut pas
s'opposer s'imposer lui-même des débats
pour le fait que le gouvernement le fera
chaque année et que l'indication de la
politique migratoire comme l'a défini
monsieur balanan de gouvernement ce qui
manque sans doute dans nos discussions
migratoire qui s'agisse de baisse
d'augmentation de stabilité se fera
également chaque année si vous adoptez
cet amendement sur ces amendements
identiques qui vot
pour qui vot
contre
attendez
attendez qui non mais je sur ces
amendements identiques qui vote pour
qui vote
contre oui c'est pour ça que je vérifie
ceux qui ne sont pas dans la commission
peent pas
voter
27 ah oui donc ok très bien donc ils
sont adoptés
c'est le ah si ils sont ah si ils sont
adoptés
oui ce sont les ressortissanss du GR
Piot qui avaient voté alors que vous
nêtes pas membre de la commission
monsieur nelen vous ne pouvez pas voter
je crois que Monsieur sint vous aviez V
monsieur le Président je n'ai pas levé
la main ce sont mes deux collègues qui
ont levé la main et je pourrais voter
qu'à partir de maain mais j'avais pas
levé la main d' donc ils n'ont pas levé
la main sur le le vote si ils ont levé
la main les deux donc pour pour voter
pour l'amendement non contre
l'amendement monsieur ah non ils ont pas
voté la main la deème fois Monsieur si
vous avez peut-être faut savoir ce que
vous faites hein parce que si vous metes
le le groupe s'est positionné contre et
moi je de collègues
l'ontevé le
oui oui bah oui vous ferez ferez
l'élection annuelle madame madame Martin
le 209 il est pas défendu le
100 monsieur Lucas
merci Monsieur
le ilut il faut recomter
je ve
pas fendez pas je je vais le défendre
monsieur le Président il y avait
simplement un brois qui m'empêchait
de savez que je suis sensible au
bruit non mais cet amendement il vise
encore une
fois il y a effectivement monsieur le
Président une confusion là et un tumulte
qui naît du fait que qu'il y a une
incertitude sur le résultat du vote
précédent ce qui ce qui rend l'exposer
de mon amendement un peu compliqué vous
comprendrez inacable il fautter on pe
alors soit vous le défendez soit vous le
défendez pas mais sinon passe au suivant
je je je défends mon amendement monsieur
le
Président je je défends j'essaie dans
dans conditions de
calmeend donc donc je je je me saisis
monsieur le Président du micro qui m'est
tendu pour vous suggérer que nous
revotions parce que là je peux pas
manifestement continuer à exposer
amendement alors qu'on sait pas si le
précédent était voté ou pas monsieur
rapporteur votre
avis mon avis sur l'amendement oui oui
bien sûr monsieur Lucas moi je suis
assez favorable je suis assez favorable
s'il vous plaît est-ce que je peux juste
donner au moins l'avis si ça ne vous
dérange pas monsieur de la porte je suis
prêt à donner un avis favorable il y a
un problème d'écriture dans votre
amendement vous vous vous dites vous
écrivez le débat au Parlement ne peut
avoir lieu sans restitution préalable du
rapport mentionné le Parlement de la
même façon qu'il ne peut pas s'obliger à
débattre pour l'avenir ne peut pas
s'interdire de de débattre si vous
deviez corriger pour la séance cette
cette expression je pourrais reprendre
votre amendement donc plutôt retrait de
façon à ce que pour la séance nous
puissions
intégrer alors vous attendez monsieur
nagelan monsieur
Vallot monsieur le Président je va
pas ça suffit c'est monsieur nagelen qui
a la parole ça suffit monsieur N c'est
vous qui avez la parole bien sûr merci
monsieur le Président juste juste pour
dire on va cl on va clore le débat
là-dessus euh j'avais levé la main pour
prendre la parole sur l'amendement
précédent vous m'avez fait signe qui
avait déjà eu cinq orateurs donc j'ai
pas pu m'exprimer si j'avais pu
m'exprimer j'aurais explicité qu'on
était contre cet amendement donc au
moins ça aurait été clair
malheureusement on n' pas pu le faire du
fait de la séance qui n'a pas euh
transmis à temps en effet le notre
papier de switch de commission cétait
qu'à partir de demain que je pourrais
intégrer la commission c'est pour ça que
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas voter et sur
les cinq que nous sommes du groupe lot
il y en a deux qui peuvent voter Olivier
a et Michel Castellani pour aujourd'hui
et et donc les deux s'étaient
positionnés contre cet amendement donc
je pense que cé important de c'est
important de et ils ont voté ils ont
levé la main donc c'était juste pour
clarifier les choses c'est important de
le dire si si vous votez pour ça veut
dire pour en fait quand vous levez la
main au moment où vous votez pour ça
veut dire pour vous l'avez fait j'en
suis désolé monsieur
vot
peut-être
peut-être défendre l'amendement de mon
collègue Benjamin
Lucard en faisant une suggestion c'est
que si nous devions
redéposer l'amendement pour revoter en
séance que vous en acceptiez la
recevabilité pour la
séance dire simplement que vous daignez
la possibilité de la transmission
préalable d'un rapport au Parlement ilra
pas échapper que pouram examiner un
certain nombre de textes financiers il y
a des délais extrêmement
précis extrêmement précis de
transmission on n'examine pas le le
PLFSS sans l'annexe 9 n été le vendredi
précédent l'examen transmis au Parlement
donc qu'on puisse transmettre au
Parlement préalablement en débat le
rapport demandé par Monsieur Luca me
paraît tout à fait fondé en droit
monsieur lu merci jeousr aux amendement
du président Vallot monsieur le le
Président le ministre a lors de notre
dernier entretien c'était son audition
la semaine dernière évoquer un passé qui
nous est commun dans des organisations
de jeunesse et je regrette de voir que
vous répercutez ici un certain nombre de
méthodes que nous avions l'habitude de
reproduire dans les conseils nationaux
pour éviter des votes potentiellement
gênants en empêchant qu'on puisse là
revoter dans la transparence et le calme
moi j'ai tourné la page de cette époque
et de ces pratiques assez peu compatible
avec le nouveau monde que vous défendez
aujourd'hui je crois que là on devrait
pouvoir revoter dans de bonnes
conditions pour savoir si l'amendement
est majoritaire l'amendement précédent
et majoritaire ou pas dans la commission
des lois alors Monsieur Lucas j'apprécie
cet aveu à postérior un peu tardif de
vos méthodes de tricherie om MJS bravo
je vous en félicite pour ce qui me
concerne j'ai fait deux votes j'ai
compté les voix deux fois deux fois j'ai
constaté que l'amendement était
majoritaire j'ai pris même le risque de
le faire deux fois voyez-vous et donc
j'en suis désolé il a été rejeté pour le
vôtre je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté
l'amendement 2 n'est pas défendu
l'amendement
537 monsieurin merci monsieur le
Président même si très Franch franement
je ne sais pas si je dois défendre cet
amendement puce qu'on a quand même deux
collègues du groupe lot qui ont
manifesté clairement leur volonté que
leur vote soit pris en compte peut-être
que dans la confusion et vous avez
certainement raison ils n'ont pas levé
la main mais s'ils n'ont pas levé la
main c'est parce que étant en fond de
salle très franchement on entend très
mal le moment où il est demandé de voter
pour ou de voter contre et dès la fin du
scrutin ils ont demandé à ce que leur
vote soit pris en compte je regrette
qu'il ne le soit pas ce sont des députés
qui ont été élus tout comme vous mon
amendement lui est un amendement d'appel
euh pour monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui cible le rapport annuel
sur les orientations de la politique
d'asile d'immigration et d'intégration
l'article l1231 du Code de l'entrée du
séjour des étrangers et du droit d'asile
nous dit que chaque année avant le 1er
octobre le gouvernement dépose devant le
Parlement un rapport sur les
orientations pluri-annuelles de la
politique d'asile d'immigration et
d'intégration ce rapport il est
important il est particulièrement cette
année puisque nous allons avoir des
débats longs et et complets sur sur le
sujet de l'immigration or ben ces
rapports ils n'ont pas été mis à la
disposition de la représentation
nationale ni pour 2022 nous ni pour 2023
il nous prive donc d'un certain nombre
de chiffres qui ont quelque part un
caractère officiel et qui devrait
pouvoir venir alimenter nos débat donc
nous allons dans quelques instants
étudier tout un tas d'amendements qui
demandent de de créer de nouveaux
rapports qui demandent de fournir de
nouveaux chiffres et bien avant cela
nous nous aimerions déjà que les
rapports annuels qui sont déjà prévus
par la loi et par les textes et bien
soit fourni à la représentation
nationale monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci Monsieur le le président ce
sera un avis défavorable mais sur le
fond euh le rapport de 2021 a été
communiqué celui de 2022 je laisserai
monsieur le ministre répondre mais il a
il a signalé au Sénat lors des débats en
séance que la publication serait serait
prochaine et donc moi je ne peux inviter
en effet que l'exécutif à pouvoir
respecter les délais de publication
alors Monsieur léomand et monsieur le
Président afin de calmer un petit peu
les esprits j'ai une proposition à vous
faire qui me semblera de nature à mettre
tout le monde d'accord l'article 44 de
notre règlement permet qu'on ait un vote
par scrutin lorsqu'il est demandé par un
diè au moins des membres de la
commission je pense qu'il y a plus d'un
diè des membres de notre commission qui
préférait qu'on ait un vote par scrutin
sur les amendements identiques 1657 et
1541 et je pense qu'on pourrait tout
simplement pour revenir au calme faire
un vote par SCR SC sur ces amendements
et donc monsieur housoussin
oui je pense que effectivement en tout
cas par scrutin ou non le fait de
clarifier les votes serait plutôt
quelque chose de positif sur
l'amendement en question monsieur bouer
me dit que le rapport 2021 a été fourni
tout à fait he moi je regrette qu'on n
pas ceux de 2022 et 2023 alors on nous
dit qu'il y a des délais mais finalement
ça doit être ça devait être fourni pour
octobre 2022 on est quand même en
novembre 2023 donc ça ça a quand même un
délai qui est qui est très long et puis
bah ces rapports il devaient documenter
les débats qu'on a aujourd'hui donc
quand on nous dit ils arriveront plus
tard c'est intéressant mais du coup on
peut pas s'appuyer sur ces chiffres pour
les débats d'aujourd'hui c'est quand
même un vrai problème que le les
chiffres et plus d'un an de retard
monsieur le ministre non dire à Monsieur
le Député que je comprends son
interrogation comme j'ai dit au Sénat de
rapporteur général je me suis engagé à
le faire simplement ne confondons pas
tout monsieur le député 2023 on peut pas
vous rendre le rapport l'année n'est pas
finie bon donc on peut pas aller plus
vite que la musique la question est de
savoir c'est quand est-ce qu'on peut
rendre un rapport sur les chiffres
complets etvidés par une statistique qui
s'appelle Inc qui est indépendant notre
pays voilà c'est c'est la statistique
publique c'est une indépendance qui met
9 mois et demi à rendre les statistiques
offici au ministère d'intérieur ce qui
fait que là le débat parlementaire
autour de la loi immigration a lieu
c'est pas moi qui fixé la date c'est vos
assemblée plutôt au mois de novembre
donc je me suis engagé devant le Sénat
qu'avant la séance publque de
l'Assemblée nationale puisqu'au 1er
décembre vous aurez comme chaque année
ce rapport il est vrai et je le déplore
moi-même qu'on ne peut vous fournir les
chiffres complets statistiques que
diriez-vous si on les ait pas fait
valider par l'INC vous me diriez bah
vous les trafiquer voilà donc là au
moins ils seront validés par Inc comme
chaque année fourni autour entre le 20
novembre et le 1er décembre et je prends
mon engagement monsieur le député
qu'avant le débat en séance publique
donc avant me semble-t-il même la PP
constitutionnelle proposé par l'lr vous
aurez ce débat complet je mets au voix
qui vote pour qui vote contre rejeté 593
Monsieur
servard Merci monsieur le Président en
fait c'est un amendement rédactionnel
mais qui est important c'est
sboliquement parce que nous avons fait
voter il y a quelques mois une
disposition mais qui ne concerne pas je
dirais qu'un texte mais qui concerne en
général toutes les écritures publiques
en
France le terme métropole est connoté
négativement et pour cela il suffit
d'aller dans le petit Robert ou le petit
larous et qu'est-ce qu'il dit il dit
métropole est un territoire faisant
référence à ses colonies à ses
territoires extérieurs or vous le savez
les départ ement français ne sont plus
colonies depuis 1946 et utilisé et là je
m'adresse pas seulement au législateur
mais à l'Assemblée nationale et à tous
ceux qui produisent des textes utiliser
le terme métropole et un peu à chaque
fois une piqûure douloureuse d'une
histoire qui est sensible pour nous et
donc je propose que ce terme métropole
soit substitué pour mettre le terme
hexagone voil monsieur le rapporteur oui
je soulligne simplement le rapporteur
serva avait déposé un amendement
équivalent en mai 2023 dans le cadre de
la loi de programmation militaire et qu'
avait fait dans les même terme
l'unanimité alors de l'hémicycle avis
favorableis favorable monsieur le
ministre favorable et je au député
servac que dans un texte qui concernera
soit l'outreemire soit la simplification
diverse des procédures législatives on
essaiera de changer l'intégralité des
codes dans lequel ces disposition évoque
le mot métropole en
Hexagon je le mets au voix qui vote pour
contre adopté le 1537 monsieur
brin merci monsieur le Président merci
de m'accueillir dans la commission nous
souhaitons ajoutter à cet article 1er
a cette l'alinéa qui permet de mettre en
lumière la difficulté que rencontre
beaucoup d'étrangers lorsqu'ils
cherchent à prendre un rendez-vous en en
préfecture aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
constate un engorgement des tribunaux
administratifs notamment s'agissant des
référés mesures utiles où finalement on
demande tribunaux administratif d'avoir
un rendez-vous en préfecture car la
préfecture n'est pas capable de le
donner vous connectez à minuit et à
minuit 5 il y a plus de rendez-vous sur
le site de la préfecture nous
souhaiterions que les préfets soient
incités y compris financièrement dans
leur prime de fin d'année à permettre
l'élargissement des créneaux disponibles
afin que ces rendez-vous soient délivrés
dans les temps monsieur le rapporteur
oui je suis favorable sur le fond je
préfère simplement l'amendement 971 de
votre collègue untermer qui me semble
être plus clairement rédigé donc je vous
propose de le retirer au bénéfice du de
l'amendement de votre collègue monsieur
valallot dire que les les deux
amendements sont sont complémentaires
comme le sont Philippe brin et C
luntermerer
euh vous dire simplement que on est dans
cette situation d'Absurdie complète où
il est plus facile de rencontrer son
député que rencontrer euh les chefs de
bureau des étrangers dans les
préfectures nous en faisons le le le
constat et cela conduit un certain
nombre de personnes à saisir les
tribunaux administratifs qui sont
contraints d'assurer le planning des
préfectures les préfectures elles-même
une fois condamné déplaçant des
rendez-vous qu'elles avaient accordés à
des étrangers pour satisfaire au besoins
de la justice ils le font pas toujours
avec diligence puisqu'il y a des
asreintes parfois que les préfectures
sont obligées de payer je sais que c'est
un gouvernement qui est attaché au
pilotage objectifs à la performance à
l'évaluation des politiques publiques et
il se trouve que dans le corps
préfectoralqu j'ai parilleurs servi il y
a une part de la rémunération de fin
d'année qui se fonde sur des objectifs
et parmi ces objectifs la proposition de
mon collègue Philippe BR est que les
délais dans lesquels on est reçu en
préfecture au service des étrangers et
bien puisse constituer un bonus ou un
malus dans la rémunération des préfets
je vous assure que on trouvera des
novations organisationnelles pour y
satisfaire
alors Monsieur le Ministre non mais dire
dire à Monsieur dire à Monsieur V qu'il
a parfaitement raison c'est déjà dans
rémunération on pourrait d'ailleurs en
tirer davantage davantage pour le
service public si vous n'z pas supprimé
4000 emplois la préfecture en 5 ans donc
n'hésitez pas à soutenir les
augmentationseffectifs qu'on a décidé
pour la première fois en 20 ans dans les
préfectures si vous aviez pas supprimé
les ETP on pourrait peut-être mieux
accir les personnes en effet mais c'est
ce qu'on ESS de
réparerors leure effectivement vous avez
raison monsieur le ministre madame
Fillon
oui le le groupe GDR soutiendra C cet
amendement et et le préfère au 791 et là
il ne s'agit pas de préférer un député
plutôt que l'autre évidemment mais
simplement parce que euh celui-là me
semble beaucoup plus incitatif en
réalité puisqu'il touche à la prime des
préfets mais c'est surtout pour pouvoir
dire à quel point dans les préfectures
aujourd'hui et particulièrement dans
dans les services réservé au aux
étrangers et bien les attentes sont
indignes et pas simplement à la suite du
covid puisqu'il y a des situations qui
perdurent euh ce qui est vrai c'est qu'à
la suite du covid il y a des personnes
qui se sont retrouvées sans rendez-vous
et qui ont alors qu'ils étaient
régularisés depuis de nombreuses années
qui ont perdu leur travail d'autres à
qui ce sont les prestations sociales qui
ont été coupées pendant plusieurs mois
ces situations-là sont évidemment moins
nombreuses qu'à la sor du covid mais
elle continue de l'être pour les
naturalisations il y a des départements
où en ce moment c'est 2 3 4 ans
d'attente uniquement pour que le dossier
commence son instruction ce n'est pas
acceptable au regard de de plein
d'objectifs mais simplement pour le
premier des objectifs d'efficacité de
nos services publics et je crois que
l'idée de conditionner la la prime de
fin d'année des préfets a des objectifs
et bien contraints mais aussi
réalisables et à mon avis de
à défendre monsieur le rapporteur mais
il fallait voter la lopmie par
conséquent pour celles et ceux qui ne
l'ont pas
fait il fallait le faire puisque non je
parle pas du groupe socialiste je je
connais leur vote et je m'en souviens
très bien je l'ai noté quelque part dans
un carnet mais simplement sur la lopmie
nous avons voté des crédits pour
notamment l'administration territoriale
et les préfecture comme jamais depuis 25
ans comme jamais près de 900 millions
d'euros c'est absolument considérable et
donc notamment sur les services des
étrangers il y aura mais je pense que
monsieur le ministre pourra le confirmer
d'ailleurs il l'avait signalé en
discussion générale mardi dernier 400
emplois supplémentaires les réponses
elles sont de plusieurs ordres la
première chose c'est évidemment des
hommes et des femmes des hommes et des
femmes qui sont budgetés deuxièmement
c'est l'administration numérique des
étrangers en France qui a été mise en
place à partir de 2021 corrigé y compris
par une décision du Conseil d'État je
vous le rappelle on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler et qui s'applique
progressivement et la troisième solution
elle nous vient c'est comme ça du Sénat
c'est la volonté d'une instruction à
360° de façon à ce que la personne
puisse de premier abord et dès sa
première demande être examiné au regard
de la la possibilité de tous les titres
de séjour qui sont accessibles au regard
bien sûr de sa situation n'est pas un
sujet que nous ignorons en revanche le
côté facécieux de l'amendement qui
m'avait pas échappé sur la prime
accordée au préfet et intégré avec la
loi n'est pas correcte dans un texte
législatif raison pour laquelle je
préfère la l'amendement de notre
collègue cécileer 971 donc je vous
demande de bien vouloir retirer s'il
vous plaît je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est
rejeté non il a pas de règlement par
contre vous avez la parole pour le
325 le 325 monsieur Houssin vous le
défendez c'est Madame Diaz c'est Madame
Diaz non non le 325 madame
madame Diaz vous défendez pas
l'amendement
non non et en
plusé non d'abord je vais parevenir sur
le voie parce que je vous avais en plus
vous avez accordé 5 voix supplémentaires
parce av confé deux fois les élus RN
voyez pour compter égalité en comptant
lot donc ça c'est hors de question que
je revienne sur le vote j'ai un des
compes qui était précis sur ce sujet en
revanche je vous demande de défendre
votre amendement sinon il considér comme
pas défendu est-ce que vous défendez le
325 monsieur le Président je comprends
pas pourquoi vous refusez qu'on active
l'article 44 par aujourd'hui je vous
demande de défendre votre am mais
attendez mais vous faites pas ce que
vous voulez en fait je ce que je veux je
préside justementit prés revient pas à
s'exonérer du règlement de l'assemblé
mais très sincèrement nous dem comprends
vous contestiez toutes les règles
précisursur président r Je vous
demandefend vre amend pas que je vous
indque n'est pas
défendu amendement suivant le
23 madame blanc je redis la même chose
que mon collègue monsieur le Président
je suis
désolé l'article 44 a été demandé par
mon collègues sur sur les votes en
commission et on demande un scrutin donc
je je dis exactement la même chose que
que mes collègues alors
emblementtional il neend pas 10% de la
Commission du reste du reste du reste
sur les votes au scrutin public c'est
avant avant les amendements et donc non
vous demandez un scrutin qui a déjà eu
lieu pour tous les amendements mais vous
êtes 5 vous êtes 5 donc vous n'êtes pas
suffisamment nombreux je
vous monsieur le rapporteur général
défavorable monsieur le Président on
vous48 est-ce qu'il y a un défenseur du
348 madame
Abad merci Monsieur le merci monsieur le
Président je défends une série
d'amendements de
maèue qui souci que de femmes dans le
monde soit privé du droit à
l'éducation on sait l'éducation est
essentielle pour la construction
l'émancipation de chacun et les
restrictions d'accès que subissent
certaines femmes dans certains pays
comme l'Afghanistan le Niger ont un
impact dramatique sur leur vie et
conditionne toute toute leur vie
assignation à domicile jusqu'au mariage
forcé il y a quatre amendements il y a
quatre amendement sur cet article
1a le 348 qui demande donc que que les
demandes de visa étudiants accordé en ou
refusé en fonction du genre en précisant
si les demandeurs subissent des
discriminations d'accès à l'enseignement
dans leur pays soit rajouté à ce rapport
le 349 je me permets comme ça je ne
reviendrai pas dessus à l'alinéa 8
demande la de préciser le nombre de
réfugiés ayant repris une formation
scolaire ou accéder au marché du travail
en fonction de leur genre le 350 à
l'alinéa 9 sur les mineurs isolés pris
en charge à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
en fonction du genre toujours dans dans
ce rapport et le
351 euh qui largement demande d'intégrer
les dimensions éducatif et l'égalité des
genres dans le rapport que le
gouvernement présentera au Parlement je
vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président quelques
quelques précisions pour notre collègue
Abad l'étudiant par définition lorsqu'il
dépose sa demande de visa auprès
notamment de camp Campus France avec les
les organismes consulaires il ne
mentionne dans intention le motif qui
est qui est le sien que la volonté de
débuter d'engager des études à
l'étranger pas les raisons
éventuellement intimes qu'aurait le
caséfiant subi pour cette raison et pas
sur le fond vous l'aurez compris donc
défavorable sur l'article sur le
l'amendement 348 en revanche sur les
autres amendements qui concernent la
question du genre en particulier je je
vous demanderai de bien vouloir les
retirer au bénéfice de l'amendement de
notre collègue Céline Calvez qui mieux
placé dans l'article 1er a en fera une
condition générale pour l'ensemble des
données de l'ensemble du rapport qui
sera remis par le gouvernement afin que
nous puissions en
débattre madame avaD
dit les quatre sont retirés alors vous P
donner les numéros s'il vous
plaît9 ok très bien
merci le 971
madamemeer merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le
Ministre en fait le groupe socialiste
n'a pas de de de lutte schizophrène chez
lui et l'amendement de Philippe Brun est
quand même différent de celui que nous
proposons également sous mon nom mais au
nom toujours du groupe socialiste à
savoir que il s'agit là pour un débat
que nous considérons intéressant de
faire en sorte que de ce débat comporte
des données qualitatives aussi et pas
seulement des données chiffrées et que
l'on puisse être à ce moment-là un
moment de rencontre où ce que fait
l'état puisse être aussi mis sur la
table et et notamment en particulier
s'agissant et bien des capacités
d'accueil que peut que peut apporter les
que peuvent apporter les préfectures si
les les étrangers ont ont on on ont dû
subir la porte close il est bien évident
que cela a un effet sur le nombre de
dossierers demandés on sait que la
dématérialisation n'est pas facile on
sait que le Défenseur des droits indique
même qu'un recours contentieux est
quelquefois nécessaire pour obtenir
l'accès au guichet préfectoral donc je
pense qu'on est tous ici dans le souci
de faire en sorte que le guichet
préfectoral soit un guichet quel que
soit sa sa sa manière dématérialiser ou
en présentiel en capacité de répondre à
la demande de personnes qui sont dans la
nécessité de faire valoir leurs droits
voilà donc c'est l'objet de cet
amendement qui apporte une un éclairage
utile me semble-t-il au débat qui
pourrait être mené dans l'Assemblée
nationale monsieur le rapporteur oui
favorable favorable comme j'ai pu
l'indiquer il y a quelques instants
peut-être pourons-nous l'améliorer
peut-être pourrons-nous l'améliorer en
lors de la séance vous
faz vous avez entendu ce que j'ai dit
donc avis avis favorable conformément à
ce que j'ai pu indiquer il y a quelques
instants et nous pouvons peut-être
prévoir de l'améliorer de le compléter
la PR en moins monsieur Brun pour la
séance alors monsieur balanan et madame
Martin
oui moi je je le groupe démocrate
viendra en soutien de l'amendement parce
que on on le sait aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué d'avoir un rendez-vous c'est
compliqué ça augmente les délais ça
augmente le contentieux et au bout du
bout ça augmente le malheur d'un certain
nombre de personnes qui parce qu'ils
n'ont pas eu leurs papiers dans les
temps se retrouvent dans des situations
compliquées donc avis très favorable
également pour notre part madame Martin
oui merci de me donner la parole moi
effectivement nous le trouvons très
intéressant cet amendement parce que il
s'agit d'abord de révéler qu'au-delà euh
des déclarations des uns et des autres
faussement positives et accueillantes il
y a une réalité qui démant cela
c'est-à-dire qui démentand le fait que
nous soyons dans une politique d'accueil
digne digne de ce nom et l'autre élément
c'est c'est bien de montrer qu'au fond
la philosophie de ce projet de loi alors
certes accentuer par le Sénat et bien de
rendre la vie absolument impossible aux
étrangers qui auraient l'idée de venir
sur le pays et par la même par exemple
par les faet des délais qui sont très
importants manque de moyens d'accueil
créer tout simplement des sans papiers
on y
reviendra merci monsieur le Président je
trouve que dans ces amendements il y a
la mise en cause implicite du préfet des
services
préfectoraux pour ceux d'entre nous qui
les fréquentons régulièrement nous
savons le le caractère très ser du
travail qui est fait par les préfets
dans les préfectures moi je voudrais
dire que plutôt que d'adapter des moyens
sans cesse augmentés pour traiter ces
sujets peut-être faut-il songer à
changer de paradigme et à diminuer
l'immigration dans notre
pays alors je mettre je vais mettre au
voix monsieur le ministre pardon vous
vouliz réagir non quelques mots sur un
sujet important qui est pourtant de
nature réglementaire mais qui est
essentiel évidemment c'est le
fonctionnement des préfectures alors je
pense que il faut voir qu'il y a
plusieurs difficultés à l'état de fait
que nous constatons toutes et tous et
qui en eff fait peut créer des personnes
irrégulières du fait de l'incurie du
fonctionnement général de notre système
qui est d je l'ai dit par un manque de
moyens dans les préfectures ça a été dit
que nous rattrapons mais évidemment
c'est la première année d'application
develop m donc ça mettra un petit peu de
temps et je vous remercie de l'avoir
voté le deuxième c'est quandême la
complexité du droit des étrangers qui
compte plus de 180 titres de séjour que
nous avons tous contribué pendant des
années a créé et pour l'agent de
préfecture c'est pas extrêmement évident
et donc c'est pour ça que il faudra
absolument je crois soutenir l'excellent
rapport du Sénat par le président buffet
sur le titre à 360°gr en quoi ça
consiste ce que ne fait pas aujourd'hui
l'agent de préfecture c'est quand on va
dans une préfecture et qu'on dépose une
demande au titre d'un titre de séjour et
qu'on a un nom on peut redéposer dans le
même bureau un titre de séjour sur un
autre sujet et ainsi au moins quelques
fois alors même déjà ça retarde le
moment de l'expulsion ou l'éloignement
ça crée la vie privée familiale que pour
une partie nous voyons bien que c'est
une façon de de rendre plus régulier les
personnes qui ont été irrégulierers mais
surtout ça donne pas à l'étranger ni
même à l'agent la possibilité de faire
avoir ses titres tout de suite et donc
quand on déposera un titre de séjour
demain dans l'amendement de Monsieur
buffet que j'espère on pourra
expérimenter généraliser l'agent de la
préfecture pourra regarder l'intégralité
des titres de séjour d'un seul coup et
quand il dira oui ce sera oui sur un des
droits auquels le législateur a souhaité
faire droit et quand il dira non ce sera
pour l'ensemble de ces titres je pense
que ça c'est un point très important qui
va beaucoup aider il y a des mesures de
simplification qui sont prévu dans ce
texte et même des amendements qui sont
prévus dans ce texte on en reparlera sur
le lien entre autorisation de travail et
carte de travail il y a un amendement
qui est d'ailleurs déposé me semble-t-il
par la majorité sur ce point ça
simplifiera bien évidemment le sujet
puisqu'il s'agit de répéter deux actes
administratifs qui sont de droit et qui
pourtant prennent deux fois plus de
temps pour les agents et puis il y a le
sujet que j'ai évoqué devant président
de la commission des loin et je suis
tout à fait prêt prêt à venir devant la
commission pour le détailler à partir de
l'année prochaine nous changeons de
paradigme dans les préfectures nous
mettons tous les moyens humains sur le
premier titre le titre pluriannuel
puisque si vous le votez vous aurez
l'examen de français à réussir vous
aurez pas de casier judiciaire à avoir
la compatibilité avec les valeur de la
République en revanche vous aurez une
automaticité du renouvellement sur les
titres pluriannuels sauf en cas de
difficulté judiciaire où là il y aura un
rappel au préfet pour qu'il puisse
s'opposer à l'automaticité alors
qu'aujourd'hui on met peu de monde sur
le premier entré sur le les tit plannuel
et on met beaucoup de monde sur la
nonautomaticité et on pense à des gens
qui sont là depuis 20 ans 30 ans sur le
territoire de la République qui n'ont
aucun problème avec la République et
qu'on force encore soit sur des fils
physiques soit dans des fils numériques
parce que maintenant les fils numériques
ont souvent remplacé les fils physiques
de préfecture à redéposer un dossier
alors qu'il y a aucun sujet sur cela et
donc il y a un paradigme à changé et je
pense que c'est pas forcément qu'une
question de moyen je suis d'accord avec
Madame G sur ce point même s'il manque
quand même d'agents de préfecture dans
certains endroits et notamment dans les
préfectures les plus rurales qui
connaissent plus de difficultés il y a
un moyen de on se concentre sur les
titres plannuels s'il y a un problème de
casier judiciire de la République on le
rappelle par automaticité par le préfet
c'est le cas de laanf avec la
modernisation numérique qu'a évoqué le
rapporteur général je rappelle qu'il a 3
ans tout était en papier dans les
préfectures aujourd'hui on a 60 % de
dématérialisation c'est pas si mal c'est
l'impôt la source appliqué mais moi je
je trouve madame la députée votre
amendement tombe à pr nommer mais si on
peut ici ou là le corriger en séance je
donne aussi un avis favorable bien je le
mets au voix qui vote pour
qui vote
contre il est adopté le 513
monsieurs merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit de demander que le nombre estimé
de personnes se maintenant sur le
territoire après rejet au non
renouvellement de leur titre de séjour
soit ajouté au rapport en effet dans
l'immigration illégale on a une
immigration qui consiste à entrer
illégalement sur les territoires elle
est en partie documentée là déjà les
chiffres sont insuffisants il s'agit
notamment de personnes qui arrivent sur
les côtes par le biais notamment de
bateau c'est l'immigration qui est
peut-être la plus médiatisée mais
malheureusement l'immigration illégale
en France et en Europe ne se résume pas
uniquement à cela en 2005 déjà une
commission d'enquête sur l'immigration
illégale mettait en avant la part des
étrangers qui se maintenait sur le
territoire français après expiration de
leur titre de séjour or nous le savons
nous avons sur le territoire un certain
nombre d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui sont entrés dans le dans
le pays sur le territoire grâce à des
visas qui ont bénéficier de titrre de
séjour de courte durée et qui après un
non renouvellement sont restés par
définition nous le rappelons le principe
même d'un titre de séjour c'est d'être
temporaire et puis nous aimerions savoir
finalement sur les 1,6 million premiers
titres de séjour qui ont été délivrés
depuis 6 ans par la macronie que sont
devenus en fait finalement ces personnes
nous pensons que que cette partie de
l'immigration illégale est un pan qui
est finalement assez peu documenté et
qui nous intéresse et qui intéresse
aussi les
Français rapporteur général oui merci
monsieur le Président mais la majorité
le gouvernement personne n'a rien à
cacher monsieur le député on voit bien
derrière cet amendement ce que vous
voulez souligner s'agissant des
personnes en situation irrégulière
d'abord on en est vous vous notez
vous-même le terme à des estimations ces
estimations elles sont régulièrement
exprimé publiquement ell figureront le
cas échiant dans le rapport ce sont des
éléments que nous connaissons nous
aurons dans quelques jours d'ailleurs un
rapport qui sera très intéressant et qui
portera sur l'aide médicale d'État nous
aurons le débat ici même sur ce même
titre premier a et nous aurons donc une
estimation relativement précise du
nombre de personnes en situation
irrégulière et lorsqu'il est indiqué que
l'accès à l'aide médicale d'État n'est
pas n'est pas utilisé pour environ 50 %
des bénéficiaires potentiels on voit
bien à peu près dans quelle estimation
de personnes irrégulières nous nous
situons donc défavorable non pas parce
que le chiffre mériterait d'être masqué
nous en débattrons ici même mais parce
que c'est tout à fait inutile je le dis
d'ailleurs pour d'autres d'autres
demandes de précision du rapport
monsieur le ministre il faudra peut-être
créer des ETP supplémentaires pour
rédiger le rapport qui sera remis devant
le Parlement parce que les demandes de
précision sont telles il y a déjà 18
occurrence dans le texte qui nous a été
transmis par le Sénat si nous devions
accepter tous les amendements par pays
par nationalité de précision
supplémentaire nous obtiendrons
probablement autour de 50 à à 70
occurrenceces ce n'est pas possible mais
voyez monsieuroussin que l'avis
défavorable ne consiste pas à masquer
bien évidemment la
réalité monsieur le ministre monsieur
votre demande toute légitime qu'elle
soit elle est impossible et quand ce
sera pour parti possible ce sera pas
grâce à vous impossible pourquoi parce
que vous demandez que les gens qui
partent du territoire national parce
qu'ils ont été refoulés parce qu'ils
partent volontairement c'est comme le
cas desess les personnes qui ont unqtf
puiss être compté mais monsieur Housin
dans l'espace schegen il y a plus de
frontière et donc lorsqu'il partent de
la France à la Belgique parce qu'ils ont
unqtf ou la France vers l'Allemagne ils
passent pas par frontière où on les
compte donc un on ne peut pas répondre à
votre question donc on peut le faire en
créant un système de fichier
informatique de police ça s'appelle le
pacte migratoire européen avec la
création d'ethas il a d'ailleurs un
système etias qui est transféré dans la
loi française par l'objectif de cette
loi donc c'est quoi le pacte migratoire
européen en quelques mots on
enregistrera tous les étrangers
désormais qui arrivent en Europe et puis
on dans un système évidemment très
important puisqu'on prendra leur prise
d'empreinte également toutes les polices
pourront avoir accès à ces contrôles
puisque ea c'est l'interconnexion de
toutes les polices dans l'Union
européenne pour savoir quelle personne
est passée où simplement vous avez
votter au Parlement européen par deux
fois contre ces dispositions le groupe
assement national vous avez voté contre
le fichage Eurodac de toutes les
personnes sur le territoire européen
vous êtes contre le fichage des
personnes étrangères qui arrivent sur
sol européen et vous êtes contre etias
c'est dire contre le moyen de donner à
nos policeses européennes
l'identification des personnes donc un
ce n'est pas possible dans la loi
actuelle et deux au Parlement européen
de vous empêcher de pouvoir compter ceux
qui se partir à l'espace Schengen avouz
que vous pourriez retirer votre
amendement tellement je crois que votre
disposition est contraire à ce que vous
prenez nationalement et au niveau
européen monsie Gouffier
oui monsieur le Président vous dire que
le groupe Renaissance sera opposé à à
cet amendement et rappeler à notre
collègue oussin que ce n'est pas la
macroni qui délivre les titres de séjour
c'est l'état français les service de
l'État dans le respect des lois qui
régissent notre République alors
manifestement euh c'est là où nous avons
une différence d'approche sur le
fonctionnement de notre état ce n'est
pas le président de la République ou
nous individuellement qui disons OUI ou
NON à telle demande comprends que vous
voudriez à titre personnel vouloir dire
oui ou non pour chacune et chacun en
dehors de toute de tout respect de
l'état de troit mais ce n'est pas le cas
c'est exactement ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure à partir du moment où on dit que
c'est la macronie qui décide que ce
n'est pas le cas euh bien entendu
monsieur
Houssin oui je note déjà deux
informations importantes qu'on savait
déjà mais que vous êtes favorable au
pacte migratoire européen nous on y est
défavorable aussi Monsieur le Ministre
parce que il consiste à répartir un
certain nombre de migrants qui arrivent
pas dans notre pays dans nos campagnes
et dans celles d'autres pays d'Europe
mais je pense que bientôt les électeurs
à l'occasion des élections européennes
auront la possibilité de dire s'ils sont
favorables ou non à ce texte je note
aussi que vous ne remettez pas en cause
les chiffres qui ont été donnés
récemment sur le chiffre réel des
clandestins qui serait euh bien
supérieur à ce qui avait été estimé
précédemment par le par le biais de
l'aide médicale d'État alors monsieur
bouer nous disait que la demande était
légitime et que finalement il y avait
pas besoin de préciser dans le texte
qu'on allait nous fournir les chiffres B
moi je trouve que c'est quand même
extrêmement intéressant de le faire
parce que par exemple vous avez rendu
par le B d'un amendement il y a quelques
minutes le débat à l'Assemblée
facultatif alors il faudrait pas non
plus qu'un certain nombre de chiffres
qui sont intéressants deviennent
facultatifs dans le rapport nous on
préfère que ça soit écrit effectivement
monsieur le vinistre vous avez raison il
s'agira avant tout d'estimation étant
donné qu'on n pas de chiffr précis c'est
d'ailleurs ce que demande l'amendement
mais il est aussi problématique que nous
n'ayons pas de chiffre
précis bien monsieur le ministre non
rappelez que Madame Méloni est favorable
au pacte migratoire votre ami
voilà bien donc je mets au voix je mets
au voix l'amendement de Monsieur Houssin
qui vote pour qui vote contre il est
alors voyez attention quand même parce
que le RM venez de voter contre donc
ouais donc on va peut-être bien il est
rejeté le 551 qui le défend madame Diaz
ouici monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à enrichir le rapport
que nous souhaitons voir présenter
devant le Parlement chaque année et là
cette demande concerne les titre des
procédures de réunification familiale et
de regroupement
familial
oui l'amendement est satisfait ces
chiffres sont déjà publiés dans le
rapport annuel qui est remis au au
Parlement et notamment par l'OFI
défavorable je mets au voix qui votre
pour contre rejeté le 175 monsieur Luc
merci monsieur le Président je veux
saisir de ce débat pour j'ai bien
compris qu'on aurait du mal monsieur le
ministresieur rapporteur général à vous
convaincre au regard de ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure sur les prés qui sont les
vôtres et qui sont les nôtres et qui
sont normaux c'est sain dans une
démocratie qu'on confronte des points de
vue et des idées je pense en revanche
que la Défenseur des droits qui a une
autorité institutionnelle devrait vous
inspirer je lis dans l'avis qui nous a
été transmis par ces soins il y a
quelques jours à peine ce qu'elle dit
sur les quotas ces quotas ne seraient
pas contraignants concernant
l'immigration familiale mais définir les
objectifs chiffrés concernant ce motif
d'immigration pourrait inciter les
administrations à opposer des refus
illégaux pour remplir les 10 objectifs
une telle mesure ne paraît pas être de
nature à lutter contre l'immigration
illégale je sais que c'est peut-être
plus simple quand c'est madame mélonie
qui le dit mais là c'est c'est la
Défenseur des droits au contraire
limiter l'accès aux voies régulièrre
d'immigration ne peut que favoriser le
développement des voisin légals contre
lesquels le projet de loi entend lutter
ainsi que le détournement des visas de
cours séjour par ailleurs ces quotas
seraient contraignants concernant les
autres motifs d'admission en France cela
concernerait notamment les travailleurs
les étudiants les personnes sollicitant
un visa à titre humanitaire à
l'exception des demandeurs d'asile et
elle met en garde contre cette politique
du chiffre qui risque de produire des
effets inverses à ceux qui sont affichés
oui j'aime beaucoup votre argumentation
mais moi je mentiens à l'amendement et
vous supprimer l'alinée 7 vous supprimez
l'alinée 7 c'est l'indicateur du nombre
d'étrangers admis aux fin d'immigration
de travail
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour contre rejeté le 358 madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président donc
nous nous
souhaitons savoir combien de person
personnes arrivé régulièrement sur le
territoire national lorsqu'elles ont été
recrutées se maintiennent sur le
territoire national à l'expiration de
leur titre de
séjour rapporteur général oui madame
Diaz généralement quand une personne se
maintient sur le territoire à l'issue de
son contrat de travail elle n'appelle
pas la préfecture pour dire qu'elle
reste sur le territoire national c'est
par conséquent défavorable je mets au
voix qui va être pour contre rejeté le
221 madame blanc merci monsieur monie
président l'accueil et la formation
d'étudiants étrangers fait partie de la
politique de rayonnement internationale
de la France toutefois les étudiants
étrangers ont vocation à retourner dans
leur pays respectifs à l'issue de leurs
études il est par conséquent nécessaire
d'ajouter aux données figurant dans le
rapport mentionné dans cet article un
indicateur permettant de s'assurer que
les refus de renouvellement de visa
étudiant et de titre de séjour étudiant
ne sont pas suivis de la délivrance d'un
visa ou d'un titre de séjour fondé sur
un autre motif je vous remercie monsieur
rapporteur général oui votre demande
légitime elle est redondante avec
l'alinéa 4 telle qu'il a été tel qu'il a
été précisé par le groupe socialiste cet
amendement esté adopté au Sénat et donc
je vous demande de bien vouloir le
retirer s'il vous plaît madame Rousseau
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
les étudiants qui sont qui arrivent à
l'université française sont des
personnes qui viennent là pour étudier
qui ressortent avec un diplôme et alors
là alors que vous voulez une immigration
choisie puisque c'est un peu l'objet de
ce texte que vous voulez des quotas que
vous voulez et là on a des gens form et
vous allez vous assurer qu'il repartent
quoi non mais vraiment il a je sais pas
où est-ce qu'on est alors je sais que
Madame mélonier très mol manifestement
mais enfin là on est quand même dans
quelque chose d'une irrationalité qui
même selon vos principes abject n'a pas
de sens monsieur de la porte oui merci
de rappeler que le groupe socialiste a
fait adopter un amendement au Sénat qui
visait notamment à pointer la situation
des visas accordés et rejetés parce
parce que aujourd'hui notamment suite à
à la mise en place de votre politique
qui fait notamment payer les frais de
scolarité par les étudiants étrangers on
a aujourd'hui une dégradation de la
condition des étudiants et finalement
une inégalité croissante puisque c'est
seulement ceux qui sont les plus à même
de payer des frais scolarités
exorbitants qui sont aujourd'hui
accueillis ce qui n'est pas une
politique que nous défendons donc vous
avez dit que l'amendement de nos
collègues rassemblement national était
légitime moi je juge plutôt illégitime
parce que son objet son objet
était justement de dire comme l'a
souligné madame Rousseau à l'instant que
quand il y a des personnes qui viennent
étudier en France elles n'ont pas
vocation derrière à rester en France ce
qui n'est pas le cas d'une partie des
étudiants et que quand on dit bienvenue
en France ce qui est le nom de la
politique d'une des politiques du
gouvernement il faut aussi pouvoir y
rester monsieur le rapporteur général
ouis je rappelle je rappelle que
l'amendement demandit le nombre de refus
monsieur balanan s'il vous plaît pardon
monsieur le Président je prend instant
l'amendement demandé le refus de
renouvellement de visa étudiant cette
demande est tellement légitime qu'elle
est identique à c'est que le Parti
socialiste a défendu au Sénat c'est
exactement ce que je disais par ailleurs
monsieur de la porte de grâce évitons
ici attendez la séance avant d'avoir des
arguments politiciens jamais aucun
gouvernement n'a délivré autant de visas
étudiants que notre gouvernement que
notre majorité jamais et c'est
d'ailleurs à tel point que nous
répondrons à l'extrême droite à
plusieurs reprises au cours des débats
dans les jours dans les semaines à venir
aujourd'hui la première raison le
premier motif d'immigration en France ce
sont les visas étudiants et c'est une
grande fierté pour cette majorité et
lorsque le président de la République
fixe l'objectif un tempant soit peu très
ambitieux de 500000 visas étudiants à
l'horizon 2027 c'est la trajectoire qui
est la nôtre voilà donc ne déformez pas
nos ambitions elles sont très fortes et
il y a eu en 2022 188000 étudiants venus
en France c'est une chance pour notre
pays bien je mets au voix qui votre pour
contre rejeté le
354 merci monsieur le Président donc
toujours par rapport au aux étudiants
nous nous souhaitons que le rapport
précise la chose suivante à
savoir sur le nombre d'étudiants rentrés
étudiants étrangers rentrés en France
pour suivre des études nous souhaitons
savoir combien de temps il reste pour
faire leurs études c'est-à-dire est-ce
qu'ils redoublent est-ce qu'ils triplent
est-ce qu'une fois qu'ils ont redoublé
deux fois la première année ils se
dirigent vers une autre filière non mais
ce sont des éléments importants je
comprends que ça vous gêne un petit peu
mais je vois pas pourquoi vous être gêné
sur le sujet c'est tout à fait normal
que l'on sache des étrangers à qui on
offre la possibilité la chance de venir
étudier dans notre pays parce que les
les les cours sont de qualité et bien il
nous apparît normal que la
représentation nationale soit éclairée
et sache combien de temps passent en
France les étudiants s'ils rest s'ils
sortent avec un diplôme et combien de
temps ils étudient mon rapporteur
général et la mê même réponse vous voyez
le la ligne à 4 lisez-le chers collègues
il comporte déjà la donnée que vous
demandez d'ajouter je je veux simplement
vous dire
[Musique]
que sur la question du redoublement par
exemple il existe des disposition dans
le code des étrangers vous les ignorez
évidemment que on regarde si
l'étudiant poursuit avec une certaine
forme
d'assiduité les études qui ont justifié
sa venue en France le Sénat d'ailleurs
souhaiterait que nous allions plus loin
dans la vérification nous aurons ce
débat dans quelques instants donc
regardez le césd étudier les
dispositions de vigilance qui existe de
façon générale mais de grâce n'assimilez
pas les visas étudiants à une trappe
irrégularité ça n'est pas du tout la
réalité de ce qui peut aujourd'hui
survenir en France Monsieur Lucas
ou madame Diaz quand on aime la France
et quand on aime l'université française
on aime les étudiants internationaux des
étudiants étrangers parce qu'enfin euh
c'est une source de rayonnement
considérable pour notre pays et nous
devrions ici être fier que la France
soit choisie en dépit d'ailleurs de ce
qui est l'image qu'elle donne à travers
le monde de par la progression de Madame
Le Pen et de par votre présence en
nombre à l'Assemblée nationale de par
l'image que nous donnons malheureusement
quand on voit des néonazis défiler dans
nos rues et bien malgré ça il y a encore
à travers le monde des gens qui aiment
la France au point de vouloir venir y
étudier et c'est une fierté pour nous
pour notre rayonnement pour notre
influence à travers le monde par
ailleurs les étudiants étrangers fichent
leur la paix ils réussissent mieux que
que les les autres les études sérieuses
le montrent il rapporte de l'argent même
si on regarde d'un point de vue
strictement économique avec vos petits
tableaux comptbles votre là vous n'avez
pas utilisé votre éternel argument de
combien ça coûte 1,35 milliards d'euros
c'est ce que rapportent les étudiants
internationaux chaque année en bénéfice
net à notre pays c'est formidable les
étudiants étrangers même vous vous
devriez quand même le comprendre malgré
tout bien madame Fillon et on
votera je je vois bien pourquoi le
rassemblement national demande des
chiffres et des chiffres sur les
étudiants étrangers mais je comprends
bien le fond c'est-à-dire que il ne faut
ici pas penser que le rassemblement
national cherche des chiffres pour
rationaliser le débat sur l'immigration
ou pour pouvoir s'en servir de manière
apaisée puisque de toute façon son quels
que soient les chiffres qu'on leur
fournisse le rassemblement national
profitera de chaque situation pour
instrumentaliser ses chiffres et pour en
permanence les les dévoyer non ces
amendements très clairement et nous
l'avons bien compris sont des
amendements qui ont un sous-entendu le
sous-entendu il est assez évident c'est
d'expliquer qu'en fait les personnes qui
viennent ici ne viendraient pas pour
étudier mais uniquement pour pouvoir
profiter de ce qu'ils appellent le
système français et qu' a une suspicion
généralisée vis-à-vis de tous les
étrangers qui viennent sur le territoire
c'est une vision extrêmement triste à la
fois de l'histoire humaine qui est
l'immigration mais mais aussi une vision
extrêmement triste de ce qu'est
l'université puisqu'elle est justement
ce lieu de rencontre aussi
internationale et je rejoins mon
collègue Lucas pour dire que de très
nombreux étudiants étrangers qui
viennent étudier à l'université ont
plutôt tendance j'aime pas le terme mais
à challenger les étudiants avec une
carte française donc oui ils sont
véritablement une chance dans
l'université et nombre d'universitaires
pourrai vous le dire mais je sais bien
que les universitaires et les chercheurs
décidément c'est pas votre truc madame
Diaz
oui merci monsieur le Président bon je
voulais réagir à ce qui a été dit et je
je vous demande moi de de voter en
faveur de notre amendement parce que oui
bien sûr que les étudiants font la
fierté de notre pays et les étudiants
étrangers qui viennent étudier dans
notre pays et qui repartent après dans
leur pays évidemment qu'il contribuent
au rayonnement de notre pays mais
puisque vous semblez ignorer que ce
statut semble
dévoyer vous si vous êtes aussi sûr de
vous chers collègues d'extrême gauche et
bien votez précisément cet avendement ça
vous évitera ou ça évitera d'entretenir
une suspicion et donc je ne comprends
pas pourquoi vous êtes gêné pour
soutenir notre amendement je constate
par ailleurs que vous faites preuve d'un
d'un mépris incroyable vis-à-vis des
étudiants étrangers quand vous dites je
vous cite vis-à-vis des étudiants
français quand vous dites les étudiants
étrangers réussissent mieux je c'est pas
hyper sympa pour les étudiants français
qui qui se mettent en qure pour dans des
conditions très difficiles et de
précarité étudiante grandissante je
trouve que vos propos sont
particulièrement déplacer et enfin je
m'étonne que vous ne voyez que les
étudiants par le prisme économique quand
vous dites les étudiant rapportent aux
universités je trouve ça assez
surprenant que l'extrême gauche se
confonde avec des comparaisons
capitalistes bien je mets au voix
l'amendement qui vote pour contre rejeté
le suivant monsieur vult je crois que
vous êtes le seul signataire présent et
bien je serai ravi de défendre juste
sans abuser de votre patience monsieur
le Président il y a 20 ans j'ai rédigé
un pour le Conseil économique et social
sur la mobilité internationale des
étudiants et à l'époque il y avait ru de
Fleurus une agence payée par les
industries nord-américaines pour venir à
la sortie des remises de diplôme des m2
et solliciter les gens qui avaient été
formés chez nous à qui on avait demandé
de repartir pour aller bosser dans
l'industrie américaine et je me dis
quand même déjà à l'époque je disais
qu'on était bien bête à 12000 € le
diplôme de par année qu'on était bien
bête de subventionner l'industrie
américaine et canadienne à raison de
60000 € par an alors que nous pouvions
avoir des besoins sur ces étudiants là
et je pense que cette remarque est
toujours vrai aujourd'hui sans compter
qu'à priori comment notre système de
santé fonctionne sans étudiants
étrangers moi je sais pas faire et je
pense que personne ne sait faire mais là
on les c'est autre chose c'est notre
collègue milfer qui dépose cet
amendement qui l' rédigé pour ça pour
que ce fameux rapport qui doit orienter
nos politiques de migration puisse aussi
nous renseigner sur les conséquences des
catastrophes nuclé des catastrophes
naturelles et des catastrophes
climatiques sur les flux de de de
demande de visa et qu'on puisse en avoir
une idée au travers de celui-ci monsie
rapporteur général
je comprends bien votre votre demande il
se trouve que le le motif que que vous
évoqué c'està-dire lié à une catastrophe
naturelle par définition n'existe pas
aujourd'hui puisquil n'y a pas de titre
de séjour dont la motivation serait
fondé sur un changement climatique sur
catastrophe naturelle d'ailleurs dans
dans quelques instants nous aurons
l'occasion de en tout cas moi j'aurai
l'occasion de vous proposer un avis
favorable sur un amendement de notre
collègue mier milfer qui consiste à nous
inciter à réfléchir et à préciser et à
définir ce que sont les migrations
climatiques et le cas échéant issu de
catastrophe naturelle donc pour cette
raison et pour cette raison seulement
avis
défavorable ah il est retiré il est
retiré le suivant n'est pas défendu il
est retiré pardon il a été retiré tout à
l'heure par Madame Abad
le 482 qui le défend monsieur oui gilet
monsieur le Président chers collègues B
le présent amendement il vise finalement
à nommer les choses comme il se doit
alors outre le fait que les mineurs non
accompagné ne sont pas toujours mineurs
et c'est loin d'être d'être toujours le
cas outre le fait que les mineurs
d'ailleurs non accompagnés sont
surreprésentés dans les faits de de
délinquent c'est une réalité en 2020 par
exemple 80 % des déferrements de mineurs
à Paris ont concerné des des MNA c'est
considérable AOP le fait d'ailleurs
qu'il coûte un pogon de dingue comme
dirait l'autre au contribuable puisque
on sait que un mineur non accompagné
coûte 50000 € par an au conseil
départemental et bien cet amendement
vise tout simplement à dire les choses
telleles qu'elles sont et à renommer les
mineurs non accompagnés des clandestins
mineurs ce qu'ils sont même s'ils ne
sont pas encore une fois toujours
mineurs
ppor je je reconnais que quand j'ai pris
connaissance hier soir de cette
amendement j'ai pensé que vous vouliez
manier l'humour qui est une forme de
tradition dans votre organisation
politique si j'ose
dire quand vous parlez mais quand quand
je dis ça chers collègu Solignac c'est
précisément parce que ça se discute au
fond vous assimilez par conséquent vous
assimilez par conséquent l'ensemble des
mineurs éanger à des clandestins tous
les mineurs hein vous savez que les
mineurs sont par définition en situation
de protection là la question ne se pose
pas de savoir s'ils sont en situation
régulière ou irrégulière nous leur
devons la protection vous parlez par
contre ce sont des mineurs non mais
chers collègues ce sont des mineurs donc
il n'y a pas de mineurs clandestins en
France ça n'existe pas non ça n'existe
pas ce qui peut exister non ça n'existe
pas mais on vous l'exliqua plus pri
c'est pas un dialogue donc on va
continuer existe pas en revanche il peut
y avoir des personnes qui se prétendent
mineurs et qui sont majeurs on aura la
discussion dans d'autres occasions
d'autres textes mais un mineur
clandestin mon cher collègue ça n'existe
pas parce qu'il est mineur et parce que
nous lui devons protection défavorable
alors madame Fillon monsieur balanan et
enfin Monsieur de courourson Madame
Fillon j'avoue aussi que la lecture de
de cet amendement a quelque chose
d'assez heurtant c'est faible he
franchement je je dirais que c'est on n
pas beaucoup mieux en terme d'amendement
Crass puisque
effectivement au regard des des députés
du rassemblement national euh même les
enfants étrangers sont pas avant tout
des enfants pour eux c'est-à-dire que
ils voi d'abord mais c'est c'est vrai
pour tout le monde chez eux il voient
d'abord le fait que ces personnes sont
étrangères avant de voir l'être humain
ou avoir ou avant de voir l'enfant à
protéger nous avons des textes je sais
que vous vous en fichez complètement he
de la convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant que les traités
internationaux que nous avons signés que
le droit d'asile que la Cour européenne
de droits de l'homme tout ça pour vous
est à bazarder pourtant c'est ce qui la
plupart de temps nous permet quand même
de tenir bon sur certains principes et
sur notre humanité alors je sais que
parais que c'est un terme un peu
compliqué pour vous mais les mineurs non
accompagnés si nous les appelons comme
ça c'est parce que nous voyons d'abord
le fait qu'ils sont qu'ils sont des
enfants et que donc ils sont d'abord à
protéger et non il y a pas de mineur
CLAND destin puisque'à partir du moment
où ils sont mineurs la question de
leurrégularité ou de leur irrégularité
n'est pas à prendre en compte ils sont à
protéger comme tous les enfants et j'ai
déjà entendu que depuis tout à l'heure
vous essayez de savoir combien ces
enfants coûtent à l'état français
euh moi je me demande même pas combien
coûte à l'état français vos enfants je
pense qu'il faut pas faire les choses
comme ça et qu'il faut regarder comment
on les emmène vers le meilleur même les
vôtres alors monsieur
non oui merci merci monsieur le
Président oui euh cet cet amendement il
est euh
oui je sais pas j'allais dire abject je
vais essayer d'avoir de garder des mots
des mots modérés mais quand même quand
même c'est c'est c'est tout simplement
ignoble si nous avons des mineurs
nonaccompagn d'ailleurs d'ailleurs on on
devrait plutôt ça appeler ça des enfants
non accompagnés ça ça serait peut-être
juridiquement moin moins fort mais
humainement ça représenterait ce que ce
que ce que nous ce que nous sommes et ce
que nous voulons bah dans notre pays on
protège les enfants parce que c'est le
rôle des adultes c'est le rôle de la
puissance publique de protéger ceux qui
sont plus faibles et parmi les plus
faibles nos enfants font partie du lot
donc vraiment votre amendement il est il
est unique et il est tellement
révélateur de ce que vous vous dites je
je reprends ce que madame fossillon a
dit je voulais le le dire c'est que vous
vous ne vous posez même pas la question
de savoir ce qu'est un mineur vous dites
c'est un clandestin c'est un étranger
donc parce qu'il est étranger c'est
ontologique à sa fonction d'étranger il
est mauvais et c'est tout simplement
abject et et évidemment nous voterons
contre cet amendement monsieur de
Courson
oui le le le vrai problème me
semble-t-il sur les mineurs dans l'
acccompagné c'est que à postériori chez
nous dans mon département on en a
actuellement 240 et suite au contrôle
notamment testosux
80 % se révèlent ne pas être des mineurs
voilà non mais si je pu terminer si je
peux
terminer si je peux terminer vous
laissez laissez parler monsieur de
Courson il est pas sou dans notre
commission et donc le vrai problème
c'est l'organisation
administrative que les départements soi
responsables des mineurs non accompagnés
et
l'État les autres si je puis dire il
faut unifier tout ça il serait logique
que ce soit l'état qui soit compétent
pour l'ensemble on n'aurait pas toutes
ces bisebilles entre l'État et les
départements et quitte à ce que l'État
conventionne auprès de chaque
département de s'occuper de ces jeunes
je vous rappelle dans un département
comme laamarne qui est à peu près 1% de
la population française on en a 240 le
prix de journée des foyers de l'enfance
c'est 171 € chez nous voyez donc à peu
près 5000 € par mois et 60000 € par an
et l'État lorsqu'on découvre que ces 80
% de ces mineurs ne sont des majeurs ne
nous remboursent les départements qu'un
montant qui est pas du tout
représentatif que ça coûte au
département donc si on veut sortir de de
de de cette mauvaise organisation
administrative la vraie réforme ce
serait qu'on vote un amendement en
disant l'État est responsable de
l'ensemble et et non pas uniquement euh
euh les les les majeurs euh je pense
qu'on ça permettra de sortir de tous ces
débats et qu'on et qu'on ait une unité
de commandement si je puis dire sur
cette affaire je le mets au voix qui
vote pour quiote contre rejeté le 107
qui le
défend le 107 pour le groupe
rassemblement nationale madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président donc ça
ça a été évoqué le le coup des mineurs
nonaccompagnés explos il varierait en
selon les indications entre 40000 et
100000 € par an euh et le statut de
mineur non accompagné est
particulièrement avantageux c'est pour
ça qu'il est dévoyé et là je vais citer
l'ancien président du conseil
départemental LR de senemar qui dit que
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
se prétendent souvent mineurs et isolés
afin de bénéficier de ce statut très
protecteur donc nous parce que nous
sommes soucieux de la préservation euh
de de l'argent du contribuable nous vous
avons proposé il y a quelques semaines
euh de rendre obligatoire un test
radiologique pour savoir quels enfants
ont vraiment le droit à la protection
parce qu'ils sont vraiment murs mineurs
et quelles personnes sont des fraudeurs
et donc doivent être exclus euh de du
principe de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
en gros nous vous demandons d'être
respectueux de l'argent des Français et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous vous
demandons de faire apparaître dans ce
rapport les départements euh qui ne ne
souhaite pas faire évaluer la minorité
des prétendus mineurs non accompagnés et
on vous propose cet amendement parce que
précisément la chambre régionale des
comptes de nouvelleiten en 2021 a pointé
du doigt la Gironde et suspecter des
prises en charge indu en assistance
éducative donc j'espère que votre
attention à l'égard de l'argent du
contribuable vous conduira à voter cet
amendement de bon sens monsieur alors
monsieur le rapporteur général pardon j'
donné la parole non défavorable parce
que ces données sont déjà connues vous
vous demandez par ailleurs dans un
amendement suivant l'évaluation du coût
de la prise en charge des mineursag
accompagné là aussi ce sont les données
tout à fait connues donc défavorables
pour le 107 et le 108 que vous
présenterez dans quelques instants
monsieur
porte merci merci monsieur le Président
évidemment contre cet amendement qui est
en fait le début d'une longue série
d'amendements qui sont des amendements
racistes et qui montrre ce qui est
l'extrême droite et nous sommes face à
des enfants et effectivement la première
chose que vous voyez c'est que ce sont
des étrangers alors que ça a été
rappeler les enfants doivent être
protégés dans ce pays c'est une réalité
et enfin je vois le la personne qui a
signé cet amendement quand il s'agit
d'exploiter vous ne regardez pas s'il
s'agit d'adulte de mineurs ou d'étranger
monsieur de fournace ferait mieux de
s'occuper des travailleurs qu'il a
exploité sur son exploitation viticole
en girande plutôt que de s'attaquer
aujourd'hui à ses enfants qui ont subi
des catastrophes et qui demandent à être
protégés par l'État
Monsieur
mendz Merci monsieur le
Président c'est assez marrant de de de
voir le rassemblement national revenir
revenir sur sur ce projet de loi alors
queilt il y a peu dans leur niche
parlementaire ils avaient proposé à ce
que la minorité soit évaluée à chaque
fois par les testux et qu'on a tous
contesté ce qu'il proposait étant donné
que même le corps médical nétait pas du
tout d'accord avec eux que tous les tous
les les médecins d'un point de vue
internationaux ne suivent pas du tout ce
qui est proposé par le assembl nationale
et je l'entends parler de la Cour des
comptes de Gironde ce qui est dommage
c'est que Madame Diaz ne prend pas ce
que dit la Cour des comptes au niveau
national de dire que tous les
départements devrait mettre en place le
fichier mis en place par l'État pour
garantir qu'un mineur qui était dans un
département n'aille pas dans un autre
département une fois qu'on a pu on a pu
le reconnaître comme non mineur en fait
vous pourriez nous aider à apporter des
réponses parce que le gouvernement a agi
dans le bon sens la protection des
mineurs la protection des département et
faire en sorte que le système ne soit
pas dévoyé et pour autant vous ne le
faites pas parce que votre seul objectif
c'est de faire croire que tout mineur
étranger est un danger potentiel et
n'est pas un mineur sauf que ce qui a
été mis en place dans le fichier du du
mise en place pour les départements
c'est pour contrer les arguments que
vous utilisez vous vous servez que
d'arguments financiers ou même la Cour
des comptes elle-même explique que ce
qu'elle donne comme chiffres ne sont pas
les bons chiffres étant donné qu'on a on
est en incapacité de démontrer que la
majorité de ces mineurs sont des majeurs
et la Cour des comptes elle-même le dit
donc tous vos arguments peut les
retourner contre vous on l'a fait sur la
niche contre re le rassemblement
national et malgré tout vous revenez à
la charge et on continuera à démonter
vos arguments un par un sans pour autant
vous traiter de raciste mais de montrer
à quel point votre démagogie ne sert
strictement à
rien alors j'ai monsieur siti après vous
voulez répondre monsieur le ministre
monsieur siti d'abord bien mes chers
collègues de la majorité je je mesure
que ce débat vous gêne parce
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement fait
preuve d'une totale passivité face à
cette situation qui ne cesse de croître
nous avons sans doute aujourd'hui près
de 40000 voire 50000 mineurs pudiquement
appelés non accompagnés parce que on ne
cite pas la réalité des des faits dans
mon département des Alpes Maritimes on a
connu une croissance de 50 % en 2023
d'arrivver de ces pseudo mineurs dont
beaucoup en effet sont sont majeurs
aujourd'hui 1000 mineurs supposés sont
placés dans des structures de protection
de l'enfance quelquefois jusqu'à les
emboliser et pour un coût de 40 millions
d'euros pour le département des Alpes
Maritimes en 2023 donc c'est un sujet
qui devrait relever de la politique
migratoire et donc qui devrait euh être
de la responsabilité de l'État du
gouvernement je regrette malgré quelques
signes de la part de la première
ministre sur une meilleure prise en
charge financière qui a été annoncée au
congrès de l'Association des départ de
France mais qu'on ne mesure pas de la
gravité de cette situation euh donc il
faut être lucide ce sont désormais des
filières migratoires aux mains de
passeurs qui sont utilisés et qui
exploitent qui exploitent cette
situation comme l'asile est dévoyé on
est en train aujourd'hui de passer à une
nouvelle filière migratoire où sous le
saut d'une pseudo minorité des filières
entières de traite des êtres humains
s'organisent et ceux qui devrai relever
de la protection de l'enfance je ne
comprends pas monsieur le ministre
pourquoi il n'y a pas une action
diplomatique aujourd'hui dans le
département des Alpes Maritimes la
première nationalité d'arrivver c'est la
Côte d'Ivoire c'est un pays qui est
organisé qui est structuré pourquoi ce
pays ne prend pas en charge ses enfants
et pourquoi ne sont-ils pas
immédiatement reconduits vers leurs
familles depuis leur pays de destination
ça serait ça faire preuve d'humanité
monsieur le
ministre allez-y merci Monsieur Merci
monsieur le le président cette question
des des mineurs des enfants non
accompagnés c'est évidemment une
question très importante qui relève à la
fois bien sûr du devoir d'humanité du
devoir de protection mais aussi
distinguer qui finance C n'est pas une
mauvaise question et bien sûr regarder
s'il s'agit véritablement de mineur ou
il s'agit de
majeur d'abord je voudrais dire ici que
ce texte de loi ne prévoit pas et
monsieur le Président on a déjà discuté
pour le coup il me paraît évident et le
Sénat d'ailleurs en a convenu dans Cees
débat être un parfait cavailler
législatif il ne prévoit pas ce texte la
question des mineurs pour la bonne et
simple raison que ce n'est pas
l'autorité préfectorale et Monsieur suti
vous le savez pertinemment ce n'est pas
l'autorité préfectorale qui peut
reconduire dans leur pays d'origine les
personnes c'est l'autorité judiciaire
c'est tellement vrai que vous le savez
bien c'est le procureur de la République
le juge judiciaire qui s'occupe de ces
mineurs et qui ordonne les placements ce
n'est pas le préfet préfet peut faire
des mise à l'abri ce qui reconduit le
mineur dans son pays d'origine c'est une
décision de l'autorité judiciaire et
donc il y a effectivement un sujet qui
est celui de l'efficacité de notre
politique judiciire diplomatique
évidemment évidemment mais c'est
l'autorité judiciaire et c'est très
important puisque lorsque le mineur est
effectivement mineur il a tout à fait la
possibilité de retourner dans son pays
d'origine c'est a une décision de
justice qui permet de considérer que par
exemple sa famille existe et présente
dans son pays d'origine s'il a des
conditions d'éducation qui se permettent
de le faire c'est ce que fait parle le
gouvernement marocain qui a signé une
convention avec le ministre de la
Justice pour ce qui concerne les mineurs
marocains vous évoquez d'autres
nationalités que ceux du Maghreb ça
montre qu' a son doute ici ou là des
améliorations qui on pu être apporté par
tel ou tel pays le deuxième sujet une
fois que je vous ai expliqué que ce
n'est pas une question d'autorité
préfectorale et donc qui ne relève pas
du code des étrangers strict au sensus
mais qui du travail que fait l'autorité
judiciaire c'est évidemment la question
de savoir si les gens sont en minorité
ou en majorité Mons sioti vous êtes trop
connaisseur de ces questions pour savoir
que vous-même lorsque vous étiz en
responsabilité n'avez pas trouvé la
martingale chacun se rappelle des
difficultés autour des tests osseux qui
per qui permettent une certaine
identification mais qui ne permettent
pas toutes les identifications et je ne
saais trop vous recommander d'adopter ce
texte de loi puisqu'il prévoit la
coeriss pour les prises d'empreintes qui
permet notamment à trouver un état civil
parce que la difficulté vous dites
qu'ils sont Ivoiriens ou qu' sont
sénégalais et une immigration qui arrive
par exle à l'ampedusa qui passe ensuite
vers l'Italie et qui qui peut arriver
vers la frontière à monton et notamment
arriver dans votre département ce sont
des nationalités revendiquées ce ne sont
pas des nationalités vérifiés et la
première des choses que l'on doit faire
c'est vérifier un état civil vérifier
une identité parce que vous le savez
pertinemment qu'un pays encore moins
juge n'accepte de renvoyer dans un pays
un enfant ou un mineur si tantz qu'il le
soit bien évidemment après vérification
en ayant bien imaginé que cette personne
ce cet enfant est bien de la nationalité
du pays que l' renvoie donc la question
de la prise d'identité est très
importante et pour la première fois vous
avez un texte de loi qui propose la
coerciss pour les personnes qui sont
étrangères pour vérifier leur identité
et ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et on
sait tous que le testosux connaît des
difficultés d'identification quand même
il faudrait le le généraliser
troisièmement il y a des
expérimentations qui sont faites sur la
minorité sur la majorité qui sont
intéressantes je pense notamment au
travail que nous faisons avec le Gard
des saau à Bordeaux et en Gironde
puisque cela a été évoqué des
difficultés qu'il y a dans ce
département il y en a d'autres
évidemment en France sur le fait que les
policiers les gendarmes font ce qu'on
appelle des procèsverbaux de majorité ou
de minorité et la foi de l'OPJ vaut pour
le procureur de la République et ils
suivent 97 % des décisions de la police
et de la gendarmerie pourquoi c'est si
important parce que quand la personne
relève de la majorité il tombe sous
l'autorité du préfet et de la reconduite
administrative quand il est sous
l'autorité de la minorité si je dire ben
il tombe sous l'autorité judiciaire et
ne relève pas du fait que nous évoquons
alors ensuite monsieur de courourson et
vous-même évoquer une question plus
globale qui celle de la relation
financière entre l'État département
d'ailleurs dans dans dans le les propos
de Monsieur de courourson il n'y a pas
de remise en cause en soi d'accueillir
les Ménas il dit juste que c'est pas au
département de le faire et financer de
telle sorte c'est tout à fait vrai qu'il
y a un grand débat qui se profile entre
l'ADF et entre les collectivités locales
et l'État d'abord je vrais dire quand
même qu'une partie des départements
n'ont pas joué le jeu pendant très
longtemps vous le savez bien il a fallu
attendre notre majorité la loi taqué
pour obliger plus de la moitié des
départements et parfois des départements
très importants je pense à la ville de
Paris par exemple qui a beaucoup
beaucoup de mineurs sur son territoire
et dont on sait pas très bien d'ailleurs
s'ils étaient majeurs ou mineurs pour
avoir ce qu'on appelle la em c'estàd un
fichier qui permet de tenir l'accueil de
ces personnes il a fallu la loi attaquer
et 86 aujourd'hui de départements don
quasiment 100 % des départements ont se
fichier ce qui permet une plus grande
efficacité de l'État et pour les les
quelques-uns qui restent par des raisons
idéologiques de refus de faire ce
fichier les décrets d'obligation seront
très bientôt publiés permettront de le
faire 1 il faut donc l'évaluer moi le
chiffre que j'ai monsieur siti j'entends
la question de 40000 ou 50000
les chiffres à partir de 86
collectivités qui ont désormais un
affichage obligatoire un enregistrement
obligatoire c'est
14782 mineurs accueillis par les
Conseils départementaux lné 2022 l'n
2023 jusqu'au mois de septembre donc bon
je sais pas parce qu' y a une question
évidemment de personnes qui étaient là
avant en tout cas les chiffres exacts
que nous avons désormais grâce à ce
fichier c'est celui-ci le deuxième sujet
pardon je parce que vous êtes
particulièrement accueillant monsieur
chti c'est connu le deuxème sujet
le deè sujet monsieur Lesieur c'est
évidemment de dire c'est évidemment êt
une frontière c'est pas normal qu'il a
beaucoup de monde dans une frontière en
tout cas ce sont les ce sont les
enregistrements faits par les 86
collectivités qui sont dans l'obligation
de le faire et comme c'est des relations
financières je pense qu'ils ont intérêt
évidemment à le faire le deuxième sujet
c'est c'est le lien qu'il y a entre MNA
et protection de l'enfance c'est ça le
sujet principal parce qu'il y a
effectivement des faux mineurs et il y
en a on est incapable de dire combien de
pourcentage et ils sont parfois nombreux
c'est vrai il y a des faux mineurs qui
prennent la place de vrais enfants qui
soient étrangers ou qui soit évidemment
français la la question n'a rien à voir
là-dedans qui sont eux à être protégés
soit parce qu'ils connaissent des des
des leorphelina soit parce qu'ils
connaissent des difficultés évidemment
de violence sexuelle de de retrait de
l'autorité parentale et il y a
départements je pense au mien où euh
nous sommes très accueillants pour
autant une partie de faux mineurs parce
qu'ils sont placés d'office prennent la
place de personnes qui sont à l'aide
sociale à l'enfance qui soient
d'ailleurs étranger ou pas étranger et
et c'est le rôle des départements c'est
pas de distinguer les étrangers des
Français c'est de distinguer les enfants
qui doivent être sous protection de la
ze des autres qui sont dans un autre
parcours de vie qui doivent être
peut-être accueilli mais qui doivent
être fait peut-être dans les relations
financières différentes par entre l'État
et le département donc la première
ministre pour répondre àre question
monsieur siti puisqu'il s'agit pas tout
à fait de ma partie ministériel mais
nous nous sommes évidemment concertés
dans la perspective de de ce texte la
première ministre a par annoncé un une
amélioration du financement ça a été dit
pour l'ADF le président sauad l'a
souligné c'est peut-être pas assez mais
c'est avancé de se pose la question en
effet et vous savez bien que Madame
Charlotte cobel prépare un texte et en
lien avec la première ministre avec le
garde des saut sur les mineurs justement
donc le Parlement aura à débattre de
cette question dans les prochains mois
puisqu'on avait encore eu un comité
interministerriel à l'enfance vous le
savez bien la semaine dernière puisqu'il
s'agit là comme je vous l'ai dit pas
d'une décision préfecturale ou du
ministère de l'intérieur mais de ce qui
relève de la justice et du du de de la
petite enfance comme des département
ministériel aura poser la question de la
recentralisation ou non de cette
compétence ou du financement ou non de
cette compétence parce que les
départements o le savez ne demande pas
tous la même chose il y en a qui demande
à garder la compétence mais 100 % du
financement il y en a qui demandent à
transférer cette compétence ce qui est
assez différent donc il une discussion
avoir j'imagine plus complète avec l'ADF
et vous le savez pertinemment et se pose
troisièmement la question de
l'amélioration de notre politique
diplomatico judiciaire on pourrait
l'appeler comme ça pour la reconduite en
tout cas en tout état de cause monsieur
le Président le gouvernement ne fuit pas
le débat simplement il n'a rien avoir
dans ce texte si puisque si ça pose des
questions migratoires ça ne pose pas des
questions qui relèvent de l'autorité
préfectorale mais bien de la mise en
place du système judiciaire et notamment
la protection que le procureur de la
République offre et oblige les
départements à avancer quand le préfet
intervient c'est pour des mises à l'abri
pour des évaluations et de ce point de
vue nous ne refusons pas le débat sur
l'évaluation il y aura des articles de
loi qui parlent de cette évaluation je
ferai constater à Monsieur sioti que le
Sénat a refusé pour l'instant la prise
de contrainte des
des empreintes au mineurs et donc on
aura sans doute une discussion à avoir
lorsque cet article arrivera devant
nous bien je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejet le
108 madame
Diaz oui merci merci monsieur le
Président et bien toujours dans notre
quête de
clarification des du coût de prise en
charge des mineurs non accompagné par le
cont a français nous souhaitons que le
rapport mentionne le coût de prise en
charge des MNA pour chaque département
ce qui permettra de mettre fin à
l'opacité qui entoure réellement
c'est le coût de la prise en charge des
minurs dans la
compagnie rapporteur j'ai déjà répondu
tout à l'heure il n'y a pas d'opacité
madame la députée les chiffres sont tout
à fait connu et d'ailleurs ils ont
permis d'alimenter la discussion entre
monsieur chti et le ministre lui-même
défavorable madame tourgia merci
monsieur le Président bon on savait que
cette cette séquence serait difficile à
vivre tant on entend de l'expression
complètement décomplexée puisqu'elle
s'inscrit dans la loi du du racisme et
de la xénophobie beaucoup ici semblent
oublier ou ignorer que notre humanité
déjà s'est construite sur des parcours
migratoire c'est bien de le rappeler et
de rappeler que dès l'Antiquité
l'Hospital était une vertu sacrée et on
se demande ce qu'il en reste aujourd'hui
par rapport au mineurs non
accompagné c'est c'est effectivement
épouvantable ce qu'on entend et me vient
à l'esprit le le poème de de Jacques
Prévert la chasse à l'enfant on y est
complètement en plein et je veux aussi
souligner l'hypocrisie l'hypocrisie de
de certains ici membres de la majorité
qui trouvent les les amendements du
rassemblement national AB qui n'osent
pas les traiter de racistes mais que
mais que tout le monde observe bien que
le projet de loi que nous examinons qui
s'intitule contrôler l'immigration
améliorer l'intégration est un projet de
loi qui déroule le tapis rouge à ce
qu'il y a de plus raciste et de plus
xénophobe ici dans le Parlement donc
arrêtons cette hypocrisie s'il vous
plaît c'est pas la peine de de dire que
les amendements sont ABS alors que en
fait vous favorisez le dépôt de ce genre
d'amendement madame
yousoufa merci monsieur le Président je
profite de cette discussion pour vous
alerter sur la situation des mineurs non
accompagnés à Mayotte euh auamo à
Mayotte c'est au moins 6 à 9000 mineurs
non accompagnés tous ne sont pas pris en
charge parce que nos infrastructures n'y
Arve pas je veux vous rappeler ça
pourrait vous intéresser certains ici
que pour un budget de 357 millions
d'euros pour le conseil départemental de
Mayotte la protection des mineurs
étrangers coûte à Mayotte 74 millions
d'euros c'est-à-dire 20% du budget du
département de maotte 20 % du budget
pour prendre en charge des mineurs dont
certains sont effectivement barbu on ne
peut pas nier que l'accueil des mineurs
étrangers à Mayotte et l'abandon de
certains volontaires par leurs parents
visent à obtenir des papiers une fois
leur majorité et je pense je pense que
Mayotte n'a aucune leçon à recevoir en
matière d'humanité je m'explique sans
chiffres sans rapport il est impossible
d'obtenir des solutions qui soient à la
à la fois humaines et protectrices pour
les
mineurs continuer sous euh couvert
d'humanité à nier la réalité ne fait
rien avancé pour information de manière
dérogatoire les familles d'accueil à
mayod vont jusqu'à 9U enfants par
famille contre quatre dans l'Hexagone il
n'y a pas assez de formation il n'y a
pas de moyens donc moi je vous alerte
sur le fait
qu'effectivement il y a des routes
migratoires uniquement pour des mineurs
ces enfants sont en danger certains se
font passer des pour des enfants alors
qu'ils brutalis au sein des familles
qu'il brutalisent en classe donc la
nécessité de savoir la réalité de la
minorité d'un individu n'est pas un luxe
c'est une nécessité pour la protection
des plus vulnérables je vous remercie je
le mets au voix qui vote pour contre
rejeté le 350 est retiré le suivant
c'est le 442 qui le défend monsieur
Guiton oui merci monsieur le Président
bon écoutez donc encore dans la dans la
suite de tous nos amendement de
transparence que nous demandons nous
demandons là très concrètement le nombre
d'étrangers se déclarant mineur à leur
arrivée et qui a après vérification par
les autorités compétentes ne le sont pas
donc depuis tout à l'heure le débat a un
petit peu été décrié mais surtout à
tourné autour des mineurs là on parle de
faux mineurs qui sont des vrais majeurs
on parle de personnes qui se sont
déclaré mineurs non accompagné alors
qu'elles ne le sont pas ça veut dire que
ils se sont rendus en situation de
fraude en voulant se faire passer pour
des mineurs pour obtenir et acquérir les
mêmes droits qu'on le droit des mineurs
si on s'en tient au chiffres qu' ont été
donnés tout à l'heure on peut donc
considérer mais justement c'est pour ça
que nous demandons de l'ajout que 80 %
des personnes qui se considèrent MNA ne
le sont pas et sont finalement des
majeurs euh dans notre pays donc ce que
nous vous nous proposons c'est
d'inscrire chaque année dans le rapport
sur l'immigration qui sera rendue et
donc dans le texte le nombre réel de
personnes qui se déclarent à leur
arrivée et qui finalement sont avéré
étant des majeurs ça permettra de
clarifier nos débats ça permettra aussi
d'aider réellement les mineurs qui ont
le statut donc qui ont des droits et des
et de ne pas aider des majeurs qui n'ont
pas les droits et qui en plus de ça se
comporte de manière frauduleuse dès
l'arrivée dans notre pays tout
simplement rapporteur oui là encore ces
chiffres sont connus ils seront bien sûr
dans le rapport il n'y a pas besoin de
le signaler défavorable madame
fossillon merci monsieur le Président à
écouter les débats tels qu'il se
déroulent sur les les mineurs non
accompagnés on on on a le sentiment
aujourd'hui que ce qui arrivent réalité
sont plus nombreux à être réellement
majeurs que mineurs monsieur monsieur de
Courson a cité tout à l'heure un chiffre
pour son département en expliquant que
40 % de ces non non non non monsieur de
Courson tout à l'heure a parlé des 40 %
qui finalement n'étaient pas reconnu
comme mineur il a oublié c'est c'est
toujours fâcheux parce que monsieur de
Courson d'habitude il est très précis
sur les chiffres très très précis mais
il a oublié de parler des recours qui
étaient formulé et dans chez les
tribunaux administratifs et du fait que
et bien environ entre 50 et 80 % en
fonction des départements était
finalement reconnu j'ai dit quoi
administratif judiciaire merci était
finalement reconnu comme étant mineur
donc il oublie la la la fin de
l'histoire c'est-à-dire le fait qu'en
réalité sur celles et ceux qui se
présentent comme mineur dans notre pays
ils sont bien plus nombreux à être
évalués comme étant mineurs que
finalement à être év comme étant majeur
et donc ce que ça dit puisque pendant la
période de recours devant le tribunal
judiciaire et bien ils ne sont la
plupart du temps et dans la plupart des
départements pas mis à l'abri ils
doivent donc soit dormir sous des ponts
soit par parfois appeler le 115 qui dans
ce cas-là les considère comme étant
majeur et personne ne s'inquiète que des
mineurs puisqu'ils sont mineurs et
seront reconnus comme tels dorment avec
des majeurs et ça il y a pas grand monde
ici dans dans cette commission pour
s'inquiéter de savoir qu'il y a des
momes qui toutes les nuits dans notre
pays se retrouvent à dormir avec des
majeurs non pas à cause des majeurs par
le fait simplement que notre évaluation
notre pays n'applique pas la présomption
de minorités pour pouvoir les protéger
deuxème chose ah non sur les coups j'ai
pas le temps je finir après monsieur de
la porte
oui finalement cet amendement c'est à
peu près ce que disait ericotti tout à
l'heure il y a pas grande différence
entre le discours du RN et de LR et
c'est ça qui me surprend monsieur sooti
et le RN ils font semblant de pas voir
la réalité quand on va à Menton par
exemple et moi j'ai été donc à Menton à
la police au frontière on peut voir des
personnes et notamment des personnes qui
se disent majeurs mais qui sont en fait
mineurs parce que vous avez aussi des
faux majeurs parce que vous avez des
personnes qui veulent pas avoir le
traitement des mineurs être pris en
charge dans le système d'aide à
l'enfance et ça existe aussi ça vous en
parler jamais et pour le coup ils sont
enfermés avec les majeurs dans des
conditions indignes mais vous en faites
pas les mineurs à Menton ils sont aussi
dans des conditions indigne et on a
aujourd'hui un autre problème c'est que
le département des Alpes Maritimes a mis
en place un espèce de truc un peu
bizarre qui a un entretien d'évaluation
de minorité préalable mais qui est pas
véritablement la véritable l'évaluation
euh qui est faite normalement avec des
règles et un droit spécial et qui va
permettre de renvoyer des personnes
parce que ils auront passer un quart
d'heure avec un agent du département euh
bah en disant non eux ils sont pas
majeurs ça c'est enfin ils sont pas
mineurs ça c'est la réalité de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans les Alpes
Maritimes on est sur une situation qui
est hors du droit hors des clous et
c'est cela que vous semblez vouloir
généraliser monsieur sooti bah c'est
ceuxa que nous
refusons je finirai parce qu'il me reste
30 secondes si vous voulez président
pour dire une chose 40 millions uros
pour le département des AP maritimes
c'est 1,7 milliards d'euros le budget du
département même si on pourrait penser
que c'est l'État qui doit le prendre en
charge je pense pas que ça soit non plus
insoutenable monsieur le ministre non si
je peux me permettre monsieur le député
sur cette question à Menton et travail
que moi je le dis bien volontiers l'État
est avec le Conseil Départemental des
ales maritimes et c'est pas pases
maritimes que nous le faisons faisons
dans d'autres départements y compris
qu'il partage pas la couleur politique
de Monsieur siti l'évaluation de
minorité elle est importante parce que
il y a une règle de droit qui est assez
simple et elle est tout à fait
respectable aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
notre État de droit si ce sont des
mineurs les policiers ne peuvent pas les
empêcher d'entrer sur le territoire
national si ce sont des majeurs les
policiers peuvent les empêcher de
rentrer sur le territoire national et
ils sont pas renvoyés en dictature ils
sont renvoyés en Espagne ou en Italie
c'est c'est pas voilà c'est regardons
regardons les choses un peu comme il se
faut donc il est évident il est évident
que l'entretien d'évaluation de minorité
à la frontière correspond à ce que doit
faire la France comme tous les États
souverains regarder si ces personnes
sont mineurs ou sont majeurs et sils
sont mineurs on ne peut pas les empêcher
de rentrer c'est bien toute la
difficulté des mineurs isolés s'ils sont
majeurs on peut les empêcher de rentrer
donc qu quand il y a un entretien qui se
fait conseil départemental état sous
l'autorité d'ailleurs des magistrats
parce que évidemment les magistrats
regardent ça le procureur de la
République les parlementaires peuvent y
aller je sais pas monsieur le monsieur
le député vous m'écoutez plus mais moi
je suis allé de très nombreuses fois à
Menton al peut-être que j'ai pas eu de
chance mais j'ai pas rencontré de
mineurs faisant passer pour des majeurs
je je suis allé très nombreuses fois je
passé de très nombreuses heures et nuits
avec les policiers les gendarmes bon
alors peut-être que j'ai pas eu de
chance donc c'est c'est c'est possible
mais c'est c'est j'ai plutôt vu en
revanche des personnes qui en effet se
revendiquaient mineur et qui sur tout de
ressemblance ce n'était pas et ça
empêche en effet les départements sans
large de bien accueillir ces mineurs
voilà parce qu'évidemment ils ont pas de
place il y a aussi partout en France des
gens qui n'arrivent pas à accueillir ces
mineurs pour des raisons financières
qu'évoqué Charles Courson et je parle
pas que des Alpes Maritimes ça peut être
le cas de plein d'autres départements je
pense au des parlementaires qui peuêtre
dans des départements pyrénéens par
exemple bien on va passer au vote si en
fait il y a deux inscrits par amendement
si je prends 6 inscrits on va pas y
arriver donc il y a encore des
amendements mineurs vous serez inscrit
monsieur 6 sur le suivant qui concerne
également les mineurs vous pourrez
répondre je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre jeté le 494
Monsieur cabrat Merci monsieur le
Président bon on vient de sortirune
séquence assez dure quand même
légèrement complotiste parce que selon
Madame Diaz les étudiants ne sont pas
des étudiants selon Madame Le Pen les
familles sont de fauses familles selon
Monsieur gilet et Monsieur cotti les
mineurs ne sont pas mineurs franchement
on commence il y a une question à savoir
oui en effet si les étrangers sont
vraiment échangés là on sort un tout
petit peu de cette mentalité
c'est-à-dire que et pour répondre à nos
collègues qui demandaient pour pourquoi
on déposer des amendements après not
amendement de suppression bah parce
qu'on est obligé de faire comme on peut
pour pouvoir faire vivre le débat et
pour pouvoir avoir des précision une
fois que vos choses iniques se passent
il y a une réalité c'est le traitement
des mineurs et la proposition loi sur
lequel je crois il y a un accord entre
la majorité et la gauche sur
l'interdiction de l'enfermement des
mineurs dans les centres de rétention
administrativ nous nous demandons à ce
qu'elle soit portée à 18 ans au lieu de
16 ans qui a été porté par le Sénat je
me souviens que monsieur le ministre a
était plutôt dans ce sens-là sur
l'interdiction réelle pour les mineurs
d'être enfermés dans les centres de
rétention en dessous de 18 ans mais il y
a une exception dans la loi l'exception
c'est en effet Mayotte à Mayotte on en a
parlé plusieurs fois il y a la
possibilité de l'expulsion des mineurs
et aussi des mineurs isolés et on a eu
un cas assez grave je je vous aveis déjà
alerté c'était il y a quelques années de
cela sur le renvoi d'un enfant français
mineur dans les Comores alors que il
était français de papier sans aucun
problème donc là on essaie de poser ce
débat parce que la question centrale
c'est autour de la zeu en réalité et du
traitement des mineurs accompagnés et
des mineurs accompagnés aussi et en
effet nous nous portons je tiens à le
préciser quand même l'idée que bah il
faut peut-être voir la politique de la
ze de manière complète et totale pour
qu'elle ne pèse plus sur maotte mais en
effet sur l'état et revenir à un
ministère de l'enfance qui soit capable
de de regénéraliser l'intégralité de
laaz en France et non pas le faire
éclater par département et donc créer
des Sit un département a une politique
un autre département a une politique et
fait de la maltraitance pour tous les
enfants monsieur le rapporteur c'est
plutôt un avis de de sagesse parce que
obtenir ces chiffres permettra de
démontrer d'une part que le gouvernement
a fait le choix le ministre de
l'Intérieur en particulier qu'il n'y ait
plus d'enfants dans lescra et nous
aurons donc l'occasion de le démontrer
et d'autant plus que nous voterons je
l'espère non seulement l'article 12
initial du projet de loi mais
l'extension vous l'avez dit vous l'avez
signalé cela a été proposé à plusieurs
reprises cette ouverture a été faite par
le Ministre à l'intérieur jusqu'à 18 ans
pour
l'interdiction de la rétention des
mineurs donc oui sagesse pour que ces
chiffres figurent dans le rapport dont
le Parlement aura à débattre monsieur
CTI oui monsieur le Président merci je
je vais pas répondre aux caricatures de
Monsieur deapport tout à l'heure sur le
département des AL naturellement il
connaît pas le sujet il y a bien entendu
aucun majeur qui veut se faire passer
pour pour un mineur ça c'est du fantasme
vous parlez de de majeur qui seraiit
enfermé aucun majeur ni mineur n'est
enfermé puisque les structures de
placement sont pas des structures
privatives de liberté et d'ailleurs la
plupart de des mineurs ou non mineurs
qui sont placé par l'autorité judiciaire
fugu dans les premières heures ou dans
les premiers jours il y a 7000 MNA qui
sont arrivés en 2023 dans les ales
maritimes nous en avons 1000 dans nos
structures de placement aujourd'hui y
compris malheureusement dans des hôtels
puisque nos structures sont embolisées
mais je voudrais au-delà de de ce débat
caricatural poser une question à
Monsieur le Ministre parce j'ai pas
compris son chiffre tout à l'heure et je
voudrais qu'il le précise à l'on de ce
qu'a dit Madame yosoufa tout à l'heure
pour Mayotte vous parlez de 14000 MNA
dans 86 départements quels sont les
département qui ne sont pas recensés
manifestement Mayotte l'était pas donc
ça fait 14000 plus 7000 quel autre
département est-ce qu'il y a la sain
sainten est-ce qu'il y a Paris est-ce
qu'il y a les départements qui ont
refusé l'enregistrement essentiellement
des départements de de gauche donc il
faut avoir la vérité des chiffres parce
que je le redis on est devant l'amorce
d'une filière migratoire qui ne va
cesser de croître et qui prospère sur
l'exploitation des êtres humains alors
j'ai monsieur benaliss si après monsieur
le ministre va parler
bon remettre un petit peu de de raison
dans dans dans ce débat cher collegti
les gens s'ils s'en vont de chez eux
c'est pas par appel d'air ou ou parce
qu'ils auraient su que en se déclarant
mineur en France il pouvoir dormir sous
les ponts en attendant leur
reconnaissance de minorité et cetera non
en fait ils s'en vont de chez eux parce
que ça se passe mal chez eux c'est c'est
un peu ça le point de départ en fait
faudrait peut-être pas l'oublier et
deuxième élément euh a qui sont accil
des mineurs non accompagnés mis à l'onne
de l'Aide Sociale à l'enfant ça abondo
tout ça une confusion est faite en
disant regardez il y a des départements
qui sont sinistrés on narrive plus à
accueillir les mineurs à cause des
mineurs non accompagnés et surtout des
majeurs qui se font passer pour des
mineurs non accompagnés il me semble que
le fait que le département du Nord soit
sinistré sur son accueil d'ê sociale à
l'enfance c'est pas du tout pour des
mineurs non accompagn c'est pour des
gamins qui sont dans des familles qu'on
laisse dans leur famille où il sont
violentés brutalisés et jour après jour
et tout le monde s'en fiche et les MNA
n'ont rien à voir avec ça pas même ceux
qui se déclare majeur
faussement donc arrêtez de faire croire
que parce que on s'occuperait plus mal
des MNA ou plus mal des majeurs
faussement déclarés mineurs qu'on
règlerait le problème de tous les
enfants dans ce pays c'est pas vrai ça
c'est la c'est la deuxième chose et
ensuite je quand même voudrais rappeler
que peut-être
que si on accueillait aussi dignement
les majeurs peut-être qu'il y aurait pas
une course effrainée à se déclarer
absolument mineur pour sauver sa peau
parce que quand les gens quand les gens
partent de chez eux pas de bon cœur oui
ils font tout ce qui en leur pouvoir
pour
survivre pour avoir un abri pour avoir
un toit sur la tête en fait en fait en
réalité pour être reconnu comme une
seule et unique chose des êtres humains
monsieur le
ministre je
peut-être après la pause du dîner
monsieur je vous donnerai la liste ex si
ça vous va maotte n'est pas dedans comme
la plupart des territoires ultramarins
parce qu'il nont pas encore mis
totalement Laem en place donc c'est ce
que j'ai d'ailleurs précisé tout à
l'heure je l'ai fait donc je donnerai
après le dîner monsieur CTI la liste des
une dizaine de collectivités qui ne sont
pas dedans peut-être juste dire à
Monsieur bernalis que je le pldoyer est
intéressant mais mais il est pas vrai
parce que il se trouve que Monsieur
Bernis dans le même départ vous j'ai été
à la fois conseil départemental ma donc
j'ai géré dans ma commune qui est la
deuxème du département le sujet non non
mais vous pouvez rire sur votre diatri
mais comme manifestement on est du même
département et que vous n'avez pas géré
une vie locale pardon monsieuris vous
êtes vous êtes assez décalé avec la
réité des choses ce qui est vrai c'est
que dans les foyers dans les foyers
départementaux il y a par placement du
magistrat des personnes qui sont en fait
majeur et qui prennent la place dans un
département qui est très touché
socialement et on peut le partager des
personnes qui sont mineurs et il y a en
effet des centaines peut-être des
milliers de gamins qui soient étrangers
ou qui soient français qui ne sont pas
accueillis dans l'a social en France je
vous ai pas je vous ai pas contredit je
vous ai pas contit monsieur bernalicis
mais monsieur monsieur Bernis c'est pas
vous avez perdu les élections c'est pas
très grave bon vous avez non vous avez
essayé de alors vous avez essayé de
représenter les élus locaux sénatorielle
on a vu comment ça s'est terminé on
parlait pas à leur nom voilà c'est pas
pas bon ce que je veux B allez allez
monsieur vous êtes passé de zéro vous
êtes passé à zéro au carré évidemment
sénatorial ça marque bon monsieur
bernalicis Mo encour pas le débat
électoral sénatorial encoursur Bernal
s'il vous plaî monsieur bernalicis je
vous encourage avoir un discours de
vérité sur ce sujet on pourrait tous
partir du principe et vous même vous
l'avez dit puisque finalement dans votre
deuxième argumentation vous dites c'est
normal qu'il se fasse passer pour des
mineurs parce qu'on naccueille pas les
majeurs bah ça c'est un autre sujet mais
donc la place c'est la place des mineurs
la place des mineurs est dans l'Aide
Sociale à l'Enfance protection d' un
département très touché comme le nôtre
et Madame fossillon a parfaitement
raison il y a dans notre mauvaise
organisation générale par le fait des
financements par le fait du nombre de
personnes et en fait on dit tous à peu
près des choses qui se complète et qui
correspond réité quel que soit les
groupes politiques une difficulté c'est
pour ça que le gouvernement va présenter
au début de l'année prochaine un texte
qui concernera les mineurs et leur
accueil et c'est tout à fait normal et
le relation avec les départements mais
ne confondons pas les choses je veux
redire une nouvelle fois que si les
majeurs se font passer pour mineurs
c'est pas simplement parce qu'ils sont
accueillis dans les départements c'est
parce que c'est l'autorité judiciaire
qui décide de leur reconduite et que
l'autorité judiciaire qui s en
reconduite je pense que ça se compte sur
les doigts d'une main les décisions de
justice qui reconduisent des mineurs
dans leur pays d'origine alors que ce
n'est pas le cas des décisions
préfectorales voilà pourquoi en général
les majeurs essaient de se faire passer
pour des mineurs voilà on peut les
comprendre mais simplement c'est pas
leur place d'être dans ce système et
c'est notre travail comme tous les pays
européens d'évaluer d'évaluer leur minor
le majorité bien on vote qui vote pour
qui vote
contre qui vote
pour qui vote contre donc il est
adopté le
484 qui le
défend allez-y oui monsieur le Président
chers
collègues cet
amendement vise à ajouter dans le
rapport du gouvernement un indicateur
sur le nombre de place occupé en centre
d'accueil pour demandeurs d'asile de
recours aux solutions provisoires
structures Collectiv ou les hôtels ainsi
que la durée d'occupation alors pourquoi
parce qu'il est essentiel de disposer
d'une information complète pour évaluer
au mieux les orientations pluriannuelles
de la politique d'immigration et
d'intégration lors du débat annuel parce
qu'il est nécessaire de s'assurer que la
règle sur l'occupation des centres
d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile est
appliqué et mesurer les abus éventuels
euh milita également nécessaire
d'évaluer l'ampleur du recours aux
solutions
provisoires les structures d'accueil et
hôtel et d'identifier et de mesurer les
abus merci monsieur le rapporteur oui
défavorable parce que le nombre de
places occupées en cada est évidemment
connu et publicque monsieur bernalis
oui alors c'est c'est-à-dire que c'est
vrai qu'il il peut y avoir un sujet
parce que on accueille mal et en plus on
met les gens dans des hôtels ou où ça
peut être mythux où il y a qui coûte
beaucoup
d'argent finalement on pourrait avoir
des vraies structures d'accueil plutôt
que de passer par les hôtels c'est c'est
le c'est le premier point mais quand
même redire que parce que le l'histoire
nous a fait la démonstration que moins
enfin plus on aueiller mal et plus
cétait la pagaille un exemple par
exemple monsieur le ministre vous
connaissez peut-être un certain Nicolas
Sarkozi qui avait fait fermer en grande
pompe un accueil à s Gat je sais parce
que à l'époque j'étais au lycée à côté à
Calais euh et et j'avais vu ce ministre
venir et dire oui à sang Gat on va
fermer parce que Ben comme les gens ils
seront pas accueillis et ben ils
viendront
plus et bon ben on a la suite de
l'histoire la suite de l'histoire oui je
vous ai pas fait l'imitation j'étais
sympa mais la suite de l'histoire c'est
quoi c'est que les gens ont quand même
continué à arriver ils étaient quand
même mal accueillis ils étaient encore
plus en difficulté en précarité et
d'ailleurs pouvait provoquer davantage
de nuisance euh par rapport au voisinage
et à la fin on aboutit sur la question
de la jungle de calé et la situation
inique qu'on a aujourd'hui est
scandaleuse où on disperse euh les les
personnes réfugiés les personnes exilées
façon puzzle en espérant qu'ils soi
invisiblebles en interdisant la
distribution de repas en centre-ville
parce qu'on ferme un accueil bien
joué bien joué donc effectivement euh
peut-être que si on utilisait moins euh
les hôtels si on utilisait plus des
structures en dur qui montrent la
grandeur aussi euh de la France et la
reconnaissance pour tout êtrre humains
pour simplement je le rappelle on va
être pénible avec ça juste son humanité
qui n'a pas besoin de se démontrer en
soi puisque c'est un être humain c'est
un semblable je pense que qu'on qu'on
aurait progressé monsieur le ministre
alors Monsieur Baris là encore pardon
mais je crois que vous dites pas les
choses telles qu'elles sont quand
Nicolas Sarkozi a F sangat mais même
quand Bernard casneuve et je pense qu'on
peut rendre hommage au travail qu'a fait
Bernard casenu dans bah si c'est
quelqu'un deimportant Bernard casenu à
grande à calé il y a aujourd'hui 20 fois
moins de migrants que lorsque Nicolas
Sarkozi a fermé sangat et 15 fois moins
que lorsque Bernard casazenu a mis fin
on va dire à la jungle telle qu'elle
était appelé à grande sainte et et à
sang Gat bon donc d'abord un ce n'est
pas vrai qu'il y a plus de migrants
aujourd'hui qu' en avait à S ou à grande
sainte calé c'est tout à fait faux
monsieur ber c'est tout à fait faux vous
le savez pertinemment donc évidemment
l'action que peuvent mener les min
intérieur qui soit de droite ou de
gauche quand ils sont en responsabilité
évidemment montre une efficacité
deuxièmement vous dites disperser bon
pardon mais vous savez combien il y a de
place d'accueil en ce moment même dans
le Nord pask sement dans le littoral il
y a plus de 1000 places d'accueil et les
les les migrants qui veulent traverser
et encore migrant est un mot sans doute
qui est impropre parce qu'il y a
plusieurs on va dire vérité derrière ce
mot veulent aller en Angleterre ils
veulent pas aller à calé à villeen
d'esque à tourcoin ou ou à Nice ils
veulent aller en Angleterre donc il
veulent pas aller dans des centres
d'hébergement ils veulent même pas
déposer l'asile moins de 4 % dépos
d'asile aidés par des associations
souvent qui leur propose quand l'État ne
le fait pas et pourtant l'État le fait
courageusement en lien avec les
collectivités locales moins de 4 % parce
qu'ils veulent aller en Angleterre donc
la question n'est pas une question
d'accueil sur le littoral monsieur
encore laissons mais non mais ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas le cas et puis quand
vous parlez pardon d'interdiction de
repas vous savez très bien qu's ont été
demandés par les élus locaux en
l'occurrence nous les suivons et
deuxièmement validés par tous les
tribunaux validés par sous les tribunaux
et vous avez été bien sûr que si et
quand vous avez contesté et vous-même
vous avez et vous-même vous avez été
verbalisé vous le savez bien euh pour
voilà parce que vous nvez pas respecter
le droit et cette amende effectivement
était soutenue donc vous dites pardon
monsieur mais n'importe quoi sire
d'humanité ils veulent aller en
Angleterre la vérité la réussite la
réussite de la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière notamment sur
le littoral où vous ne citez jamais les
policiers les gendarmes qui
courageusement plonge dans une eau à
5°grés pour sauver des bébés des femmes
et des hommes parce que à chaque fois
vous préférez attaquer les forces de
l'ordre alors qu'ils font un travail
humanitaire extrêmement forte j'ai
vousavez pas encore parlé mais
j'anticipe de votre votre votre chemin
d'après mais monsieur Bern la vérité
c'est qu'il faut un traité il faut un
traité international avec la
Grande-Bretagne pour une route
d'immigration de demande d'asile
classique pour ça faut croire en
l'Europe c'est pas ce que vous faites
alors Monsieur Dumont avant qu'on
vote merci monsieur le Président ouais
j'ai entendu mon mon collègue bernalicis
expliqua que le cand sang Gat ou la
jungle de Calais était la panassée était
quelque chose d'absolument merveilleux
vous savez moi je suis le député de Cala
et si vous vous y avez fait vos études
moi j'y vis et j'étais mère d'une
commune juste à côté de Calais et je
peux vous dire Monsieur monsieur
bernalicis que quand vous avez dans une
jungle le plus grand bidonville d'Europe
qui fait plus de 10000 personnes que
vous avez dans une situation où
malheureusement vous avez de la
prostitution vous avez des meurtres vous
avez des Rix je ne suis pas certain que
ce soit la panassée
et monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
l'a dit les migrants qui sont à calés
sur le littoral grande sainte étaple
partout ailleurs ne veulent pas rester
ils veulent partir ils veulent traverser
et vous avez aussi certaines pardon vous
le dire associations qui sont proches de
vos idées politiques qui les incitent à
ne pas déposer l'asile et qui leur
disent vous êtes mieux à tenter la
traverser à mourir dans la Manche à la
mer du Nord plutôt qu'à déposer l'asile
en France c'est pour ça que vous avez
aujourd'hui des bébés éitréen pour ça
que vous avez des Afghans c'est pour ça
que vous avez des CDES quel que soit
leur nationalité qui vont mourir dans la
Manche et dans la mer du Nord pas de
souci j'en ai absolument aucun aucun
problème il y a aujourd'hui des
associations vous vous laissez parler
monsieur duumont il y a aujourd'hui des
associations qui font du contre-emploi
qui viennent derrière les agents de
l'État et qui Incit à ne pas déposer des
demandes d'asile et qui font qu'il y a
aujourd'hui des mort dans la Manche et
dans la mer du Nord c'est ça la réalité
du territoire et je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire que les élul vous et votre
groupe politique vous et l'extrême
gauche que on est dans une situation où
aujourd'hui à calé les éus locaux les
éus nationaux font tout pour ne pas
accueillir c'est absolument faux la
réalité pardon de le dire et j'en
terminerai par là c'est que dès qu'on a
ouvert un centre d'accueil que çaaelit
sangat ou le camp Jul Ferri il y a eu
des bid enville et c'est là où il a le
plus de on passe au vot qui vot vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté le
345 madame Diaz merci monsieur le
Président donc nous nous souhaitons
toujours enrichir ce rapport et nous
souhaitons que ce rapport précise en
tout cas indique un suivi du lieu
d'installation effective des
travailleurs en situation irrégulière
qui ont obtenu le titre de séjour visé
par l'article 4 B du projet de loi en
fait cet amendement vise à faire de la
PR une prévention d'éventuel
détournement ou une prévention
d'éventuel dévoiement du dispositif
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
espérons que vous allez le voter
monsieur rapporteur
oui j'ai du mal à comprendre ce que ça
veut dire que le lieu d'installation
effective des bénéficiires d'un titre de
séjour pourtant la mention au
travailleur temporaire c'est quoi c'est
le lieu de travail c'est le lieu
d'habitation c'est la résidence
secondaire non je crois que là il faut
être un peu sérieux et puis par ailleurs
vous demanderiez par conséquent que le
rapport remis par le gouvernement au
Parlement descend de commune par commune
pour connaître le lieu d'installation
effective des bénéficiires donc je crois
que ce n'est pas très sérieux
défavorable madame Diaz
oui je pense que c'est l'intervention de
monsieur le rapporteur qui n'est pas
très sérieuse je imaginer qu'une
personne en situation d'irrégularité
pourrait en fait viendrait dans un
métier en tension dont on sait qu'il est
peu rémunérer et si cette personne
bénéficiait d'une résidence secondaire
je trouve cela assez curieux donc ne
faites pas mine de pas avoir compris la
portée de notre amendement nous nous
disons il y a un risque de dévoiement de
votre article 4 bis c'est-à-dire des
personnes pourraient dire on vient
s'installer dans telle zone mentionnée
par la carte qui précise les zone
entention et finalement s'installer
ailleurs juste pour bénéficier de de ce
titre de séjour particulièrement
avantageux donc j'espère que j'ai été
plus clair dans mon expression et donc
j'espère que vous ferez preuve de bonne
foi en vontant pour notre amendement
alors Monsieur rapporteur voulez
répondre non mais simplement d'ailleurs
le titre travailleur temporaire ne
concernera pas simplement les personnes
qui serai éventuellement régularisé au
titre deticle un titre beaucoup plus
général qui n'est pas rattaché encore
une fois à ce seul article que nous nous
débtrons dans quelques dans quelques
jours vous parlez des situations
régulières et là vous vous évoquez dans
l'amendement les personnes qui
bénéficient d'un titre qui sont bien en
situation
régulière
Monsieur Merci monsieur le Président je
trouve çatr intéressant le débat qu'on a
sur le sujet de l'immigration parce que
souvent on parle d'immigration comme ça
en donnant des nom de pays et puis en
parlant de telle ou telle situation mais
sans la prendre au global tout à l'heure
monsieur sooti nous a parlé de la Côte
d'Ivoire en nous disant ah c'est la
catastrophe il y a plein d'Ivoiriens qui
habitent qui qui arrivent dans notre
pays et cetera et cetera savez-vous que
nous avons avec la Côte d'Ivoire un
commerce excédentaire de 325 million
d'euros que donc la Côte d'Ivoire dans
les échanges si on prend global tout ce
qui se passe avec la Côte d'Ivoire on
leur vole chaque année 325 millions
d'euros ah bah oui quand on le dit comme
ça ça vous choque hein ah quand on le
dit comme ça ça vous choque et oui ça
vous choque que il y a en Côte d'Ivoire
le groupe Total qui exploite les
ressources de la Côte d'Ivoire que
Monsieur Boloré pendant des années qui
est votre ami et qui fait des chaînes
pour se plaindre de l'immigration a eu
pendant des années à exploiter pendant
des années des infrastructures en Côte
d'Ivoire bref que nous avons participé
au pillage économique de la Côte
d'Ivoire et quand on le dit comme ça ça
vous choque et quand ensuite les gens
arrivent dans notre pays et bien vous
voulez les repousser même chose pour
l'éritrée que nous proposez-vous de
renvoyer les gens dans un pays qui est
une dictature de renvoyer les gens dans
un pays où le PIB par habitant est 971 €
c'est ça que vous nous proposer 76 € par
mois c'est ça que vous nous proposez on
est en train de parler de situation
humaine de pauvreté de raisons pour
lesquelles les gens quittent leur pays
parce qu'ils ont envie de venir en aide
à leur famille ça vous parle normalement
la famille non la droite hein mais quand
c'est la famille des autres quand c'est
des gens qui ont une couleur de peau qui
est différente de la vôre vous comprenez
plus vous comprenez plus ce que c'est
que la famille et ben oui je suis désolé
ça vous choque quand on vous dit les
choses comme ça mais c'est ça c'est ça
le racisme c'est ça qu'il y a derrière
c'est quand on ne voit pas dans les
autres des êtres humain à parité avec
nous et justement quand on pose la
question de la situation des gens il
faut les prendre au global voilà c'est
ça qu'on essaie de vous dire et par
ailleurs pour ce qui concerne
l'Angleterre et le RoyaumeUni il en a
marre de faire les gardes de FME du
royaume c'est terminé donc par contre
j'espère que chacun apprécie à sa juste
valeur le débat sur tous les cavet
législatifs que nous vivons voilà je
mets au voie l'amendement qui vote pour
qui vote contre il est rejeté le 357
madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président donc
avec cet amendement nous souhaitons
faire apparaître dans le rapport des
précisions relatives à la nationalité
des individus concernés par des mesures
d'éloignement et des décisions
prononcées en ce sens et si vous refusez
notre amendement ce qu'on pensera c'est
que vous n'assumez pas la politique
internationale catastrophique que vous
menez ou alors l'échec de vos relations
diplomatiques avec des pays-tiers alors
c'est exactement ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui parce que quand on regarde
les chiffres en 2021 on constate
que plus de 21000 donc
21452 mesures ont été prononcées à
l'égard d'individus de nationalité
algérienne et seulement 754 de ces
mesures ont été exécutées et à l'échelle
du pays ce sont 143000 mesures
d'éloignements qui ont été prononcés
pour seulement 13000 exécutés alors le
problème c'est que nous perdons la
France à cause de votre politique perd
toute crédibilité en la matière et nous
nous ne souhaitons pas au rassemblement
national que notre politique migratoire
dépendent du bon vouloir des autres pays
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
vous demandons de vous ressaisir et de
changer rapidement de paradigme monsie
rapporteur
oui les les chiffres concernant le délai
moyen de mise en œuvre d'une mesure
d'éloignement sont connus là encore il
est inutile de l'ajouter estfvorable
madame
Rousseau moi je vous propose qu'on ait
aussi des chiffres sur leur pointure
leur taille leur enin je sais pas des
trucs un peu intéressants quoi sur les
personne parce que là manifestement vous
voulez vraiment les fichers tout vous
voulez tout savoir sur eux bah écoute
allons jusqu'au bout et demandons la
pointure leur pointure leur taille de
vêtement leur mensuration et puis je
voudrais bien aussi des statistiques
genré parce que quand même là je vous
entends pas trop là-dessus donc ce
serait quand même intéressant non mais
en fait là en fait c'est quoi votre but
quel est votre but c'est qu'on fasse des
quotas par pays maintenant c'est qu'en
fait non seulement on est un quota
français mais en plus qu'on est des
quotas par pays et là on va pouvoir
négocier pays par pays en la la
politique diplomatique qu'on va avoir en
fonction de histoire qu'on a par pays
mais franchement vous vous rendez compte
un peu du ridicule dans lequel on est là
dans en France dans dans ce débat là qui
à la fin finit par une espèce de de vous
qui dénoncez l'orgie administrative mais
là on est dans une espèce de trombose
administrative en plus enfin vraiment
rien n'a de sens dans vos amendements
madame Diaz
oui juste pour répondre à Madame
Rousseau ça n'étonnera personne madame
Rousseau votre comportement et vos
propos sont absolument caricaturaux
évidemment nous ne souhaitons pas
demander les mensurations des
clandestins nous souhaitons juste
connaître la nationalité des personnes
faisant l'objet d'une mesure
d'éloignement de manière à ce que la
France puisse reprendre la main sur ses
capacités en matière de diplomatie je
vois pas ce qui vous choque là-dedans si
ce n'est votre aveuglement ou votre
dénis ou votre appétence pour cette
idéologie immigrationniste qui vous
plaît tant mais qui fait tant de mal au
français je le mets au voix qui vote
pour
qui vote contre rejeté le
387 monsieur gilet oui monsieur le
Président chers collègu selon les
données du ministère de l'Intérieur tel
que rapporté dans un document du Sénat
en 2020 seulement 7 % des
UTF ont été effectivement mis en œuvre
laissant ainsi 93 % de ces mesures non
exécuté un tel échec ne peut pas rester
sans réponse l'échec de de la non
exécution des eqtf c'est d'ailleurs
l'échec aussi du ministre de l'Intérieur
il faut le rappeler c'est important de
le rappeler avec des otf respectés une
fillette n'aurait pas été violée le 10
février 2022 à vénicieux paramarocain
Lola serait toujours en vie Dominique
Bernard également le 24 novembre 2023 un
jeune de 18 ans n'aurait pas été agressé
au couteau à Brest claire qui a témoigné
longuement ces dernières semaines
n'aurait pas été violé et étranglé dans
le hall de son immeuble par un sans abri
sous qtf là aussi voilà l'objet de cet
amendement de de rappeler la réalité des
faits de rappeler que des dizaines et
des dizaines de Français chaque semaine
chaque jour même sont les victimes
d'étrangers sous qtf parce qu'ils sont
dangereux et il y a donc nécessité de
les expulser merci
oui merci monsieur le Président nous
aurons l'occasion de vous répondre
monsieur le député lorsque nous
étudierons je parle sous le contrôle du
rapporteur Pradal les articles 9 les
suivants qui consistent à lever un
certain nombre de protection mais dans
dans l'immédiat au au-delà de l'outrange
d' certain nombre de vos propos
simplement sur les questions
d'éloignement que ce soit par pays par
nationalité sur toute une série de
données chiffrées que vous allez encore
énumérer d'ici quelques instants les
données existent c'est bien le débat
c'est bien le sens de vos amendements
par conséquent défavorable mon cabrat
oui merci monsieur le Président toujours
difficile de répondre après avoir
entendu une litanie venant de la part de
charognard les famille elle-même demande
à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
d'instrumentalisation et vous le faites
vous vous moquez des victimes vous les
utilisez que pour votre agenda et vous
êtes vraiment mais vraiment sur ça la
preuve c'est même plus le racisme c'est
c'est même plus l'ignominie c'est la
preuve de votre déshumanité moi je vais
essayer de revenir aux choses sérieuses
parce que votre amendement est d'une
bêtse sans nonom monsieur le ministre
l'a reconnu alors il est plus là mais il
se reconnaîtra que actuellement il y a 7
% en effet d'qtf exécuté je rappelle que
il y a cela un an il nous avait dit de
toute façon qu'on produisait de l'qtf à
la masse dans ce pays hein et déjà il va
falloir quand même revoir un jour ou
l'autre notre politique d'obligation de
quitter le territoire français parce que
elle ne correspond à aucune réalité
elles sont d'ailleurs toutes contestées
à 50 % au moins devant les tribunaux et
cassé bien heureusement mais nous
faisons 14000 renvois dans ce pays 14000
renvois d'éléments dangereux il y a même
des erreurs récemment nous avons eu un
retour parce que le ministre ne respecte
pas le droit et préfère faire du renvoi
alors que le jugement n'est pas encore
tombé et par exemple les autres pays
européens sont dans les mêmes moyennes
13000 à peu près pour l'Allemagne 10000
pour l'Italie il n'y a pas une politique
excessive de l'qtf en France il y a une
un ciblage envers des populations et au
bout d'un moment il va falloir arrêter
d'instrumentaliser comme a pu le dire
aujourd'hui euh monsieur beer ancien
ancien criminologue les étrangers ne
sont pas surreprésentés dans les crimes
ce sont les Français et les Françaises
qui sont sur représentés dans les crimes
donc arrêtez d'instrumentaliser des
peurs arrêtez d'instrumentaliser des
morts ça nous dessert toute la nation et
de toute façon ça monre votre vrai
visage alors avant de donner la parole à
Madame Rousseau je précise que j'ai des
vice-présidents y compris de
l'opposition qui me demande de passer à
une minute donc je vous invite à la
concision
madame
Rousseau puisque vous voulez absolument
puisque vous voulez absolument
instrumentaliser les fait divers
allons-y jusqu'au bout là il y a un des
10 plus grands pédocriminels au monde
qui vient d'être arrêté enfin dont le
procès vient de commencé aujourd'hui il
a été arrêté en France il était
cantonnié et il est de il est de
français à mon avis de 10 générations
donc en fait si vous voulez
instrumentaliser les les faits divers et
ben allez-y jusqu'au bout et si tous les
violeurs étaient des immigr ben ça
saurait j'ai envie de vous dire donc en
fait là ce que vous faites c'est que
vous utilisez des faits divers pour
essayer de retourner une opinion
publique mais nous ne sommes pas DUP et
nous résisterons à
cela je mets au voix qui vote pour
contre rejeté le 353 madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président alors
l'immigration coûte cher même si c'est
difficile de connaître les coûts
exacts au regard des données qui nous
sont sont disponibles et au regard des
rejets au regard du sort que vous avez
réservé à nos amendements toutefois euh
nous nous souhaitons éclaircir un point
via cet amendement nous souhaitons
connaître le montant de la prise en
charge juridictionnelle parce qu'en fait
il y a à la fois le coût de
l'immigration mais en plus il y a les
coûts que représentent les contentieux
générés par les étrangers que ça soit
dans l'ordre judiciaire ou dans l'ordre
administratif c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous souhaitons au nom de la
bonne information que l'État doit
français nous souhaitons par cet
amendement que les coûts directs et
indirects en matière de charges
juridictionnell soient explicités dans
le rapport mon rapporteur
oui défavorable monsieur Lucas
oui moi je vais vous dire Madame Dias ce
qui coûte cher c'est la politique
brutale et répressive de la France qui
croit encore qu'elle peut interrompre un
phénomène humain qui est celui de la
migration j'étais à brillançon plusieurs
collègues y sont allés également quand
vous vous avez un escadron de
gendarmerie qu'on ramène de Toulouse
dont les gendarmes même nous disent
qu'il passent leur temps à courser dans
la neige des gens qui tentent de
survivre qu'ils arrêtent des gens qui
seront remis aux autorités italiennes
qui reviendront le lendemain ou le
surlendemain ou le surlendemain et qui
finiront par passer les gendarmes même
nous disent on freine mais on arrête
rien ce qui coûte cher c'est votre
politique ce qui coûte cher c'est une
politique combien coûterit l'expulsion
de tous ceux que vous voulez expulser
extrêmement cher bien plus cher que
l'inclusion bien plus cher que de leur
permettre de travailler dans de bonnes
conditions dignement et d'lever leurs
enfants ici bien plus cher que l'aide
médicale l'État en réalité pour les
finances publiques la politique raciste
et xénophobe que vous proposez elle est
scandaleusement considérable en terme de
gabg donc là aussi moi je vais vous dire
ce qui coûte cher on va regarder ce qui
coûte cher dans les mesures que vous
proposez et vous avez raison il y a
effectivement en matière migratoire des
politiques qui coûtent très cher ce sont
celles de brutalité et de fermeture je
mets au voix qui vote pour contre rejeté
le 36 6 madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président donc
par cet amendement nous souhaitons
connaître le montant de l'aide médicale
d'État
qui est accordé à ceux qui ne devraient
pas en
bénéficier monsieur le rapporteur bon
par définition aucune personne qui
bénéficie de la me ne devrait pas en
être bénéficiaire
défavorable madame
Martin c'est c'est ce qui est compliqué
un peu dans ce débat c'est que une
partie des députés dont en particulier
ceux du front nation du rassemblement
national font fi des raisons pour
lesquelles les gens partent de chez eux
comme si c'était quelque chose de facile
et d'Odin et considère au fond que ces
personnes viennent dans l'idée de
pouvoir entre guillemets profiter d'un
système sur laame c'est 38 cas qui ont
été repérés l'année dernière et qui
étaient discuta dans le fait d'en
bénéficier en en revanche c'est un
pourcentage très important de personnes
qui pourrai y avoir droit et qui ne le
demande pas le de une sur deux le
deuxième élément c'est que si l'on prend
l'exemple par de l'Espagne l'Espagne
avait supprimé la me et au bout de 2 ans
l' remis en place y compris pour des
raisons de santé publique troisième
élément qu'on peut éventuellement
ajouter c'est qu'à Mayotte la n'existe
pas ça n'empêche pas les gens d'arriver
donc arrêtez d'avoir toujours cette idée
sous-jacente selon laquelle les gens
partent de chez eux pour profiter d'un
système qui entre nous est devenu bien
maigre au fur et à mesure des
gouvernements libéraux qui depuis bien
longtemps se sont succédés madame
ysoufa madame excusez-moi de vous porter
la contradiction mais effectivement il
n'y a pas d'aide médicale d'État à
Mayotte notre seul hôpital dans notre
désert médical
est géré par une enveloppe unique et la
moitié de la patientelle à Mayotte est
étrangère c'est-à-dire qu'elle ne
contribue pas ne paye pas ses soins ne
paye pas ses ses ses accouchements par
dérogation uniquement la gravité de la
situation à Mayotte c'est que
aujourd'hui le le le service des
urgences est en effondrement total et
que là vous êtes en train de dire
finalement ça n'a rien à voir avec les
patients qu'on reçoit on est au point
aujourd'hui on est avec des quissas
médicaux c'est-à-dire que l'hôpital de
Moroni l'hôpital de Domoni envoie des
bateaux et prévient et prévient et
prévient l'hôpital de Mayotte en disant
on envoie un hélico on mobilise une
ambulance des quelques dizaines
d'ambulances qu'il y a à Mayotte pour
aller prendre en charge des étrangers
qui ont organisé leur voyage pour se
faire soigner par bateau gratuitement à
Mayotte comment est-ce que vous voulez
face à vos compatriotes de Mayotte qui
ont 10 ans de moins d'espérance de vie
qui subissent un désert médical
expliquer que c'est normal tout système
ne n'arrive à tenir que si on y
contribue
c'est une anomalie c'est une aberration
de de d'utiliser Mayotte pour justifier
justifier l'injustifiable on est
aujourd'hui nous Maoré en train de payer
dans notre chair votre générosité qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui vous refusez vous
refusez la solidarité nationale il y a
pas d'ame il y a pas il y a pas de
circulaire tobira pour prendre en charge
les mineurs et vous osez parler de
maotes venez et venez et regardez la
situation et là vous nous parlerez
quelque chose bien alors on va pas s'il
vous plaît je mets au voix l'amendement
qui vote pour qui vote contre il est
rejeté le 1106 Monsieur housoussin Merci
monsieur le Président il s'agit de faire
figurer dans le rapport le nombre
d'étrangers ayant fait l'objet d'une
décision d'éloignement qui n'a pas été
exécuté alors même que précédemment ils
ont fait l'objet d'une condamnation
définitive pour des crimes ou délit
qu'ils ont commis sur le sol français on
sait que les décisions d'éloignement ce
soit les interdictions du territoire ou
les otf ont des taux d'exécution qui
sont qui sont très faibles on aimerait
avoir des détails sur les personnes qui
ont été condamnées et pour qui ces
décisions ne sont finalement pas exécuté
il s'agit à la fois d'informer les
Français et puis aussi d'en faire une
priorité c'est-à-dire qu'on puisse
identifier en particulier ces chiffres
et ces personnes pour que le
gouvernement dans son action puisse
faire de leur expulsion et du fait qu'il
quitent le territoire français une
prioritésie rapporteur oui merci
monsieur le Président le chiffre est
connu le ministre de l'Intérieur a eu
l'occasion de dire à plusieurs reprises
qu'il y avait actuellement sur le sol
national 4000 personnes qui ne sont pas
expulsables au regard des protections
qui proviennent de la suppression de la
double peine il y a déjà plus d'une
vingtaine d'années donc ces chiffres
sont absolument connus ils figureront
bien sûr dans les éléments qui
permettront au au Parlement de débattre
défavorable ils font même l'objet d'un
article 9 et 10 du projet de loi
monsieur Lucas monsieur madamemeill
alors non très rapidement parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on on en arrive au terme
des demandes que vous faites mais moi ce
qui me surprend c'est que vous demandez
qu'on inscrive des choses qui existent
déjà et et je voudrais pas que au
travers de vos amendement est du fait
qu'il soit rejeté que l'on soit dans une
société où on refuse la transparence et
que l'on mette en avant l'opacité en
fait si on refuse vos amendements c'est
parce que ça existe déjà c'est parce
qu'il y a déjà dans les rapports les con
essens que vous réclamez donc je crois
que c'est extrêmement important ne vous
ne pense je ne veux surtout pas qu'on
pense que par ces amendements vous
démontrez et bien que on est dans un
territoire où on ne sait rien et que
grâce à vous enfin on va savoir les
choses en réalité c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe on a les chiffres il faut
aller les
chercher bien je le mets au voix qui
vote pour qui vote contre rejeté le 516
madame
tanzili merci monsieur le Président euh
à l'instar de l'amendement que nous
avons adopté de notre collègue Cécile
huntermer en fait je vous propose
d'ajouter au rapport que le gouvernement
présentera au Parlement des éléments
d'information sur les moyens financiers
et humains d'évolu au bureau des
étrangers au sein des préfectures et sur
les délais de traitement des demandes
qu'ils ont à instruire il me semble en
effet que ces deux sujets sont une
composante essentielle du débat objet de
cet article car malgré une augmentation
des effectifs concernés de 56 % en 10
ans nous constatons toujours un
engorgement des services avec des
frustrations tant pour le personnel que
les demandeurs et avec des conséquences
juridictionnelles importantes puisque
les demandeurs saisissent régulièrement
le juge administratif comme l'indique le
Conseil d'État pour faire constater la
carence de l'État voilà je vous remercie
oui favorable il faudra simplement pour
la séance qu'on travaille à à les
connecter ensemble je parle de
l'amendement de céer que nous avons
adopté il y a déjà quelques quelques
heures madame
rol
merci merci monsieur le Président euh je
trouve cet amendement très intéressant
surtout dans ces euh argumentaire
puisque il y a de ça 1hure ou 1h30 nous
avons eu la même discussion sur la
nécessité euh de flécher les fond là où
ils étaient nécessaires et que monsieur
le rapporteur vous nous avez expliqué
que tout avait déjà été voté dans la
lopmie qu'il n'y avait aucun souci et
que donc tout était déjà là et que nous
n'avons n'avions rien compris je suis
ravie de voir que vous allevez dans le
sens de cet amendement qui signale que
justement l'argent n'était pas là où il
fallait et qu'il fallait faire un peu
plus pour arriver à suivre si ça va bien
ou pas comme quoi vous voyez là en même
temps il y a des fois c'est
amusant monsieur alors Monsieur de
courourson et après monsieur le
rapporteur oui vous avez certainement lu
le rapport que j'ai fait sur les
préfectures puisque je suis le
rapporteur spécial vous l'avez tous lu
voilà
B
alors monur de cours s'il vous plaî oui
je voulais vous dire que contrairement à
ce que dit l'exposé des motifs de cet
amendement auquel je suis favorable et
bien les effectifs des préfectures en 15
ans ont baissé de presque 25 % et que
les deux missions qui ont été le plus
impacté c'est la mission contrôle de
l'égalité et la mission étranger et que
lors du débat sur la loi de finance
puisque ma mission elle a été examiné le
ministre c'est dommage qu'il soit pu
parmi nous s'était engagé a
réalimenter ses deux missions d'ailleurs
je vais passer un amendement en ce sens
et et contrairement à ce qui est dit le
le les moyens des des effectifs des
préfectures affecté au service étrangers
on ont augmenté de 56 % ces 10 dernières
années non non pas du tout pas du tout
mais sur le fond je suis favorable à
l'amendement mais il faudrait changer
l'exposé des
motifs alors monsieur le rapporteur
général V dire un mot avant qu'on vote
al je ne sais pas si on peut amender le
exposé son
euh je ne pouvais pas euh cher Sandra
rigole je ne pouvais pas tout à l'heure
accepter l'amendement de philiip brin
parce qu' il comportait une fie sur les
primes accordés au au préfet ça ce
n'était pas possible et par contre je
maintiens ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs pour le coup monsieur de
Courson a parfaitement raison euh non
les effectifs ont pas augmenté de 56 %
ils ont même baissé les 25 dernières
années et la Lop m met fin à ce
processus
vous êtes d'accord monsieur de
courourson oui vous faites comme ça je
suppose que cela veut dire vous vous
vous acceptez de de considérer que la
courbe monte et donc il y aura en effet
400 à 500 ETP qui seront affectés aux
préfectures là en revanche nous pouvons
je pense connecter à la fois la demande
de notre collègue et la demande de notre
collègue s il y a pas de contradiction
ma cher collègue qui vote pour qui vot
contre il est adopté le 1591 n'est pas
défendu
le
397 qui le défend madame bordau oui
merci monsieur le Président alors c'est
un amendement qui prend acte des mauvais
résultats de l'indicateur de performance
efficience de la formation linguistique
dans le cadre du contrat d'intégration
républicaine qui affiche un taux de
conformité de 63,9 %. cet amendement
vise à permettre au Parlement de
disposer d'informations fiables sur les
évolutions du niveau de français parmi
les étrangers admis au séjour en France
étant entendu qu'il s'agit là d'un
facteur clé pour leur intégration euh
effectivement il me paraît primordial
que des personnes qui euh sont
désireuses de venir sur le territoire
national français euh parle à minima
quelques mots de français de façon à
pouvoir
s'exprimer soit dans le cadre de leur
travail soit dans le cadre de leur vie
quotidienne il n'est pas pensable que
des personnes veuillent se maintenir sur
le territoire national français et ne
fasse pas effectivement un petit effort
pour apprendre quelques mots et quelques
expressions de notre langue
oui merci merci monsieur le Président à
travers votre intervention vous vous
prouvez que des chiffres existent et que
des donné sont public vous parlez même
d'indicateur de performance le contrat
d'intertion d'intégration républicaine
excellente mesure je pense l'avoir voté
dans une autre législature où je
j'aurais pu être là sur à côté en tout
cas de C c'était le cas à l'époque et
précisément l'objectif de
l'apprentissage langue française en fait
partie je parle sous le contrôle de la
rapporteur du titre premier Elodie jacqu
et Laforge qui interviendra dans
quelques jours nous allons renforcer
l'obligation de résultat concernant
l'apprentissage du français nous allons
être extrêmement vigilants et compris
sur la question du regroupement familial
qui est un élément proposé par le Sénat
donc ce sont nos objectifs mais
consulter le rapport de l'OFI il est
très précis il donne tout tous les
éléments que vous souhaitez voir porter
à la connaissance du Parlement ils sont
déjà connus ils sont déjà publicqus et
je vous informe par conséquent qu'il y
aura un avis défavorable à la fois sur
le 397 et celui vous présenterez
probablement dans quelques minutes
quelques secondes le 992 pour les mêmes
raisons
torign merci monsieur le Président donc
tout à l'heure je disais que ce texte
permettait au rassemblement ce texte
produit par la
macronie par le gouvernement ouvre
déroule le tapis rouge au rassemblement
national et là on le voit puisque en
fait le le texte les collègues du les
députés du rassemblement national nont
peut-être pas lu le le le texte projet
de loi qui prévoit un
examen nous nous pensons que
effectivement l'apprentissage du
français est important mais nous ne
pensons pas que le titre de séjour doit
être conditionné à l'obtention d'un
examen pour que les gens puissent parler
le français ben il faut qu'il soit
effectivement bien bien installé en
France avec un travail si possible bien
sûr en logement et qu'il puisse avoir
des conditions de vie sereine parce que
sinon on peut pas apprendre correctement
une langue et moi je vais vous dire même
puisque tout à l'heure ça a été on l'a
mentionné combien ici d'entre nous ont
des origines étrangères moi ma
grand-mère espagnole est arrivée en
France elle ne savait ni lire ni écrire
l'espagnol d'accord à la fin de sa vie
elle ne non l'espagnol elle ne savait
pas le lire et l'écrire et donc parce
qu'il y a aussi des gens qui arrivent
chez nous qui n'ont pas été scolarisés
voilà même même aujourd'hui en 2023 à sa
mort elle ne savait pas non plus lire et
écrire le français et il y a même un
livre qui a été écrit là-dessus que je
vous invite à lire c'est le livre de lid
salver où qui est écrit dans une langue
mitigé entre le français et l'espagnol
qu'elle appelle le fragnol comme il y a
le franglais donc essayz un petit peu de
comprendre ce que c'est que le
métissage que je vous disais tout à
l'heure nous sommes issus de d'histoire
de migration qui ont des millénaires
merci merci en l'occurrence c'est un la
partie du Tex sénatorial ici madame bord
oui alors je pense que notre collègue
torinia n'a jamais travaillé à
l'étranger quand on va travailler dans
un pays on il va pas pour faire du
tourisme ce que ce qu'on peut
effectivement faire quand on va faire du
tourisme on peut très bien ne pas parler
parfaitement ou pas parler du tout la
langue c'est compliqué mais on peut le
faire quand on est censé aller
travailler il vaut mieux quand même
connaître la langue parce que sinon on y
va pas pour travailler concernant les
observations de monsieur le rapporteur
j'entends ce que vous me dites j'entends
que les chiffres existent certes mais ça
serait quand même beaucoup plus facile
qu'il soit intégré de hipso facto dans
le rapport ça éviterait bien des
difficultés dernier point concernant les
chiffres j'ai bien compris tout à
l'heure s'agissant de Mayotte qu'il y
avait quand même une petite difficulté
avec les chiffres manifestement les
chiffres annoncés par le ministre
étaient pas les chiffres de la réalité
puisqu'il nous a indiqué que les
chiffres des MNA ne contenaientent pas
effectivement ceux de Mayotte ni ceux de
l'outremè donc il y a quand même une
difficulté avec les chiffres qu'on peut
trouver à droite à gauche s'ils étaient
dans le rapport ce serait peut-être des
chiffres entre guillemets officiels
monsieur rapporteur non mais inutile
madame la députée d'en faire des tonnes
euh regardez simplement euh l'alinéa 26
l'alinéa 26 de l'article 1era prévoit
que le rapport de l'OFI est joint par le
gouvernement pour le débat au Parlement
voilà devant le Parlement vous aurez
tout tous les éléments dans le rapport
je voix qui vot pour contre rejet le 992
Madame B oui merci monsieur le Président
cet amendement prévoit d'intégrer donc
au rapport annuel du gouvernement
j'entends déjà monsieur le rapporteur me
dire que ça doit déjà y être le nombre
d'étrangers ayant refusé de signer le
contrat d'intégration républicaine parce
que le contrat d'intégration
républicaine ça n'est pas obligatoire
c'est entre guillemets obligatoire pour
ceux qui veulent demander une carte de
une carte de séjour pluriannuelle encore
que c'est obligatoire mais il y en a qui
échappe à cette entre guillemets
obligation mais ça n'est pas obligatoire
pour les autres et cela permettrait
effectivement de connaître la part
d'étranger qui exprime dès leur arrivée
leur volonté de ne pas s'intégrer à la
République française si ces personnes ne
veulent pas s'intégrer à la République
française elles n'ont rien à faire sur
notre sol que ça vous plaisent ou non
elles n'ont rien à faire nous n'avons
pas vocation à accueillir tout le monde
et notamment des personnes qui ne
veulent pas s'intégrer à notre
République le rapporteur
défavorable rapidement monsieur
porte donc ok bon alors bien
mais au voix qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le 297 qui le défend
oui monsieur le Président je défends
l'amendement de de Monsieur Shrek ça
concerne le le coût précis de l'
juridictionnelle qui est alloué aux
avocats notamment déployer à la défense
des étrangers et ceux qui ne remplissent
pas les conditions de résidence
habituelles et régulières en France il
est important de connaître le coût des
frais d'interprète lorsqu'ils sont
assistés au tribunal et il est
indispensable que l'impact budgétaire de
la défense des étrangers
extracommunautaires en France soit
identifié
merci voilà après les avoir classés dans
des cases maintenant combien il coûent à
chaque instant de leur vie et en fait la
question qui nous est posée aujourd'hui
c'est quelle est la quelle est la
responsabilité de la France dans les
mouvements de population qui vont qui
que connaissent aujourd'hui que connaît
aujourd'hui la planète mais que qui vont
semplifié notamment en raison du
réchauffement climatique et en fait la
question n'est pas de savoir combien
coûte un interprète lors de l'aide
juridictionnel parce que ça ça
signifierait qu'en fait il n'est pas ce
ne sont pas des justiciables et ils
n'ont pas de droit comme les autres or
en fait à partir du moment où ils sont
en France il ils ont des droits et
l'aide juridictionnelle fait partie de
ces droits et à force de les
déshumaniser à force de les priver de
tout droit et de toute aide et bien vous
créez une des des citoyens de seconde
zone que vous déshumanisez par votre
action et à partir du moment où des
personnes sont déshumanisées et bien il
est bien plus facile d'avoir des actions
de haine et de violence contre eux donc
vraiment moi j'entends votre votre
idéologie raciste et cetera mais là il y
a une limite qui est que en fait ils ont
des droits ils ont des droits sur notre
sol et oui nous devons payer l'aide
juridictionnelle madame
Diaz oui merci monsieur le Président moi
je suis un petit peu perplexe depuis
tout à l'heure à chaque fois qu'on vous
demande de nous éclairer sur des données
vous nous dites bah elles existent nous
ce qu'on vous demande en revanche c'est
de les actualiser et de les joindre au
rapport de manière à ce qu'elles soi pas
contestable mais là on vous demande de
nous préciser dans le rapport quelque
chose d'important puisque il s'agit de
l'impact budgétaire de la défense des
étrangers extracommunautaires en France
et vous nous dites sans justifier vous
nous dites défavorable alors moi je me
demande pourquoi vous ne justifiez pas
votre avis
défavorable je veux dire c'est assez
surprenant ça vous intéresse pas de
savoir combien ça coûte au P les
dispositifs qu'on est en train de vous
demander donc je suis assez surprise et
je vous demande d'argumenter de nous
expliquer pourquoi vous ne souhaitez pas
connaître l'impact budgétaire de la
défense d'étrangè qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le 310 qui le défend
madame bord oui merci monsieur le
Président cet
amendement vise à compléter l'alinéa 19
par les mots et leur nationalité en fait
une politique ambitieuse de contrôle de
l'immigration se B sur une connaissance
précise du phénomène migratoire au titre
européen on compte
331400 franchissements irréguliers de
frontières un chiffre en de 66 % par
rapport à 2021 les personnes sommées de
quitter le territoire de l'Union
Européenne étaient essentiellement
originaire d'Algérie du Maroc et du
Pakistan ces données ne permettent
néanmoins pas d'avoir une vision précise
et on a besoin d'une vision précise de
la situation en France afin que la
France puisse prendre des mesures
adéquates pour contrôler l'immigration
illégale il est donc nécessaire
d'identifier les pays d'origine des
migrants illégalement présents sur notre
territoire alors je j'ajoute euh avant
que sur mon extrême gauche euh je
n'entends de certaines choses que j'ai
déjà entendu que euh c'est un amendement
raciste et que sais-je encore que les
débats les débats auxquels nous
assistons donnent l'impression quand
même d'opposer et ils se reconnaîtront
les prétendus humanistes qui veulent
tout donner à tout le monde sansm ni
contrôle c'est un peu open bar et
surtout et surtout avec des fonds et
surtout avec des fonds publ opposé donc
ces prétendus humanistes au rétrograde
au racistes mais vous n'êtes pas vous
nêtes pas chers collègues de l'extrême
gauche des parangons de vertu vous avez
notamment vous avez notamment un racisme
extrêmement sélectif parce que le
racisme antiblanc qui existe vous vous
n'en parlez pas vous n'en parlez jamais
de la même façon que vous avez des
combats extrêmement sélectifs vous avez
des marches des défenses des marches
pour les droits des femmes j'y souscrit
totalement mais on ne vous a pas vu on
ne vous a pas vu je répète on ne vous a
pas vu ni entendu sur la défense de
droits de ces jeunes filles et de ces
jeunes femmes et de ces femmes violé par
vos amis du Hamas c'est extrêmement
terminé monsieur le
rapporteurforable défavorable monsieur
alors franchement je vous invite à la
concision parce que ça va faire 1h3
qu'on a le même débat donc monsieur
carbra allez-y et et la concision elle
vaut pour tout le monde he monsieur vous
en faites pas c'est pour les
présentateurs d'amendement comme pour
ceux qui y répondent allez-y monsieur
cabrat moi je suis pas du genre concis
mais je vais essayer de faire un effort
pour vous faire plaisir monsieur le
Président moi quand même on vient de
passer un moment de débat et ça va
continuer parce que nous sommes sur un
rapport pour avoir des chiffres annuels
donc en réalité le RN mais tout ce
qu'ils ont envie mettre la nationalité
le nombre deqtf et ceci et cela en fait
ça montre juste quelque chose ces
personnes n'ont pas travaillé vous ne
travaillez pas vu que vous ne croyez pas
dans la recherche vous ne prenez pas les
travaux que font les chercheurs que font
François eran vous ne croyez même pas
les chiffres du ministère de l'Intérieur
vous ne croyez pas les chiffres qui sont
donnés par votre propre camp en fait ça
à se demander c'est à se demander si
avoir des chiffres vous est vraiment
utile vous allez les contester en ce qui
con concerne le droit que vous avez
attaqué avant bah vous montrez que vous
êtes contre l'État de droit contre le
droit aux étrangers contre le droit
conventionnel alors vous voulez sortir
des traités concernant le droit des
personnes pas le traité concernant la
finance sur la langue vous dites qu'il
faut un taux d'efficience dans mon
patelin où j'étais où j'ai grandi les
les paisants de mon coin disaient les
étrangers ils parlent mieux français que
nous donc bon vous voyez et je pense
vraiment que en plus quand on voit
certaines de vos propositions de loi ou
certains de vos textes dans les niches
parle aire il y a des étrangers qui
feraient bien mieux pour être vraiment
plus sérieux là sur la nationalité on a
les chiffres ça sert juste à votre
politique à dire regardez c'est des
Algériens des Marocains des Pakistanais
soit des Arabes donc en gros vous faites
juste preuve d'islamophobie pure et dur
mais on n'est pas étonné donc aucun
intérêt et je nous on vota contre
Monsieur
nel merci Monsieur le présent très très
rapidement en réalité il il y a un vrai
débat qui qui se pose sur cette question
question là ça veut dire qu' on peut
alors peut-être pas exactement citer
comme ça et et peut-être pas dans le
cadre de de cette de cet amendement là
mais réfléchir à avoir des orientations
des connaissances des statistiques par
nationalité pourquoi parce que demain ça
peut nous permettre de prendre des
décisions diplomatiques avec certains
certains pays qui seront en lien avec le
nombre d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière qu'on a dans notre pays et
des fois même enlever certains
stéréotypes qu'on a moi je prends
l'exemple j'ai récemment visiter une une
prison la majorité des délinquants qui
étaient dans cette prison et qui étaient
en situation irrégulière étaient des
étrangers qui venaient de pays européens
non pas de pays subsahariens ou
africains comme on aurait pu avoir comme
certains auraient pu tenter tenter de de
le dire mais d'Europe et je pense que
c'est important de d'avoir cette
connaissance par nationalité sans aucune
connotation raciste mais juste pour
avoir une connaissance plus approfondie
et monsieur le rapporteur avant qu'on
vote mais une précision lorsque par
exemple une personne en situation
irrégulière s'inscrit à l'aide médicale
d'État nous en connaissons la
nationalité elle est bien en situation
irrégulière lorsque quand je dis que
nous avons toute une série de données
déjà existantes c'est le cas par exemple
pour l'aide médicale d'État dont la
nationalité de chaque ressortissant est
bien sûr
codue qui vot pour qui vote contre
rejeté amendement suivant le de
326 merci monsieur le Président alors là
nous allons vous demander d'intégrer au
rapport quelque chose en effet qui n'est
pas aisé d'établir mais au moins en
votant cet amendement vous vous pourrez
souligner votre
objectif de récupération de données nous
vous demandons de connaître le nombre de
personnes en situation irrégulière par
département alors je sais que c'est pas
facile puisqu'on a déjà du mal à obtenir
le nombre de de personnes en situation
irrégulière sur le territoire national
selon le ministère de l'intérieur ou
l'observatoire de l'immigration on
vaacirit on oscilerait entre 600000 et
900000 clandestins présents sur le
territoire national et donc nous ce que
nous vous demandons c'est d'essayer de
nous dire combien de ces personnes
seraient dans quel département donc en
votant pour cet amendement vous
manifesterez la volonté de connaître la
réalité et si jamais vous nous dites ah
bah non c'est pas possible vous savez
par principe par définition être en
situation irrégulière on ne peut pas en
savoir plus et bien nous considérons
qu'il s'agit là d'une fatalité de
laquelle vous vous accommodez fort bien
monsieur
rapporteur
défavorable madame
ro merci monsieur le Président on est
donc sur une longue série
monoobsessionnelle sur les chiffres et
les chiffres si on en parle un peu
sérieusement moi j'ai envie de parler de
ceux des patrons du BTP de la
restauration de ces patrons en général
qui rappellent qu'ils ont besoin de
personnes qui travaillent qui ont des
compét et que peu importe leur
nationalité qu'aujourd'hui vos
obsessions elles mettent sur la paille
des milliers d'entreprises et que même
le ministre de l'Industrie aujourd'hui
rappelle ce fait qui est très simple qui
est que aujourd'hui on a besoin de gens
qui sont compétents et qui viennent de
partout c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a fait
la grandeur de la France de faire venir
des intellectuels de faire venir des
savants de faire venir des gens qui
pouvaient faire avancer c'est tout ça
que vous rejetez aujourd'hui et enfin
vous parlez des violences faites aux
femmes les violences faites aux femmes
on est non nom et nombreuses ici à les
dénoncer partout à se battre dans nos
rangs pour qu'elles en sortent à même
demander des sanctions pour qu'ici dans
nos assemblées elles cessent et qu'il y
ait des sanctions contre en revanche au
rassemblement national elles sont
nombreuses les affaires sur des
pédophiles et des violeurs qui n'ont
jamais été pris en compte donc avant de
faire la leçon aux autres avant de faire
vous voulez que je donne les noms parce
que sont des élus ces affaires sont
publiques et en fait et en fait
s'il vous plaît vous laissez perd madame
regol merci et en fait quand on donne
des leçons on essae à minima d'être
propre chez vous c'est la saleté qui
prédomine et en particulier sur les
violen fa aux femmes et c'est scandaleux
d'instrumentaliser les choses ainsi
quand vous avez des personnes dans vos
rangs condamné que vous n'avez jamais
jamais ça suffit le BO vous répondrez
ensuite madame
Diaz vous oui monsieur monsieur le
Président permettez-moi
euh de vous faire part de notre
indignation vis-à-vis des propos que
nous faisons que nous venons d'entendre
on a quand même une collègue dans cette
salle de commission qui vient accuser le
rassemblement national de fait
absolument AB mais ce que nous
soulignons par ailleurs c'est qu'elle
manque de courage puisque quand nous lui
demandons de nous donner les noms et
bien là il y a plus personne donc
monsieur le Président nous sommes partis
parulirement surpris de la tournure que
prend cette commission même si en je
pense vraiment que de Laan nu on pouvait
s'attendre à tout mais là je pense
vraiment que ça dépasse les bornes bien
donc je mets au voit l'amendement qui
vote pour contre rejeté le suivant qui
le défend oui monsieur le Président
merci nous souhaiterions dans ce rapport
avoir des indicateurs permettant
d'évaluer la qualification des étrangers
ayant recours à des visas de travail
puisque madame l'a dit ce sont des
chances pour la France et ils ont des
qualifications particulières et bien
nous aimerions justement connaître les
et renforcer le contrôle et l'évaluation
de ses qualifications des étrangers pour
qu'il soit impératif dans notre système
de visa de travail que cela reflète
adéquatement les compétences et les
qualifications de ces étrangers venus
sur notre pays pour justement travailler
effectivement pour les métiers en
tenstion et puis que ce soit vraiment
fléché sur ces métiers là plutôt qu'il
ne soit pas utile à la nation je vous
remercie monsieur rapporteur ces
éléments sont évidemment connus madame
la députée défavorabl monsieur cignac
oui merci monsieur le Président on est
là dans un long tunnel insupportable du
rassemblement national qui nous apprend
en réalité deux choses la première chose
c'est que le rassemblement national peut
faire de de l'obstruction quand il
s'agit de de servir son son
idéologie et que plus savoureux
finalement le rassemblement national ne
sait rien des étrangers dont il se
nourrit pourtant à longueur de journée à
travers les fantasmes qu'il
instrumentalisent à leur endroit
alors le rassemblement national il lui
suffisait de faire un article
additionnel plutôt que d'aligner des
amendements à ce rapport un article
additionnel qui aurait pu consister à
dire que il souhaite tout simplement
tout savoir des étrangers pour mieux
alimenter les fantasmes et faciliter
leur trac parce que c'est de ça dont il
s'agit le but du rassemblement national
à travers tous les amendements qui
viennent d'être déposés ça c'est
précisément de pouvoir stigmatiser
l'ensemble de ces étrangers pour tôt ou
tard organiser leur trac c'est ça c'est
ça la réalité et chers amis du
rassemblement national vous qui vous
targuez de ne jamais faire de
l'obstruction d'être constructif et
républicain vous venez de prouver à cet
instant que vous êtes tout l'inverse de
ce que vous prétendez être
monsieurum
merci monsieur le Président non en effet
on a quand même sur le sujet une
question qui doit se poser c'est la
question de quel type d'immigration de
travail on veut la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui en France on a une
immigration qui est une immigration qui
travaille mais qui n'est pas venue avec
un titre de travail qui est venu
principalement avec un titre familial ce
qui fait qu'on a une immigration qui est
une immigration qui est sousqualifiée
généralement subie les chiffres de l'INC
montrent que 40 % des immigrés ont un
niveau brevet des collèges ou inférieur
que c'est 20 % en population générale et
que donc tout l'intérêt je pense de ce
projet de loi doit être de rattraper la
moyenne des pays de l'OCDE faire en
sorte d'avoir une immigration de travail
beaucoup plus qualifié et réaugmenter le
nombre de titres de séjour au titre du
travail et les diminuer drastiquement au
titre de la famille puisque on a
aujourd'hui des rapports inversés par
rapport aux autres pays en parti on l'a
beaucoup évoqué le Canada voire même
l'Allemagne qui fait que aujourd'hui
l'immigration est un coût pour les
finances publiques et non pas un
bénéfice contrairement à l'ensemble des
autres pays dans le monde et donc c'est
en cela que la connaissance de ces
données est importante mais en effet
nous les avons mais au-delà de les
connaître il faudrait savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait et le sens de ce projet de
loi malheureusement est plutôt d'ouvrir
les vannes d'une immigration du travail
sousqualifié exploité pour multiplier
les livreurs uberits plutôt que d'aller
chercher des ingénieurs
monsieur rapporteur oui merci monsieur
le Président je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire monsieur Dumont que le premier
motif d'immigration en France serait
l'immigration familiale je ne peux pas
vous laisser dire monsieur duumon que
le vous avez dit que c'était la cause
principale le motif principal je
rappelle simplement qu'aujourd'hui il y
a 108000 titres
délivrés pour les visas étudiants
108000 qu'il y a
51000 personnes d'origine étrangère qui
reçiv un titre de migration économique
pardon j'ai cherché le terme qu'il y a
14000 14000 mon cher collègue
ressortissant étranger qui viennent au
titre du regroupement familial 14000 sur
330000 titres qui ont été délivré et
qu'il y a ensuite 90000 au total
étrangers qui viennent au titre de
l'immigration familiale parmi lesquels
la moitié sont des conjoint français des
ressortissants qui viennent rejoindre
leur conjoint français donc voilà
essayons monsieur
non c'est du essayons quand on qu'on
parle d'immigration de parler de
chiffres qui sont précis rationnels je
sais bien qu'on a eu des conversations
des débats il y a quelques instants qui
étit intité intentiné irrationnel mais
enfin essayons de discuter de choses qui
existent s'il vous plaît sur
l'amendement qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le 521 monsieur Guiton oui
merci monsieur le Président donc cet
amendement il est très clair il vise à
avoir le chiffre exact des obligations
de quitter le territoire français
exécuté ça fait à peu près bientôt 18
mois que nous sommes dans cette
assemblée on est beaucoup de nouveaux et
ça fait 18 mois qu'on a à chaque fois ce
débat lors des auditions avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur daranin
sur les octtf alors d'un côté vous nous
dites les octtf on n pas vraiment de
chiffr exact par parfois le ministre va
nous dire qu'il veut exactement les
appliquer on a un garde des saut qui dit
que les TF c'est impossible de toutes
les appliquer on entend en fait
finalement 50 nuances de macronisme sur
ce chiffre qui sont les OQTF encore la
semaine dernière lors de l'audition sur
ce texte de Monsieur monsieur Darmanin
il nous a répondu que finalement c'était
faux qu'il y en avait beaucoup plus
d'exécutés mais que quand même les
chiffres n'étaient pas bons donc le
chiffre exact 6,9 deqtf exécuté en 2022
c'est le rapport annuel du Contrôleur
général des lieux de privation de
liberté qui lu dit lui-même moi ce que
je vous invite à faire monsieur le
rapporteur c'est c'est adopter mon
amendement parce que si vous voulez on a
besoin d'avoir ce chiffre pour éclairer
les débat de notre assemblée et au moins
ça permettra de de faire taire toutes
les toutes les les contestations négatif
qu'on peut avoir dès qu'on cite un
chiffre parce que c'est quand même
compliqué à chaque fois d'avoir des
arguments parfois techniques parfois
politiques parfois statistiqu du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui finalement
jongle avec les mots jongle avec les
statistiques jongle même avec des
arguments et nous dit jamais la même
chose sur ce sujet qui est pourtant
clair combi d'obligations de quitter le
territoire français sont exécuté chaque
année moi je veux bien entendre je tiens
quand même et je vais pas revenir sur
tous les faits délinquences qui ont été
avérer mais il y a quand même des
personnes sous octf qui sont des bombes
humaines pour reprendre les mots de
Marine Le Pen donc nous avons besoin
d'avoir ce chiffre pour savoir quelles
sont les exécutions réelles de ces qtf
sinon nous ne mettons sinon nous mettons
et nous continuerons de mettre en danger
nos compatriotes car il y a un nombre de
faits de délinquences et d'actes
criminels de personnes sous OQTF car
elles ne sont pas appliqué ça c'est
insupportable pour nos concitoyens de
voir des personnes sous qtf pouvoir
encore agir malheureusement sur notre
territoire monsieur le rapporteur oui ne
laissez pas croire que les chiffres
n'existeraient pas qu'il ne serait pas
clair que le débat ne serait pas
transparent le ministre a répondu il y a
quelques quelques instants il y a chaque
année 14000 14000 éloignements 14000
éloignements il y a 14000 140000 au qtf
si je prends le chiffre de l'année
dernière il y a aussi le le flux puis le
stock donc 14000 sur un nombre qui qui
correspond à la fois aux TF de l'année
et aux TF passés c'est plus que
l'Allemagne cela vous a été répondu tout
à l'heure et le chiffre en pourcentage
que vous indiquz tout à l'heure est tout
à fait juste il figurera dans le rapport
versé par le Gouvernement au Parlement
com il figure dans tous les rapports
publics il n'y a aucune difficulté sur
ce
chiffre madame monsieur porte pardon
merci monsieur le Président écoutez on a
parfois l'impression en écoutant les
amendements et les défenses des députés
du rassemblement national qu'on est un
peu sur ces news et c'est un peu
dérangeant d'écouter ce type de propos
mais allez au allez au bout de votre
logique parce que vous parlez des TF et
des
expulsions vos amis vos amis Autrichiens
d'extrême droite ont fait un déplacement
en Afghanistan pour essayer de permettre
au gouvernement autrichien de continuer
à pouvoir expulser en Afghanistan donc
ce que vous souhaitez faire c'est
expulser des gens pour les envoyer à la
mort c'est ça que vous voulez faire et
c'est pas surprenant parce que à
l'époque Julien haudou avait dit
laissonsles mourir de froid à la
frontière biélorusse une de vos députés
avait dit dans le cadre d'un débat sur
SOS Méditerranée on na pas vocation
aller les sauver en Méditerranée donc
assumez jusqu'au bout votre proposition
c'est de dire expulser des gens y
compris dans des pays où ils sont
menacés où leur vie est menacée des pays
qui sont en guerre où ils sont menacés
d'être assassiné par un pouvoir est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous proposez qu'on
expulse des gens en Afghanistan en Syrie
est-ce que c'est autres votre position
assumez-la vous êtes en dehors de toute
humanité et tous les débats qui ont
précédé le prouent vous êtes animé par
une haine viscérale des étrangers
surtout quand ils n'ont pas une couleur
de peau qui est blanche et qui
correspond à votre idéal de société suis
ménager
alors vous est-ce que l'on peut arrêter
de s'interpeller entre membres des
groupes je pense que vous avez
suffisamment la parole comme ça et je
vous la donne pour que vous ayez pas
besoin de discuter entre vous Monsieur
kbrat Madame bord donc c'est Monsieur
ménager qui parle merci merci monsieur
le Président je souhaitais quand même
revenir un instant sur les propos de
madame regol vous venez de profférer des
accusations qui sont Abes vous salissez
chaque jour un peu plus la politique à
la nupès alors on s'attendait vraiment à
tout mais chaque jour un peu plus vous
vous permettez des choses qui ne sont
pas dignes dignes des Français qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui et et et je peux
vous dire que le combat politique ne
permet pas tout ne permet pas de de
proférer de tels mensonges et moi Madame
regol j'ai juste une question à vous
poser parce que vous avez pas vous
souhaitez citer des noms mais nous moi
je vais vous en citer un monsieur
catnins votre collègue de la nupes qui a
été lui condamné pour violence conjugale
vous en dites quoi vous en dites quoi
ben le rapport il est qu'on ne peut pas
insulter ses collègues continuellement
et et ne pas assumer ses propos vous
êtes depuis le début ça va faire 4h
qu'on est en commission et je voulais
vous dire que l'enfer est pavé de bonnes
intentions et en fait avec vos
intentions en fait c'est la France qui
devient l'enfer qui devient l'enfer pour
les Français pour leur quotidien avec
cette vision immigration que vous
développez vous donnez des leçons de
morale depuis maintenant 3h vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que l'hospitalité
était une vertu sacrée vous dégoulinez
de bons sentiments vous êtes c'est
tellement plus facile en fait d'avoir
ces bons sentiments c'est tellement plus
simple de vous regarder le matin dans la
classe en vous dire on est généreux mais
vous en accueillez combien chez vous
vous en accueillez combien des mineurs
non accompagnés vous en accueillez
combien des immigrés vous en accueillez
combien la plupart vous êtes protégés
vous gagnez comme tous les tous les
députés ici de bons Sala vous vivez bien
vous prenez le vous prenez le taxi vous
êtes pas malheureux mais en face il y a
des Français qui vivent en face de la
délinquence en face de cette immigration
massive donc à un moment de la même
manière vous vous dites généreux mais
vous êtes responsable des morts en
Méditerranée quand il traversent la
Méditerranée quand ils meurent en
Méditerranée c'est parce que vous leur
laissez croire que c'est un eldorado
donc à un moment assumz assumez que
votre fausse générosité elle crée ses
meurs elle crée ses drames et nous nous
avons la vraie générosité c'estàd
d'accueillir ce que nous pouvons
accueillir aujourd'hui mais
malheureusement la France ne peut plus
en accueillir parce que excepté en
matière d'asile où il faut continuer à
le développer continuer à ir c'est ce
que nous défendons rassembl nationale
pour tout le reste il faut dire stop et
c'est ce que les Français en grande
majorité attendent bon ce soir ce sera
une minute pour tout le monde d'accord
je mets au voie l'amendement qui vote
pour qui vote contre merci Monsieur LAN
il est rejeté il y a que Monsieur Loman
qui a voté je vous rappelle le 331
madame Diaz merci monsieur le Président
un amendement très simple nous nous
voulons connaître la nationalité des
personnes ayant fait l'objet d'une
mesure d'assignation à résidence le
nombre mesure de placement en rétention
et la durée globale moyenne de ces
dernières monsieur rapporteur
défavorable monsieur
cabrat on a eu beaucoup de leçons de
féminisme de la part du rassemblement
national j'ai juste une question est-ce
que vous approuvez les propos de votre
Président Monsieur Bardella qui dit en
ce qui concerne les femmes afghanes qui
ne voit pas la plus value à à accueillir
les femmes afghanes en France parce que
moi je veux bien avoir toutes les leçons
de féminisme du monde mais quand on est
capable de gérer et de voir les femmes
en terme de plus value et non pas en
respect du droit bah écoutez moi je
m'interroge vraiment je crois plutôt que
la protection des femmes elle est de
notre côté pas du vôtre je mets au voix
qui vote pour contre rejeté le 355
madame Diaz
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
cet amendement vise à éclairer la
représentation nationale et les Français
sur le lien qu'il peut exister entre la
délinquence et la criminalité des
étrangers n des PL à nos collègues de la
France insoumise dans notre pays 63 %
des Français sont inquiets pour leur
sécurité et même 81 % des Français sont
inquiets pour la sécurité dans de leurs
enfants et 7 Français sur 10 considèrent
comme Marine Le Pen qu'il y a un
ensauvagement de notre société et les
derniers chiffres dont nous disposons
datent de 2019 il s'agit de l'INC qui
indique que sur les crimes et les délits
commis en France 20 % proviennent de
l'Afrique hors Maghreb et 37 % du
Maghreb c'est-à-dire que quasiment que
58 % des étrangers mis en cause en 2019
proviennent d'Afrique donc nous
souhaitons que ces précisions soient
apportées au rapport parce que les
Français ont le droit de savoir s'il
existe un lien entre insécurité et
immigration massive et anarchique telle
que nous la subissons
actuellement qui défend le 403 de
Monsieur bertolo
allez-y non
merci monsieur le Président je vais
défendre l'amendement de mon collègue
Berthelot avec cet amendement nous
proposons que le Parlement ait
connaissance du nombre de crimes et
délits commis par les étrangers sous
obligation de quitter le territoire
français en précisant les cas de récidiv
l'actualité tragique récente nous montre
que de nombreux crimes sont commis par
des personnes étant sous le coup d'une
qtf pire encore plusieurs autres crimes
sont le fait d'étranger relevant déjà
d'une qtf qui n'hésite pas à récidiver
le fait que des personne devant être
expulsé du territoire commettant des
crimes ou des délits graves et déjà
insupportables mais être en état de
récidive rend la situation encore plus
épouvantable lorsque vous apprenez
qu'une personne ne devant pas se trouver
sur notre territoire car sous le cûp
d'une no qtf est condamné pour des viols
et qu'ell récidiv pour les mêmes faits
voire pire cela est totalement
insupportable pour les Français il y a
donc un intérêt certain pour les
parlementaires de mesurer précisément
l'état de la criminalité chez les
étrangers est déjà sous coup d'qtf
pardon il y a même un enjeu d'apaisement
derrière cette mesure le fait d'avoir un
chiffre clair précis et indiscutable
écartera de facto les approximations et
nous permettra d'avoir un débat sans
tabout sur des points concrets ce
qu'attendent tous les Français je vous
remercie le 518 monsieur Guiton oui
merci Monsieur le le le président mais
écoutez depuis tout à l'heure nous nous
nous débattons donc d'amendement
proposés par par le le rassemblement
national sur votre rapport qui est dans
votre texte pourquoi nous déposons tous
ces amendements et d'ailleurs on en a
pas déposé énormément contenu de
l'ensemble du texte sur l'immigration
sur cet
amendement pour nous il est important
d'avoir les statistiques officielles du
nombre d'étrangers qui peuple nos
prisons notamment le le taux on on voit
bien depuis tout à l'heure que lorsqu'on
parle du lien entre l'immigration et la
délinquence ou du lien entre parfois
l'immigration les les mineurs non
accompagnés qui fraudent le système ou
autre autres autre chose si vous voulez
vous êtes gêné vous êtes gêné parce que
vous nous dites toujours oui les
chiffres ils existent par-ci ils
existent par là nous on veut être clair
vous faites un grand texte sur
l'immigration vous voulez selon les mots
de votre Ministre de l'Intérieur être
ferme sur le rapport avec l'immigration
bah d'ailleurs la la fermeté elle elle
commence avant tout dans le constat et
le constat c'est le rapport là que nous
sommes en train de voter sur ce chapitre
premier et donc nous nous voulons
l'enrichir du mieux possible de manière
à ce que et la représentation nationale
et l'ensemble de nos compag patriote
soit saisi des chiffres très précis
lorsqu'on voit que un/4 d'étrangers
peuple nos prisons nous devons
l'inscrire dans le marbre et nous devons
évidemment le faire savoir à l'ensemble
de nos compatriotes parce que lorsqu'on
parle souvent de surpopulation carcérale
et on l'a dit dernièrement au ministre
de l'Intérieur et c'est notamment le but
de cet amendement pour résoudre le
problème de la surpopulation carcérale
le prier problème évidemment c'est un de
construire plus de prisons mais de
d'exclure tous les délinquants étranger
qui peuple nos prisons car on
libérait 25 % de capacité opérationnelle
de place de prison donc nous demandons
par cet amendement d'avoir le chiffre
exact le taux exact et nous réitérons
encore ce propos d'expulser les
délinquants et criminels étrangers comme
nous le proposons monsieur housousin le
oui merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit de connaître le nombre
d'étrangers actuellement inscrit au
fichier de traitement des signalement
pour la prévention de la radicalisation
à caractère terroriste en effet alors on
a eu des chiffres par le passé du nombre
d'étrangers ficiés au fsprt il y en
avait 613 en 2018 et on n pas de chiffre
depuis et puis il y avait quand même un
petit détail c'est que ces 613 c'était
ceux qui étaient détectés comme étant ou
ayant été en situation irrégulière or
nous nous aimerions aussi connaître le
nombre d'étrangers qu'il y a qui sont en
situation régulière parce que nous
pensons que dans les personnes qui sont
fichées pour radicalisation à caractère
terroriste il y a un certain nombre de
Français qu'il faut surveiller il y a un
certain nombre d'étrangers qui eux ben
n'ont pas vocation à rester sur notre
territoire rapporteur sur ces quatre
amendements oui je voulais juste
rappeler à Monsieur Guiton que non il
s'agit pas de notre texte je pour
l'instant nous étudions le texte du
Sénat je tiens à le rappeler je parle
sous le contrôle de l'ensemble des
députés j'ai j'ai accepté de déposer des
amendements qui permettent me
semble-t-il d'améliorer l'article 1er
prier a mais je vous rappelle que nous
débattons bien ici du texte du Sénat
défavorable à l'ensemble des amendements
y compris pr d'ailleurs sur le tout
dernier les chiffres sont connus le
ministre de l'Intérieur a très
régulièrement l'occasion de communiquer
sur le nombre d'étrangers dans les
fichiers pour radicalisation le préfet
de police de Paris lorsqu'il a été
auditionné par les rapporteurs a même
signalé quel était le chiffre pour la
plaque parisienne les communications
sont très régulières défavorables madame
Martin texte du Sénat avec de nombreux
avis de sagesse de monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur moi je comprends la
difficulté pour le rassemblement
national parce par qu' effffectivement
le texte en lui-même est déjà tellement
xénophobe et véhicule tellement de
préjugés dégrade tellement l'ensemble
des droits des étrangers bah qu' vous
reste pas grand-chose à vous mettre sous
la dent donc du coup on assiste à une
surenchère absolue la simple chose que
l'on peut vous dire sur le sujet de ce
lien que vous voulez sans doute sans
cesse faire entre délinquence et
étranger en France c'est qu'en avril
2023 de chercheurs du CPI le CPI c'est
un un centre d'études qui est rattaché à
Matignon donc qui n'a rien à voir c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire avec nous
piloté par Arnaud Philippe et Jérôme
Vallette on conclut en faisant la
synthèse de nombreuses recherches sur le
sujet et ce depuis nombreux de
nombreuses décennies qu'il n'y avait pas
de lien entre délinquence et étrangers
monsieur Guiton oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
j'entends vos arguments mais je ne
comprends pas quelque chose puisque
c'est le texte du Sénat vous aviez
déposé d'ailleurs par notre président un
amendement de suppression de cet article
premier a il a bizarrement disparu donc
à partir du moment où vous ne déposez
pas d'amendement de suppression à partir
du moment où vous ne votez pas les
amendements de l'extrême gauche pour
supprimer cet article alors il devient
le vôtre il devient le vôtre c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est logique le le texte
vient du Sénat mais si vous s'il vous
plaît pas vous avez qu'à le supprimer il
me semble que vous allez en supprimer
quelques-uns non des articles du Sénat
et que vous allez pas avoir de mal avec
les voix de l'extrême gauche donc soit
soyez clair soit c'est votre texte vous
l'assumez et vous le votez soit c'est
pas votre texte et alors vous les
rejetez et vous supprimez tous les
articles qui qui vous incombent mais là
si vous voulez moi je ne comprends pas
votre argument il est un peu de mauvaise
foi où à mon avis il y a encore un peu
de macronisme qui essae de
s'accorder en fait pour arriver à voter
un article il faut arriver au terme des
amendements sur cet article madame
fillonro vous l'avez maintenant
merci bon il faut vite qu'on sorte de ce
tunnel des horreurs mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on va y revenir assez
assez rapide
régulièrement on a évidemment là tout le
narratif on a effectivement là tout le
narratif xénophobe qui consiste à mettre
un trait d'égalité un trait d'union
entre étrangers et délinquence et on
verra plus tard que ça va également avec
avec terrorisme la politique du du Bou
émissaire c'est c'est vraiment le fond
de commerce du rassemblement national
mais il faut qu'ils y ajoutent en
permanence un récit xénophobe à tel
point force de regarder l'humain
uniquement sous le prisme de l'étranger
il ne voit même pas en réalité que sur
tout un tas de délits et de crimes il
parle d'abord des hommes et des jeunes
hommes est-ce que vous considérez que
parce que 97 % des places en prison sont
occupées par des hommes il faut expulser
tous les hommes de ce pays ou alors
faut-il se soucier aujourd'hui et
particulièrement de ce virilisme ambiant
faut-il ou non condamner gros lardon par
exemple qui nous explique aujourd'hui
que ce sont les étrangers qui possèdent
les femmes et qui les volent au blanc
regardez plutôt cela à mon avis et nous
aurons réglé quelques quelques problèmes
dans notre société pas en regardant
d'abord la question de l'étranger mais
en regardant d'abord la question du
matchisme et du virilisme monsieur
housoussin
oui non c'était simplement pour revenir
sur la réponse de monsieur le rapporteur
qui nous dit concrètement mais en fait
tel ou tel chiffre a été donné dans une
audition à tel date lointaine en vidéo
on dit pas que le chiffre parfois
n'existe pas mais s'il y a un rapport
pour les centraliser et pour les avoir
chaque année c'est bien pour ça qu'on
demande à avoir des éléments dans le
rapport c'est pour qu'il soit centralisé
un endroit de donné qu'on puisse faire
des comparaisons d'année en année et pas
qu'on nous dise ah bah le 15 janvier
2012 dans telle audition il y a eu tel
chiffre justement nous on veut quelque
chose de centralisé donc que les
chiffres a été donnés dans des auditions
à l'oral très bien mais c'est pas
pratique al monsieur le rapporteur non
je voulais dire à madame ellisa Martin
qui va réapparaître je pense d'ici
quelques
secondes vous vous dites le projet de
loi initial du gouvernement était
xénophobe c'est ce que vous avez dit
ouais est-ce
que notre volonté de lutter contre
l'écosystème qui consiste à exploiter un
certain nombre de de ressortissants de
nationalité étrangère est-ce que c'est
xénophobe est-ce que lutter est-ce que
criminaliser les passeur c'est
xénophobe est-ce que lutter contre les
marchands de sommeil c'est xénophobe
est-ce qu'appliquer des sanctions
administratives à l'encontre des
employeurs voyou c'est xénophobe est-ce
que reconnaître un titre de
séjour pour toute personne qui aurait
subi prostitution proxétisme est-ce que
c'est
xénophobe madame Elisa Martin je crois
que si nous voulons avoir des débats
approfondis avec des divergences qui
sont tout à fait naturel entre formation
politiqu qui n'ont pas tout à fait les
mêmes sensibilités il faut éviter ce
genre d' thème en tout cas moi je les
accepte
pas bien alors sur le 355 dans le
silence a tant que faire pe ce peu si
possible alors qui vote pour contre
rejeté le 403 pour contre rejeté le 518
pour contre rejeté et même vote pour
1104 le 496 madame torignia merci
monsieur le Président donc ça va faire
3h qu'on discute euh voilà on parle de
de tunnel terrible
de de tunnel
d'ignominie de de propos abject euh moi
je rappelle chaque fois que déjà on
avait pas besoin d'une nième
loi d'une enè réforme sur asile
immigration bon la macronu l'a voulu
donc la voilà et en plus elle a été
durcie par le Sénat qui nous rajoute ce
premier article que nous nous voulions
supprimer et donc bon il n'a pas été
supprimé ce qui permet au rassemblement
national et à la droite de dérouler tout
t leur fantasme alors on a vu voyez on
est quand même les mots ont du sens on
est en train de réifier complètement des
êtres humains qui sont venus sur notre
territoire après des parcours
dramatiques des parcours tragiques dans
des condition terribles et là il est
question de faire l'inventaire des
stocks comme dans un magasin c'est
terrible alors donc c'est un amendement
de repli puisqu'il y a ce premier
article qui n'a pas été supprimé on
propose cette cet amendement de repli
qui permettrait de comptabiliser les
personnes qui dorment à la rue et
notamment les enfants parce que dans le
rassemblement national il va falloir
nous prouver maintenant que vous aimez
les enfants et tous les enfants que vous
n'êtes pas raciste puisque il y en a
quand même beaucoup qui dorment à la rue
euh je crois que on en dénombré 2822
sans solution d'hébergement faute de
mise à l'abri disponible c'était ce le
constat que dressait l'UNICEF et que
justement quand on appelle le 115 il n'y
a pas de de solution d'hébergement pour
tout le monde et donc il avait
800 monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président mais
madame madame torgia nous n'avons pas
peur du débat sur l'immigration comme
sur tous les sujets nous avons accepté
la proposition du Sénat qui consistait à
chaque année pouvoir débattre des de la
question migratoire nous avons des
divergences profondes avec le Sénat il
souhait fixer un
nombre comment dire très net vraiment un
chiffre annuel qui serait un plafond
nous considérons que ça n'est pas
souhaitable ils souhait nous imposer de
débattre ça n'est pas constitutionnel
ils souhaitent que le Parlement
détermine ces mêmes chiffres n'est pas
non plus constitutionnel mais nous
n'avons pas peur du débat de la même
façon que dans cette commission nous
acceptons les échanges et parfois les
propos avec lesquels nous sommes en
divvergence complète je voudrais
simplement vous dire Madame torgha que
bien sûr que les chiffres des personnes
qui sont appelées à dormir dans la rue
ne peuvent pas être connu avec précision
en revanche les dispositifs
d'hébergement d'urgence a été
considérablement augmenté et j'espère
que vous nous approuverez lorsque nous
demanderons la suppression d'une
disposition qui a été ajoutée par le
Sénat qui consistait à réserver
l'hébergement du urgence aux personnes
en situation régulière ce qui aurait
bien sûr jeté dans la rue un très grand
nombre de ressortissants qui aujourd'hui
sont en situation irrégulière j'espère
que là vous soutiendrez l'amendement de
suppression que je déposerai monsieur de
la porte non monsieur Loman pardon
monsieur de la porte après vous en
faites pas merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement vous propose de
parler des gens qui dorment dans la rue
et normalement on devrait pas avoir en
parler parce que en 2017 quand monsieur
Macron a été élu il a dit à la fin de
l'année plus personne ne dormira à la
rue donc normalement ça devrait être un
problème réglé depuis 6 ans et ça n'est
toujours pas un problème réglé pourquoi
parce que euh vous avez fait le choix de
faire une politique depuis maintenant 6
ans qui euh fait des cadeaux fiscaux
systématiques aux riches et qui
n'utilise pas l'argent pour euh le
répartir et faire en sorte que nos
compatriotes les plus pauvres euh soi
mis à l'abri tout à l'heure un collègue
du rassemblement national nous a dit
c'est c'est tellement plus facile de se
dire qu'on est généreux c'est plus
facile ensuite de se regarder dans la
glace mais vous savez c'est pas une
question de générosité c'est une
question de savoir ce qui fait de nous
des Français il est écrit dans la devise
de notre pays liberté égalité fraternité
égalité ça veut dire qu'on considère
chaque être humain à égalité les uns par
rapport aux autres qu'on ne fait pas de
différence en raison de la couleur de
peau de l'origine du sexe et d'ailleurs
l'article 1emer de notre Constitution
que vous devriez lire peut-être plus
souvent bien et puis la fraternité c'est
justement le fait que on essaie de
s'occuper des autres donc voyez-vous
finalement être français c'est être
généreux et c'est faire en sorte que
l'on assure la fraternité avec
l'ensemble de l'humanité vous nous dites
on ne peut pas accueillir toute la
misère du monde mais commençons par
faire en sorte que celles et ceux qui
ont beaucoup qui s'enrichissent sur le
dos de l'ensemble des Français et des
Français qui travaillent et qui
s'enrichissent aussi sur le dos des
personnes
qui travaill dans des conditions parfois
absolument déplorables parce que des
patrons voyou les obligent à travailler
dans ces conditions là commençons par
partager la richesse commençons par
faire en sorte que nous nous occupions
de ceux qui ont le moins en prenant à
ceux qui ont le plus et vous verrez il y
a bien assez d'argent pour que tout le
monde puisse vivre heureux monsieur de
la porte oui pour revenir à cet
amendement
important il a le mérite de mettre
l'accent sur une situation réelle à
laquelle nous sommes tous confrontés
dans nos circonscriptions est
possibilité de loger ses familles et je
peux vous dire à cand que c'est horrible
la situation de de voir et de voir
l'état dire son incapacité à loger des
familles des femmes avec des enfants qu'
on 3 5 8 11 ans ça c'est la réalité
aujourd'hui ils dorment dans des tentes
alors qu'il fait 0 degr donc ça je pense
qu'on doit être en capacité de le
mesurer et au-delà des appels refusés au
niveau du 115 parce que il y a
aujourd'hui ces familles qui sont là
elles ont arrêter d'appeler le 115 donc
c'est à minima 3000 familles en France
c'est à minima 3000 enfants à la rue
mais c'est sans doute deux voire trois
fois plus parce qu'il y en a certaines
qui sont dans des squats pour lesquels
certains on est en train de couper le
gaz aujourd'hui ça c'est la réalité dans
mon département on a coupé le gaz à des
enfant je mets au voix qui vote pour
contre
rejeté non non il est rejeté il il est
largement rejeté 24 contre 13 vous êtes
largement rejeté vous avez continué à la
main donc
alors Monsieur Lucas est-ce que vous
voulez nous faire une présentation
commune de vos 5 amendements non ils
sont différents monsieur le Président
alors
allez-y ils ont le droit deend merci
Monsieur le le le président alors que
nous achevons nous apprêtons à à arriver
au terme de cette première séquence de
de débat de remarques qui vont avec cet
amendement d'abord que le rassemblement
national cherche à faire entrer des
éditoriax entr entiers de news dans la
loi et dans un rapport gouvernemental
c'est prendre le risque d'ailleurs de
mettre la rédaction de cette chaîne au
chômage euh chers collègue mais enfin
j'ai entendu depuis 16h cet après-midi
que nous étions généreux partisans de la
morale humaniste droit de l'omiste bien
pensant angélique moi je vous le dis
très clairement mesdames et messieurs du
du Front national moi je préfère être
généreux qu'égoïste je préfère être
humaniste que raciste je préfère être
moral qu'immoral je préfère être droit
de lomiste que nier les droits humains
je préfère être bien pensant que penser
à mal et je préfère être un ange plutôt
qu'un démon d'où cet amendement qui vise
à reconnaître la situation particulière
des travailleurs des saisonniers de
celles et ceux à qui vous daignez des
droits et leur dignité étrangers qui
travaillent et qui sont autant si ce
n'est plus que d'autres victimes de la
précarité des accidents du travail des
souffrances au travail voilà ce dont il
faudrait parler plutôt que vos fantasmes
et vos
délires rapporteur
alors être un an je suis pas
certain les autres les autres je sais
pas il faut en discuter non mais je je
m'interroge sur l'intérêt de votre je je
comprends bien le fond et vous l'avez
d'ailleurs très bien explicité mais
pourquoi spécifiquement sur les
ressortissants de nationalité étrangère
la question des décès au travail la
question des accidents du travail non
mais pourquoi je je je pense que c'est
une préoccupation qu'on doit avoir pour
pour chacun et pour chacune donc pour
cette raison je je j'émettrai un avis
défavorable monsieur
porte merci monsieur le Président
pourquoi cet amendement de Monsieur
Lucas est très juste parce que on a un
certain nombre de travailleurs notamment
saisonniers qui sont exploités et on a
eu récemment notamment dans les vignes
en Champagne des accidents mortels de
plusieurs saisonniers et quand on sait
que c'est ça représente 100000 personnes
donc une majorité par exemple de
personnes qui sont issues de Pologne ou
de Bulgarie qui décèdent avec des
semaines de travail parfois qui explos
et aujourd'hui on a des gens qui sont en
train d'exploiter euh des travailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'on demande que cet
amendement euh puisse tenir compte de
cette situation et pour qu'on ait des
moyens pour lutter contre ça parce que
je remarque encore une fois que quand il
s'agit de déposer des amendements pour
cibler euh les étrangers pour faire des
liens absolument odieux entre
immigration délinquence insécurité pour
demander un certain nombre de
d'indicateur presque vous voudrez pusser
les gens pour les contrôler à l'instanté
quand il s'agit euh de gens qui sont
exploités vous avez même fait une
proposition pour que ce soit que les
jours de repos soient décalés dans les
vignes de champagne alors que la
situation est absolument catastrophique
donc l'extrême droite est toujours la
même en vérité quand il s'agit d'être du
côté du capital et du patronat elle se
range toujours du côté de celles et ceux
qui exploitent la misère du monde
monsieur de la
porte pauvre George marché doit se
retourner dans sa
tombe merci Président il est bientôt
l'heure de la pause et nous allons aller
manger nous allons aller manger dans
certains restaurants dans lesquels il y
aura sans doute des travailleurs
étrangers qui seront en cuisine et qui
voilà seront là mais je dois dire aussi
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale on n'est pas
exemple de tout puisque il y a
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée nationale des
sous-traitants qui emploi de la main
d'œuvre étrangère et je rappellerai que
dans cette assemblée il y a eu il y a un
an un accident de travail mortel et que
malheureusement aujourd'hui les
statistiques ne prennent pas assez en
compte la question de la National et de
la précarité donc cet amendement il a un
mérite c'est de rappeler cette réalité
cette triste réalité mais il a aussi une
nécessité c'est de mettre en avant
celles et ceux que nous exploitons et
que nous refusons de voirsie rapporteur
général contenu de votre déclaration
monsieur de la porte sur le fait que
nous allons dîner et peut-être dans des
restaurants où un certain nombre de
personnes en situation irrégulière sont
employé j'espère que vous voterez
l'article 41 que nous verrons dans
quelques jours maintenant mais
pour B dit c'est pas gagné c'estad ire
simplement pour apporter un élément en
fait ce qui ce qui me gêne c'est de
cibler uniquement sur décès accident du
travail évidemment sont des des sujet
extrêmement important moi je je verrai
plutôt l'analyse de la situation
socio-économique ou les besoins sociaux
vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est une
vision plus globale qui n'apparaît pas
en effet dans le rapport il y a un
amendement d'ailleurs qui est déposé par
notre collègue Gouffier valand qui est
1582 qui lui essae de d'aller vers une
évaluation plus précise des bénéfices de
l'immigration en matière économique et
sociale vous le voterez sans doute je
suppose mais peut-être que pour la
séance au lieu de cet amendement de
réfléchir à la question de besoins socio
économique la situation sociale
économique des ressortissants concernés
je pense que ce serait plus large et à
la fois plus comment dire plus éclairant
y compris pour le Parlement lorsque le
rapport sera déposé donc pour cette
raison seulement défavorable bon à ce
rythme là Monsieur rapporteur peut-être
qu'on arrivera au 4 bis dimanche dans la
soiré je mets au voix l'amendement qui
vote pour qui vote contre rejeté je
suspens ça suffira pour cet après-midi
on se retrouve à 21h30 dans la même
salle